foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the live
session by Infinity learn by SRI
chaitanya I am missed by a maths
educator and over here we are going to
do the complete revision of cbse Class
10 math so are you guys ready hello
Fatima hi Shiva hello um
welcome to this session I'm Audible and
visible to you just confirm in the chat
and let's wait for some more seconds and
let other students join as well so that
we can start with the mega marathon
session over here wherein we are going
to cover the whole syllabus of cbse
grade 10 math and we'll be practicing
many questions on the basis of the
topics
welcome to this session hello Krishna
welcome to this session are you guys
able to hear and see me properly just
confirm in the chat so that there is no
hindrance in our uh session hello Sumit
welcome to this session
so let us wait for some more seconds and
then we'll be starting with the class
after some seconds hello hi uh tender hi
janak welcome to the session hello art
craft hello vasavi hello vishu Rao
welcome to this session hello Ranjit
welcome to this session hi Gangnam
I hope I'm pronouncing your name
correctly welcome to this session
everybody hi vardan good evening good
afternoon a very good afternoon to all
of you yes I had taken your name Gangnam
bike okay so I hope you guys are good to
start with it hello Siri hi Aman welcome
to this session hi Lakshmi welcome to
the class hello Anu hello SRI Siri hello
ashwita welcome to this okay Tundra good
afternoon to everybody okay so I hope
you are good to start with this session
now this is a mega marathon session of
almost seven hours wherein we are going
to cover the whole syllabus of cbse
grade 10 math and obviously we'll be
doing questions on the basis of those
topics as well I'm doing good Siri I
hope you guys are doing good as well
okay so do something for that Tushar if
you want to attend this session hello
jadugar hello laksh welcome to this
session okay so let's start with this
session guys so see I had taken the
things topic wise right for example you
will not be able to see the name of the
chapter but obviously every topic which
is there in your syllabus I had taken
them so you don't have to bother about
that hello hi sanvi welcome to this
session hello vasavi
hello Army here welcome to this session
hi Tushar good evening good afternoon
not evening it is okay so let's start
with it guys the very first topic
according to your syllabus the
fundamental theorem of arithmetic you
people already know this again I'm
saying it's not that you're doing it for
the first time you're going to have your
board exams on the 21st that is the day
after tomorrow so therefore we'll try to
do these things quickly okay
so the fundamental theorem of arithmetic
over here right so every composite
number can be expressed as a product of
primes apart from the order in which the
prime factors occur and this prime
factorization is unique so you can take
a very simple number for example 18 so
18 is what guys it is 2 into 3 into 3 9
2's are 18 right so this factorization
is unique apart from the order in which
the prime factors occur it means that
the order can be anything you can write
it like this
if you want you can write it like this
right the order of prime factors cannot
change but this factorization is unique
it means 3 is coming 2 times and 2 will
come one time you cannot have any other
prime factor over here and also if three
is two times it will remain two times
only if two is one time it will remain
one time only but order can change order
can change because multiplication is
both commutative as well as associative
so every composite number can be
expressed as a product of primes and
this factorization is unique apart from
the order in which the prime factors
occur so any doubt in the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic guys
hello Hari sharan welcome to this
session
okay Siri welcome to this session
okay we are doing over here for cbse
grade 10 maths we will concentrate on
that only Hello Kareem no this is not
cut this is your syllabus hi jadugar
hello grish so tell me any doubt in this
in the fundamental theorem of arithmetic
hello Girish welcome to this session
hello Shivam vlogs
hello ranjita hello Siri so please
confirm in the chat quickly so that we
can move on to the next topic and
obviously we'll be doing questions as
well so instead of talking about
anything which is not related to your
studies
it will waste your time only okay hi
arav hello shanmukh welcome to this
session hello srinivasra welcome to this
session hello Aman hello pankaj
hello saloni welcome to this session
okay so this is the fundamental theorem
of arithmetic now the second thing is
greatest common divisor or the highest
common factor so you know how to find
the greatest common divisor or the
highest common factor so I am taking an
example over here suppose you have got a
number I am taking in the prime
factorized form okay suppose it's prime
factorization is some something like
this and I'm taking another number over
here suppose it is something like this
okay so I have to find the highest
common factor or the greatest common
divisor of these two numbers over here
so hcf will be what guys it is the
highest common factor so the very first
thing is you have to take common prime
factor over here so common prime factors
over here are two three and five just
suppose I must taking over here seven
square as well just suppose so you just
have to take common prime factors so 2 3
and 5 and you have to take the smallest
power of each of the common prime factor
it means two you will take and over here
also you will take two and over here you
have to take one so this is the hcf of
these two numbers any doubt in the hcf
guys now what is the least common
multiple that is LCM in LCM you don't
need to take the common prime factor
only you have to take every prime factor
involved in both the numbers so every
prime factor involved in both the
numbers are 2 3 5 and seven you have to
take every prime factor involved in both
the numbers and you have to take the
highest power so highest power of 2 is 3
over here of three it is 5 of 5 it is
three and of seven it is two you got it
guys so that's how you find the hcf and
LCM any doubt in that guys exactly thank
you Salman
session on you know you they when it
will be live after this session
obviously it will be there on YouTube it
will be there on the do on the infinity
learn class 9 and 10 YouTube channel so
any doubt in this thing guys very simple
thing it is you have to find the hcf and
LCM I hope it is clear to you hello
surender welcome to this session
so very simple topic so I had explained
using this question only hcf and LCM so
sometimes if you see gcd that is the
greatest common divisor so don't get
confused that oh my God what is this gcd
means highest common factor only so I
hope it is clear to you right so LCM and
hcf we had discussed using that question
now there is a concept relationship
between hcf and LCM of two numbers right
so if you take any two numbers A and B
if you take any two numbers A and B
the product of hcf and LCM of these two
numbers
is every time equal to the product of
numbers itself you got it the product of
the hcf and LCM of two numbers is every
time equal to the product of the numbers
itself
I mean and this is only for two numbers
don't think that it's for every like
three numbers also no for three numbers
there is a different relation it is not
there in your cbse grade 10 math
syllabus although it is given uh on the
last page of your ncert but it is not
asked in examination so for two numbers
the product of their hcf and LCM is
equal to product of the numbers itself
Now One More Concept is there I am
asking a question suppose LCM of two
numbers suppose LCM of two numbers is
300.
and hcf is equal to suppose I'm taking
27 so is this true can this situation
happen that at LCM of two numbers is 300
and hcf is 27 can this situation happen
is this situation true
tell me guys
they when we have done many questions on
the infinity learn class 9 and 10
YouTube Channel please check out the
board brahmaster series wherein we
practice many questions after that we
did Sprint sessions wherein we practice
sample papers and we did many a two
three mentee quizzes as well yesterday
itself I had taken many good questions
from 6 30 to 8 30 PM you can check the
channel
so this situation is not correct because
LCM is every time a multiple of hcf okay
LCM will every time be a multiple of hcf
or you can say hcf should be
a factor of the LCM every time is this
situation clear to everybody over here
exactly so objective question can be
asked on the basis of this concept that
LCM is every time a multiple of hcf or
hcf is a multiple of LCM any doubt in
this thing guys tell me
obviously you you can get the PDF of
every session from the telegram Channel
please uh subscribe to the telegram
Channel and of all the previous sessions
you can access the PDFs over there as
well
hello Arena Rani welcome to this session
okay so this was the thing over here
hello Tushar
now this thing is asked many a times in
the examination see the very first thing
is you have to prove suppose root 3 and
irrational number root 5 and irrational
number root 7 and irrational number
so I am assuming that this thing you
already know right
I am assuming that this thing you
already know that how to prove
a non-perfect square number square root
of a non-perfect square number and
irrational MRI you have you do it by
proof by contradiction
any doubt in that
will do those questions as well don't
bother see if you are over here please
have faith in me I will take those
questions as well but obviously you
cannot say that in in this session I
will take all the questions which are
there in your books it is not possible
now I hope you understand that Tushar
therefore I will not be able to take
your question doubts the reason being if
I do that it will take 12 hours to wrap
up this session
is it okay or not if I do that hello
hanisha welcome to this session telegram
channel is given in the description of
this video you can click on the link
there
uh Gangnam bike okay
hello SRI rajneesh
logarithm is not in the syllabus of
grade 10 cbse math okay so this thing
I'm assuming that you know how to prove
these things as an irrational number but
suppose this type of question is given
to you it is given that root 5 is an
irrational number you don't have to
separately prove root 5 and irrational
number okay so what you will do you will
assume this to be a rational number
assume this to be a rational number so
this is equal to P by Q where p and Q
are integers p and Q are integers
and Q is not equal to 0 right
you are assuming this to be a rational
number where p and Q are integers and Q
is not equal to 0. so what you will do
you will separate root 5 on one side of
this thing so I can write P by Q is
equal to minus 6 over here so can I not
say it is p minus 6 Q by Q over here now
can I take 7 in the denominator over
here so root 5 is equal to P minus 6 Q
upon 7 Q over here right now you see we
have already assumed p and Q as integers
right so you see p as in p is an integer
Q is an integer so therefore P minus 6 Q
is also an integer Ok p minus 6 Q is
also an integer in the same manner seven
Q is also an integer and obviously it is
not equal to zero so this is the ratio
of 2 integers where denominator is not
equal to zero so therefore according to
the definition of rational numbers this
is a rational number right
but it is already given that root 5 is
an irrational number right it is already
given that root 5 is an irrational
number so what you will say this is a
contradiction that an a rational number
is coming out to be an irrational number
so you will write that this
contradiction arise due to a wrong
Assumption of taking 6 plus 7 root 5 uh
as a rational number hence 6 plus 7 root
5 is an irrational number I hope it is
clear we don't need to be see it is not
compulsory in this case to assume p and
Q to be Co Primes
over here it is not compulsory to assume
p and Q to be Co primes you assume pn2
to be p and Q to be Co primes when you
will prove these things to be irrational
you got it when you will prove root 3
root 5 root 7 something like that to be
an irrational number then you have to
assume ratio of Co Prime integers over
here even if you will not assume them to
be Co primes no problem in that you just
have to assume them to be integers I
hope it is clear hello AK Chaudhary
obviously obviously it will be of ah
more level than that of a basic question
paper Shivam I hope you understand that
Tushar you just have to assume it to be
a rational number where p and Q are
integers and Q is not equal to 0 you
just have to simplify separate 5 root 5
on one side you will get it to be equal
to this right now this is the ratio of
two integers because p and Q are
integers so P minus 6 Q is also an
integer so ratio of integers is also a
rational number now this is a rational
this is irrational so this is
contradiction and this contradiction
arised offer due to of due to our wrong
Assumption of assuming
an irrational number as a rational
number is it clear
obviously I can remember the students
zoeb in those cases so zoeb is asking
one question I will explain over here
see I am not taking every doubt I hope
you understand the situation suppose you
are being asked to prove root 2 plus
root 5 and irrational number so what you
will do in this case
assume it to be equal to P by Q where p
and Q are integers and Q is not equal to
0 and then you have to square on both
these sides Square on both these sides
you will get what you can use a plus b
the whole square formula over here use a
plus b the whole square formula you will
get 2 root a b so 2 root five twos are
10 it will come and this is P Square
upon Q Square over here right T Square
upon Q Square now you see root 2 square
is 2 root 5 square is 5 that is 5 plus 2
is 7 so this is 2 root 10 that is equal
to P Square upon Q Square minus 7 over
here you can further simplify this will
give you P Square minus 7 Q Square upon
Q Square
now you can take 2 over here guys this
will give you 2 Q Square so root 10 is
coming out to be equal to this now again
you see p and Q are integers so
therefore P Square minus 7 Q square is
an integer and 2 Q square is also a non
zero integer so ratio of 2 integers is
an irrational number but root 10 is an
ratio of two integers is a rational
number but root 10 is an irrational
number so again this is a contradiction
so you will write that this
contradiction arise due to a wrong
Assumption of taking
root 2 plus root 5 as an irrational um
as a rational number hence root 2 plus
root 5 is an irrational number I hope it
is clear
crack
boards
are the complete I hope you understand
that only Hindi is not possible kashid I
hope you understand that saloni root 2
square is 2 root 5 square is 5 so 2 plus
5 is 7 or not saloni okay you people are
going to have exams after ah one day
right so I am assuming according to that
only now
in alphabet it will be given that A and
B are prime numbers okay Gangnam bike
ok so I hope it is enough for this now
over here try doing this one let me know
the answer over here I hope you
understand that there can be many doubts
Amazon I'm saying that again and again
but it is not possible for me to take
the doubts I hope you understand that
again
this session will go on for 20 hours
we have to do this we have to cover the
concepts and I have got important
questions only you don't have to bother
about that just have faith in me and be
with me for the next seven hours we'll
be doing everything over here I hope you
understand Euclid's division Lemma is
not in this syllabus Euclid's division
Lemma Euclid's division algorithm is not
in this syllabus so you it is given that
the LCM of two prime numbers where p and
Q
are prime numbers p is greater than Q is
437 so you have to find the value of 2p
minus Q
so guys you understand that LCM of two
prime numbers is what guys if if there
are two prime numbers so their LCM will
be what LCM of two prime numbers will be
their product or not you have studied
this concept LCM of two prime numbers is
the product of those numbers so that is
given to be equal to 437 over here right
that is given to be equal to 437 so you
can do the prime factorization of 437
what are you getting over here
so you'll get ah
23 over here you see so it is coming out
to be equal to 19 into 23 right and it
is given over here that P is greater
than q p is greater than Q so there is
no other possibility
that t will come out to be equal to 23
yes or no p is coming out to be equal to
23 and Q is coming out to be equal to 19
over here
any doubt in that
so you have to find the value of 2p
minus Q so this will be 2 into 23 minus
19 so this is 46 minus 19 and what is
the answer guys
it ah it will come out to be equal to 27
so therefore 27 is the answer any doubt
in the question
no its not like that this thing is in
this syllabus AK Chaudhary which I was
explaining
this thing is in the syllabus proof of
irrationality is in the syllabus of this
chapter okay
I had already taken many sessions now in
all those sessions I had already
explained that what is this syllabus and
we did many questions as well I hope it
is clear to you guys
ok now let us take the next chapter that
is polynomial so zeros of a polynomial
so zeros of a polynomial means value of
the variable for which the value of the
polynomial is itself equal to zero for
example you take a very simple linear
polynomial what is its zero guys so you
find 0 by putting the polynomial itself
equal to 0 right so X is equal to minus
1 by 2 is the 0 of this polynomial clear
X is equal to minus 1 by 2 is the 0 of
the polynomial the value of the variable
for which the value of the polynomial is
itself equal to zero now finding 0 for a
linear polynomial is very easy but
suppose you have got a quadratic
polynomial what will you do in a
quadratic polynomial a simple quadratic
polynomial I am taking and again minus I
am assuming that you know how to do the
middle term splitting so if you have got
a quadratic polynomial you have to split
it right you have to do its
factorization you will get X Plus 1 X
plus 2 over here
so what you can say over here the zeros
of this quadratic polynomial are minus 1
and minus two you can put these values
in the polynomial you will get the value
of the polynomial itself to be equal to
zero so you will say x is equal to minus
1 and X is equal to minus 2 are the
zeros of this polynomial so any doubt in
this thing guys
obviously we will do every chapter again
I am saying okay very good AK Chaudhary
it is not possible like that now we are
going according to the flow of ncert
right chapter by chapter will cover the
whole syllabus so you don't have to
bother
zeros is the see 0 of a polynomial and
we also call support you suppose you
take it to be equal to 0 it means see 0
of this polynomial and solution of this
equation they are same I hope you
understand that if you put that
polynomial equal to zero then you say
Roots then you call it Roots I hope it
is clear if you put this quadratic
polynomial to be equal to zero then you
find it Roots its roots so what these
zeros of this polynomial and the roots
of a polynomial equation they are same I
hope you understand this thing
now graphs of a polynomial so you see if
you have got a linear polynomial its
graph is a straight line if you got a
simple linear polynomial I am taking ah
suppose 2x plus 1 something like this
anything you can take it will be a
straight line but that is not as in the
examination what is ask in the
examination is
this thing right so can you tell me the
number of zeros of this polynomial what
is the number of zeros of this
polynomial over here can you tell the
answer guys
factorization of cubic polynomial is not
there in grade 10 cbse syllabus
therefore I am talking about that see
there are many things which can be asked
in mathematics but again please make
your agenda clear what we are doing over
here because everything cannot be done
in one single class now I hope you
understand that so you have got how many
zeros over here one two three four four
zeros are there right so why these are
the zeros because any point on the x
axis is of this form or not X comma 0
any point on the x axis is of the form
this and what is 0 this is the value of
the polynomial right this is p of X only
so this is the value of the polynomial
at X so therefore you will say one two
three four zeros are there of this
polynomial now can you tell me how many
zeros are there for this polynomial
weight you can ignore that figure
I was not able to make it properly can
you tell me the number of zeros for this
polynomial guys
number of zeros for this polynomial can
you tell that
see
please make your agenda clear I hope you
understand that
no three zeros are not there three zeros
are not there only one zero is there you
have to count those points which are
passing through the x axis only these
are not the zeros of the polynomial so
only one zero is there of this
polynomial I hope you understand that
only one zero is there for this
polynomial clear
only one zero is there of this
polynomial
okay now one more thing is there in this
syllabus that if you have got a
quadratic polynomial the relationship
between zeros and coefficients of a
quadratic polynomial and over here a
cannot be zero the coefficient of x
square cannot be zero otherwise it will
not remain a quadratic polynomial so
some of the zeros of a quadratic
polynomial is minus B by a and product
of the zeros is equal to C by a there
are many other things in this thing as
well which is not in the syllabus of
cbse grade 10 now there is something
called vietas formula which you must
have studied if you are preparing for
foundation and all that for ntac and all
that something called vietas formula
which is not there in your grade 10 math
syllabus right so we are just concerned
about quadratic polynomials some of the
zeros of a quadratic polynomial is minus
B by n product of the zeros is equal to
C by any doubt in this concept
foreign
that's what I'm saying we are just
concerned about quadratic polynomial
otherwise there is something called
vieta's formula the relationship between
zeros and coefficients of a polynomial
is there for polynomial of any degree
but in the syllabus of grade 10 only
quadratic polynomial is there yeah gamma
is deleted that's what I am saying
OK C over here so try doing this
question guys if you have got this
quadratic polynomial and its zeros are
alpha and beta can you find the value of
this thing Alpha by Beta plus beta by
Alpha
can you do this guys
find the value of alpha by Beta plus
beta by Alpha for this quadratic
polynomial x square minus four X Plus
thirteen can be anything guys you know
that right it can be twisted in any
manner possible
cubic is not there that's what I am
saying cubic is not in there in the
syllabus it used to be there in the
syllabus it is there in ncert but not in
the class 10 syllabus you are going to
have examination day after tomorrow so
why will you study something which is
not in this syllabus again you have to
understand that thing now
a Gangnam bike please understand that
this is for cbse only now
okay if examination is done that that is
very good Tushar okay very good let's
see if it is correct or not so the very
first thing is you will find the value
of alpha plus beta Alpha plus beta is
minus B by a b over here is minus 4 so
minus of minus 4 by a is 1 the
coefficient of x square so this is 4 and
what is Alpha Beta Alpha Beta is equal
to C by a c is the constant term that is
13 coefficient of x square is 1 so that
is 13 over here now you have to find the
value of this thing if you simplify this
expression you will get Alpha Beta in
the denominator and Alpha square plus
beta Square in the numerator now you see
you cannot find the value of Alpha and
beta separately so you have to
manipulate the expression in the form of
alpha plus beta and Alpha Beta only
there is no other possibility over there
so Alpha square plus beta Square can be
written as Alpha plus beta the whole
Square minus 2 Alpha Beta divided by
Alpha Beta I hope you understand that
now Alpha plus beta is already we have
got that is 4 so 4 Square minus 2 into
Alpha Beta over here is 13 Alpha Beta is
13 So This Is The Answer 16 minus
26 upon 13 so the answer over here is
minus 10 by 13.
I hope the question is clear to you
any doubt in the question guys
hybridgest welcome to this session
minus 10 upon 13 is the answer yes this
is for grade 10 math Jaya
any doubt in this question
yes minus 10 by 13 is the answer but
suppose in the same question I am asking
one more question can you find the value
of alpha Cube plus beta Cube all of
these can be asked in the examination
they are asked day in and day out can
you find the value of alpha Q Plus beta
Cube for this polynomial
hello Samir welcome to this session hi
himal
last FC again I am repeating
first you have to manipulate this you
cannot find the value of Alpha and beta
separately so you have to manipulate the
given expression in the form of alpha
plus beta and Alpha plus beta so Alpha
square plus beta Square can be written
like this Alpha plus beta the whole
Square minus 2 Alpha Beta just use
algebraic identities over here right now
just put the values of alpha plus beta
and Alpha Beta will get the answer
okay hello jangir welcome to this
session
yes gamma is deleted yes rupight is for
sure deleted from cbse Hello Anushka
welcome to the session ibts Army so over
here Alpha Q Plus beta Cube can be
written as Alpha plus beta the whole
Cube minus 3 Alpha Beta into Alpha plus
beta this identity you have studied in
Grade 9 math Alpha Q Plus beta Cube can
be written as Alpha plus beta the whole
Cube minus three Alpha Beta into Alpha
plus beta now Alpha plus beta we already
know that is four
so 4 Cube over here minus 3 Alpha Beta
is nothing but 13 Alpha plus beta is 4
simplify this expression you will get
the answer any doubt in the concept guys
tell me hello daksh welcome to this
session
hello sravani
uh yeah something like that only because
but I had only five subjects in my grade
10 examination back then okay I hope it
is clear hi daksh welcome to this
session again I am saying this is just
an identity Alpha Q Plus beta Q can be
written as Alpha plus beta the whole
Cube minus three Alpha Beta into Alpha
plus beta this is an identity Alpha plus
beta you already know Alpha Beta you
already know put the value you will get
the answer
you have studied this identity in grade
10 9 it is just uh Grade 9 math this is
just an identity there is no logic for
that I hope you understand that
okay now formation of a quadratic
polynomial this is an important thing if
the sum of these zeros of a quadratic
polynomial is s suppose and product of
the zeros is p so the polynomial will be
represented by this x square minus sum
of the zeros into X Plus product of the
zeros okay x square minus some of the
zeros into X Plus product of the zeros
but this is not the only polynomial
possible there can be infinite number of
polynomials whose sum of zeros is s and
product of the zeros is p
so over here I can take any real number
value K okay for example I show an
example
suppose x minus 1 is there and x minus 2
is there these zeros of this polynomial
are 1 and 2 right but is this the only
quadratic polynomial whose zeros are one
and two the answer is no there can be
infinite polynomial whose zeros are one
and two
there can be infinite polynomial whose
zeros are one and two over here right so
therefore you can take any real number
value over here so in finite polynomials
are possible
finding the zeros you will not be able
to find the zeros if it is not given
separately Usha if only suppose sum of
zeros and product of zeros is there then
why will you find these zeros now you
understand that hi bihari welcome to
this session
you got that logic Usha
OK so you can do this question on the
basis of that concept like P be a prime
number
the quadratic polynomial having its
zeros as factors of P you have to find
again I am saying that you are going to
have examination the day after tomorrow
so I am assuming that you people are
already aware of all the concepts to be
done in this chapter it's not that we
are doing it for the first time so try
doing this question let me know the
answer in the chat
so you have got p as a prime number so p
is a prime number what are the factors
of a prime number 1 and the number
itself the factors of a prime number are
1 and the number itself so the
polynomial will be what guys x square
minus some of the zeros into X Plus
product of the zeros but this is not the
only polynomial possible you can
multiply it by any real number K you got
it so from here C sum of these zeros
will be what x square minus P plus 1
into X and product of the zeros will be
P into 1 that is p you got it so
basically this is the polynomial but out
of the given options you are seeing that
you are not getting an option so you
have to manipulate the options
in the third option
if I take minus 1 is common what are we
getting over here we are getting x
square minus P plus 1 into X Plus p
so you see can I not say that third
option is the correct answer because in
place of K you can have any real number
but this thing is same as this thing or
not so can't we say that option third is
the correct answer
is it clear yes very good some minus one
product one no it's not like that Anita
in this question it's a prime number P
exactly option third is the correct
answer very good
you have to work according to the
options in questions like this okay
okay very good
now you see now we are doing linear
equations in two variables so one
question I have taken from graphs a very
basic graphical question maybe I will
not be able to find the exact solution
to it because I don't have the graph
paper with me but I can explain the
concept so you have to solve it
graphically for that what you do you
have to make its graph right you have to
make its graph
so you see the first equation over here
what will you do in order to make a
straight line you need at least two
points right you join those those two
points and you make the graph of that so
what you will do over here suppose I am
putting X is equal to 0 Y is 5. if I put
Y is equal to 0 x is five so can I not
say that I want I'll make its graph by
joining these points over here 0 comma
five and five comma 0 over here
0 comma five and five comma 0 can I make
its graph by joining these points
5 comma 0
and 0 comma 5.
yes or no
now in order to make the graph of that
equation 3x plus 5y is equal to 15 again
I want two points so you can put those
two points suppose X you are putting to
be equal to uh 0 over here so Y is equal
to 3 and if you put Y is equal to 0 x
will be equal to 5 so it is basically
five comma 0 and 0 comma three so the
graph is passing through 5 comma 0 and 0
comma 3 somewhere over here
so please forgive me for my bad graph it
is just a rough figure so I hope you
understand that this is the solution of
this graph solution is this common Point
only five comma 0 so you can say x is
equal to 5 and Y is equal to 0 is the
solution any doubt in this thing guys
tell me
hello Chef welcome to this session
uh obviously not in this session I hope
you understand that any doubt in this
thing guys to any student over here this
can also come in the examination
therefore I have taken this question
graphical method comes many a times
I hope it is clear
common point is 0 comma 5 0 comma five
is not the common point you take X is
equal to 5 comma 0 is the correct answer
you can put over here you see 5 0 5 plus
0 is 5 over here and if you put uh X is
equal to 5 and you put Y is equal to
zero you are again getting fifteen or
not tell me five threes are fifteen and
five so it means both the equations are
getting satisfied therefore 5 comma zero
is the answer hi Anil welcome to this
session
I hope it is clear
number of zeros over here we are not
knowing the number of zeros not not ah
OK you are talking about polynomial
number of zeros it depends on the degree
of a polynomial so suppose the degree of
a polynomial is n so maximum number of
zeros it can have will be n maximum
number of real zeros it can have will be
n
no it is not deleted from the syllabus
graphical method is there in the
syllabus I hope it is
we'll do many more things now pile don't
bother we'll do everything
see you are having examination day after
tomorrow obviously we are doing revision
of everything which is there in this
syllabus okay hello all
a mind series I hope I'm pronouncing it
correctly okay take let us take the next
thing over here
foreign
the conditions of number of solutions ok
so if you have got a pair of linear
equations in two variables so a One X
plus b one y plus c one is equal to 0
and you've got the next linear equation
in two variables a two X plus b 2 y
plus C2 is equal to zero so number of
solutions you want to decide see so if
the lines are intersecting it means
intersecting one solution or you call it
unique solution right one solution or
you call it unique solution they are
intersecting so the condition for Unique
solution or one solution or intersecting
lines is a one by a two is equal to is
not equal to B one by B two correct and
for coincident lines that is infinite
solutions coincident lines one line is
this and another line is on this right
so in finite Solutions the condition is
a one by a two is equal to B one by B
two is equal to c one by C2
and for parallel lines parallel lines
means no solution is there because no
point is common in between the lines for
parallel lines no solution is there
because no point is common in between
the lines the condition is a one by a
two is equal to B one by B two not equal
to c one by C two you got it guys
these things must be on your tips
speed distance and time correlation I
think it is not there in grade 10
concept hello Veera welcome to this
session okay and one more thing is there
in this which you must know
C
uh this situation of having solution
this situation of having solution means
that the equations are consistent okay
consistent means having solution so
whether whether one solution or in
finite solution the lines are known as
consistent I mean the equations are
known as consistent because they are
having solution and when they are not
having any solution you call them
inconsistent
inconsistent means having no solution so
when you have got a pair of linear
equations in two variables they are
having no solution then you call them to
be inconsistent hello chandravati
welcome to the session hi hey month
so any doubt in these things guys tell
me any doubt in this thing
dependent lines means in finite
Solutions there is another name for
infinite solutions dependent lines when
dependent equations
uh when you have got a pair of linear
equations having in finite Solutions
then they are known as dependent linear
equations as well hi pratik hello
FF gaming welcome to this session so any
doubt hi kulanu welcome to this session
we'll do some questions don't bother
hello Devi welcome to this session
yeah that is in the syllabus gaming so I
hope it is clear
so try doing this question on the basis
of these Concepts and give me some
seconds actually uh
higher devil hello famous welcome to the
session hi Phoenix
yeah it will not be deleted it will be
shared with you on the uh telegram
channel of infinity learn Grade 9 and
10. hello Prasad hi Rani hello famous
shots welcome to this session try doing
this session and give me some seconds
guys
foreign
Audible and visible just confirm so over
here the equations are inconsistent
inconsistent means that they are having
no solution so what is the condition for
inconsistency A1 by A2 is equal to B1 by
B2 not equal to C1 by C2 right this is
the condition for inconsistency over
here guys yes or no so a 1 by a two
is what five by two k plus 1 is equal to
B1 by B2 so that is 1 by K minus 1 is
not equal to c 1 by C2 that is one by
two k plus 1 right you do not have to
take this one because you just have to
find the values over here right so you
just can cross multiply and solve this
thing so you will get five k minus 5
that is equal to 2 K plus one so what
will you get after solving this equation
guys you will get K is equal to 2 over
here so therefore option D is correct
any doubt in this question to any
student over here it's a simple question
yeah
I hope it is clear
exactly
inconsistent exactly your right anju
hello yeshwan welcome to this session
okay
let us do the next question what about
this guys what will be the answer to
this one see we did many sessions on the
Infinity Run class 9 and 10 YouTube
channel we did the board Master Series
where wherein we had practiced many
questions over there we did Sprint
sessions as well you can check all those
playlists on the infinity learn class 9
and 10 YouTube channel High issue if you
want to do many many more questions
obviously in this session this is a mega
marathon session of seven hours wherein
will cover the whole syllabus right so
try doing this one if you want to find
the value of x plus y this is again an
important type of question over here
exactly correct hello nijam welcome to
this session hi issue
no Clarity picture how it is possible
devil hello Muskan welcome to the
session hi lucky so whenever you've got
this C the coefficient of x over here
and the coefficient of Y they are same
coefficient of Y over here and the X
they are interchanging basically so when
you have got a pair of linear equations
in two variables like this when you have
got interchanging coefficients so what
you do once you add them and then you
subtract them so obviously over here you
don't have to subtract because you have
to find the value of x plus y you do not
have to find the value of X and Y
separately so you can just add them what
are you getting after adding
332 X Plus y you are getting right and
this is equal to uh 996 over here so
basically X Plus y over here is coming
out to be 3. I hope it is clear so X
Plus Y is coming out to be 3 over here
you don't have to subtract in this case
although because you are not being asked
to find the values of X and Y separately
I hope you understand that hi zeeshan
welcome to this session hello issue okay
we'll do questions on the basis of
similarity of triangles as well Prasad
but obviously jayachandra when you have
got coefficients interchanging you have
to add the equations once you have to
add them and once you have to subtract
them add them and once you have to
subtract them when the coefficients of
inter coefficients are interchanging you
see in pair of linear equations in two
variables over here you do not have to
subtract although because there is no
need of that you don't have to do
subtraction of equations because that is
not needed because you don't have to
find the values of X and Y separately
you just have to find X Plus y right so
only addition will fulfill your purpose
why they will why is it so are you not
able to understand English hello
welcome to this session
okay
we'll do questions don't bother
ok so try doing this one and let me know
the answer you have to find the area of
the rectangle over here now this is an
ncert question only the area of a
rectangle gets reduced by nine square
units if its length is reduced by 5
units and the breadth is increased by
three units if we increase the length by
three units and breadth by two units the
area is increased by 60 67 square units
over here
is this screen clear to every student
please confirm hello Anthony welcome to
the session okay Rani
hello anju is this screen clear to every
student over here just confirm in the
chat once guys
hello Anthony welcome to this session
okay fine okay I was just confirming uh
Tejas please refresh once maybe
okay thank you for that I think it is if
it is not clear please refresh once
because it is clear to every other
student so you can please refresh once
okay
it cannot be zoomed like that now at my
end it cannot be zoomed like that please
understand it is fixed hello Aman
welcome to this session you can please
Zoom at your end you can see in the
landscape mode if you're seeing in the
mobile phone hello man welcome to this
session
okay see the area of a rectangle so
suppose the length of the rectangle is X
and the breadth of the rectangle is y
suppose something like that so area of
the rectangle gets reduced by 9 square
units if length is reduced by 5 units so
you've got its length you are reducing
it by five units and breadth is
increased by three units you are
increasing its breadth by three units
then its area is reduced by nine square
roots area is reduced by Nine area is
length into breadth guys now you have
got this equation simplify this first so
this is X Y plus 5x minus 5y minus 25
that is equal to X Y minus 9. so you see
x y and x y will get canceled out so you
will get 5x minus 5y
and that is equal to 16 right
I hope it is clear to you
okay I did a mistake oh my God wait uh
breath is increased by three units I did
five over there so it is a mistake right
it is increased by three over here right
okay wait so I'll do it once again
quickly
so it is increased by three units right
ah it is okay so this is three x minus
5y
minus 15 and that is equal to X Y minus
9 area is reduced by nine so you can
simplify x y and x y will get canceled
out so this is nothing but 3x minus 5y
is equal to what
6. so this is the first equation over
here what is the second situation over
here if we increase the length by three
units and breadth by two units so if you
increase the length by three units and
breadth by two units Breath by two units
you are increasing the area is getting
increased by 67 square units it is given
in the question over here so you can
simplify it and then you can solve it
obviously so it is X Y plus two X plus
three y
uh plus 6 over here that is equal to X Y
plus 67 so this will get canceled out
again so you will get 2x plus 3y 2x plus
3y that is equal to sixty one this is
the second equation right so you have to
solve this pair of linear equations in
two variables guys
you are not doing it for the first time
okay let's see madhvi if it is correct
or not I think it is correct so what you
will do guys you have to uh solve this
pair of linear equations in two
variables uh just check once if it is
correct uh area
reduced by five and breath is increased
by three okay
it is correct now what we can do we can
eliminate the variable y if I want by
multiplying this equation by 3 and this
equation by 5 over here guys so what
will I get 9x minus 15 y
that is equal to 18 over here is it
correct now over here you will get ah 5
2 is at 10 X plus 15 Y and that is equal
to what guys
and that is equal to ah
30 right so if you add these equations
over here so you will get 19x is equal
to what what you are getting over here
guys
323 so what is the value of x which is
coming out guys can you tell that what
is the value of x which is coming out X
is coming out to be 79 79 is a six yeah
so it will come out to be 17 right so X
is coming out to be 17. so what is the
value of y which will come so over here
only you can put 17 so this is 17 plus
3y that is equal to 61 so are you
getting over here what is the value of y
guys so y will be uh
yeah 9 you are getting so Y is coming
out to be nine so what is the area of
the rectangle guys area is length into
breadth so it will be 17 into 9 so I
think yeah it will be 153 square units
don't forget to write the units
correctly so I hope the question is
clear any doubt in the question guys
exactly we have got graphs as well we
did graphs already Emoji over here yes
153 square units only 153 if you will
write your answer is not correct now so
you have to make sure that you are
writing units properly you have to write
units as well properly is the question
clear
I hope you understand that see I am
assuming that you people are already
going to have exams the day after
tomorrow so therefore we are doing
questions according to your board exams
only right so I hope you understand that
see the only thing is if you understand
the equation this and the equation this
now it is your work to solve the
equations that's it I can also skip it
maybe I can just form equations and I
can see I can say solve it because you
already know that you are I mean you
already know how to solve a pair of
linear equations in two variables right
or not
I am there as well pratik hello dilip
welcome to this session is it clear
I am there pratik
combination of both of them anju I hope
you understand that
okay so I hope the question is clear to
every student over here now one more
question I'll take try doing this one
guys a two digit number is obtained by
either multiplying the sum of the digits
by eight and then subtracting 5 over
multiplying the difference of the dates
by 16 and then adding three you have to
find the number over here
you understand that now if I'll do
everything okay like this you will do
this like this you will do it will take
so much of time guys it will take 20
hours
I am assuming that you have studied this
now we are not doing it for the first
time right
okay
a two digit number is obtained by either
multiplying the sum of the digits by
eight you see that a two digit number
can be written like this or not 10x plus
y if this is the unit's Place date and
this is the tens place digit why is the
units Place digit and X is the tens
place digit so our two digit number is
obtained by either multiplying the sum
of the digits by eight so you take some
of the digits and multiply it by eight
some of the dates multiplied by 8 you
will get the number 10x by plus y
and then subtracting 5 okay you are
subtracting 5 as well so you can
simplify this this is eight X plus eight
y minus 5 that is equal to ten X Plus y
over here and I can further simplify
what will you get you will get 2X
you will get 2x minus 7y right minus 7y
that is equal to Minus 5 this is the
first equation now second equation over
here is
or by multiplying the difference of the
digits by 16 difference of the digits by
16 and you see over here we are assuming
that X is greater than y right we are
assuming that X is greater than y
difference of the digits by 16
and then adding three so you are adding
3 over here so you will get 10 X Plus y
over here right now you can simplify it
further and solve it so this will give
you 16 x minus 16 y minus 10x minus y
that is equal to minus 3 will get over
here
so what will you get over here guys this
is 6x
minus 17 y
that is equal to minus 3 this is the
second equation is the equation clear to
every student over here guys any doubt
in the equation guys tell me
equation is clear yeah I think 83 is
correct we are doing pair of linear
equations in two variables so what will
you do over here
I can multiply this equation by three
over here guys because I want to
eliminate variable X so this will give
you 6 x minus seven threes are 21 Y is
equal to minus 15 this is the third
equation so I can eliminate the variable
X over here so what we can do over here
guys I can do second equation minus the
third equation so what will I get over
here guys see 6x6x will get eliminated
so I will get 4 y over here and that is
equal to 12 right that is 12. so Y is
coming out to be four threes are 12. so
Y is coming out to be 3 so you can put Y
is equal to 3 in the first or maybe in
this only you put Y is equal to 3. Y is
equal to 3 and that is equal to minus 3
so from here what is the value of x guys
okay X will come out to be 8 if you
solve this so basically you are getting
X is equal to 8 and Y is equal to 3 so
what is the two digit number guys X is 8
and Y is three so the two date number is
coming out to be 83 any doubt in the
equation guys
obviously you can use any method over
here but obviously elimination I would
say is the best suited method over here
otherwise you can use any other method
Richard
it will automatically come shanmuk from
the definition of the question I mean
whatever is given in the question now if
you will form the equation according to
this situation given in the equation
automatically you will get that I hope
you understand that higher nawab but
there are many situations which can be
done using both pair of linear equations
into variables and many a times it can
run using quadratic equation as well I
mean it can be done but see if a
situation is quadratic
any how it will come out to be quadratic
you don't have to bother it will
automatically come up according to the
question now it is it is on the base no
no mentee obviously we don't have that
much time nitik
thanks Ravi
obviously no sahiti why there is no
purpose of doing that I hope you
understand that you can use any method
is all up to you if suppose no method is
given in the question no method is
specifically mentioned in the question
it is all up to you can use any method
possible
ranisi just understand the situation
a two digit number can be written like
this where this is the units placed this
is the tens place digit Now read this
situation a two digit number is obtained
by either multiplying the sum of the
digits by eight some of the digits
multiplying it by eight and subtracting
5 you are getting the two digit number
if you simplify this Rani you will get
this equation fine now the second is or
by multiplying the difference of the
digits by 16 and then adding three so
you're getting this two digit number
same to date number simplify it you will
get this equation right so you have got
a pair of linear equations in two digits
two variables Rani solve the equations I
am assuming you know already how to
solve a pair of linear equations in two
variables you will get X is equal to
eight Y is equal to three so the two
number will come out to be 83. I hope it
is clear Rani
fine hello lucky welcome to this session
thank you Swati
combination of both of them Sabrina
okay fine
obviously you are having examined the
day after tomorrow last last year last
year's I hope I'm pronouncing your name
correctly menti was already there
yesterday
thank you swathi okay let's move on to
the next question now we are going to
see the quadratic equation this standard
form of a quadratic equation is ax
square plus BX plus C with the
coefficient of x square can never be
equal to 0 because the if the
coefficient of x square becomes equal to
0 it will cease to be a quadratic
equation right this concept you already
know this is live session
ok
so try solving this equation by
factorization method and let me know the
answer over here guys
because if suppose it is already
mentioned in the question that you have
to use the factorization method so then
you have to do that there is no other
way out right
we should put the value of first
equation it is all up to you can put in
one or two it is all up to you vishali
if you are talking about the previous
question and get the same answer because
it was a pair of linear equations in two
variables pair means if you put X in
both of one I mean any one out of them
you will get the same answer I hope you
understand that hello Arnav welcome to
the session
what is reverse two digit number reverse
to date number is this Girish if you
have got 10 X Plus y then the reverse
order of it will be 10 y plus X OK
Girish
I hope you understand that Girish
only Hindi is not possible enough
because there are many students your
South India says
you can understand English right
3n it is given in the question ganta
okay
let's do this so how do we solve a
quadratic equation by factorization guys
you see you take this one and you take
this one right you take this number
eight you take 21 so multiply these
numbers eight eight twos are sixteen now
what you will do you will do the prime
factorization of this number over here
prime factorization so it will be two
age or sixteen two fours are eight
right so you want two numbers over here
you want two numbers over here whose I
mean by addition or subtraction you must
get 22 that's how you do the middle term
splitting guys so basically I've got
that number you see seven twos are
fourteen
twos are 28 and then six so basically
I've got 28 and 6 you see 28 and 6 is
working over here so can I take this
over here and I can write 8X Square
minus 28 X Plus 6X minus 21 and that is
equal to 0. so you see this is the first
group this is the second group out of
the first group you can take what you
can take as common uh
so you can take 4 as common 4X so 2x
minus four sevens are 28 or of the
second group you can take 3s common so
2x minus 7 will come out so this is the
factorization out of the whole thing in
the left hand side you can take 2x minus
7 is common you can take 2x minus 7 is
common you will be left with 4X plus 3
over here so what are the roots of this
quadratic equation guys the roots of
this quadratic equation are 7 by 2 and
minus three by four any doubt in this
question guys to any student over here
screen is two blur maybe there is an
internet issue at your end Shreya
prime factorization see that's how you
middle term split a quadratic polynomial
right you take this and this you
multiply the numbers do the prime
factorization out of this prime
factorization only you will get two
numbers whose addition or subtraction is
minus 22 so you see seven twos are 14
twos are 28 and three twos are six so
twenty eight and six is working you see
28 Minus 6 is 22 so that's how you can
do the middle term splitting you have
studied middle term splitting in six
seven not six seven eight nine and now
you are in ten I hope it is clear let's
see right now we'll discuss those
questions only we have which we have got
over here I hope you understand that
otherwise there will be no end to it
otherwise it will take 25 hours if I
take every question over here
then obviously we'll use quadratic
polynomial is the board visible to
everybody my name is Miss by yashwant
exactly seven by two and minus three by
four is correct
we'll do the next question lunatic don't
write the same thing again General
solution yes yes we will do that only
you see in the next slide only you've
got that your answer is there emoji and
lunatic please have please have faith in
me I'll explain everything which is
there in your syllabus it is impossible
that I leave anything which is there in
your syllabus please understand that so
this is the standard form of a quadratic
equation where a is not equal to 0 the
coefficient of x square then this is
called the quadratic formula or you also
call it the sridharacharya's formula
sridhar
siddhartharyas
formula sridharacharya's rule right so
that's how you find the roots of a
quadratic equation you write it like
this minus B plus minus root D upon 2A
where D inside this square root is
called the discriminant right this is
the discriminant why this is called a
discriminant because it discriminates on
the basis of its value you can easily
understand from here
that if you take this discriminant to be
a negative number so obviously this
Square inside this square root you will
get a negative number and up till
greater than you do not know how to find
the square root of a negative number you
will get something called complex
numbers which you will study about in
grade 11 only so therefore when
discriminant is negative then you will
say no real roots are there no real
roots are there okay and if you have got
discriminant positive discriminant is
positive so you'll get a positive number
inside a square root that you can easily
solve you can find the square root of a
positive number then you will have real
and distinct Roots real and distinct
means two Roots which are real and
different minus B plus root D upon 2A
and the other root is What minus B minus
root D upon 2A real and distinct roots
are there and you can see over here when
discriminant is equal to 0 that is b
square minus 4 AC is equal to 0
obviously you will see this situation
this thing will be 0 this will also be 0
so both the roots will be equal to minus
B by 2 a or not tell me when
discriminant is equal to zero then both
the roots will be equal to minus B upon
2A only
then you will say that roots are real
and equal then you will say that roots
are real and equal this is the most
important condition according to your
board exams I hope it is clear exactly
it is there in the portion hsg gaming
this is not a question zeeshan these are
the situations which is there already in
your book and you must have already
studied about that and it will come in
the examination the day after tomorrow
I hope it is clear
exactly sahity it is very important I
hope this thing is clear to every
student over here the things related to
quadratic equation
okay now let us do the next thing over
here can you solve this quadratic
equation guys
discriminant is useful to find the
nature of roots of a quadratic equation
nature of roots and obviously in
solution of roots as well I mean getting
the roots discriminant is coming that's
it
square root trick I mean square root is
also the it is already there in grade
eight so you will not get big numbers to
find this square root don't bother
rishit otherwise there is a long
division method you must have studied in
grade 8 using which you can find this
square root it is not there I mean you
will not get such big numbers it is 100
sure
they can ask Muskan obviously it is
there in ncrt now can you find the roots
of this equation
it might not look a quadratic equation
but I am giving you a hint that it is a
quadratic equation it might not look up
quadratic equation but it is a quadratic
equation only
because that is in the syllabus
exactly Muskan they can ask
motorboat question right now I will not
take although because I had not taken it
over here see I had already taken all of
those questions if you have seen the
board brahmastra series on the Dome on
the class 9 and 10 Infinity learn class
9 and 10 YouTube channel we did the
complete both brahmaster series we did
Sprint sessions wherein we practice many
many questions so you can please check
those links as well I mean you can
quickly go on to those things and you
can check after this session if you want
that's what I am saying be in this
session all of the things which are
explaining over here they are important
okay
simple concept it is a direct concept
formula
I hope
um
cello so you have to find the value of x
over here so see this is a trick
question basically if you will simplify
this thing on the right hand side it
will take too much of time it will waste
your time so what you will do take it
over here
take the expression having the variable
in the left hand side take the
expression having the variable in the
left hand side
so what you can do over here this is p
plus Q Plus 3x
minus 1 by 3 x and that is equal to 1 by
P plus 1 by Q they go this is a trick
over here now what you will do just
simplify take calcium this will go over
here
minus P minus Q minus three x
simplification I am assuming that you
understand guys and you can multiply the
things over here so you will get three p
x 3 Q X
plus 9 x square right and that is coming
out to be equal to P plus Q upon p q p
plus Q upon p q so you see over here
this side canceled out guys 3x and 3X
will get canceled out and one more thing
over here you can simplify over here can
I not take minus 1 as common in this
thing so only P plus Q will be left so P
plus q and P plus Q will get canceled
out now you can cross multiply what will
you get guys minus p q over here and
that is equal to 9 x square
plus three p x plus three Q X
over here now what I can do I can take
it on this side and then I can further
simplify so what will I get I hope it is
visible to you so this will give you 9x
square plus 3 p x
so in some questions maybe I will not be
visible to you but I hope this situation
the question is clear to you so 3 QX
plus p q you'll get plus p q and that is
equal to zero so you see this is the
first group this is the second group out
of the first group you can take three x
is common so 3x plus P will be left out
of the second group you can take ah you
can take q s common
so 3x plus P will be left now out of the
whole expression you can take three X
Plus p as common out of the whole
expression you can take three X Plus p s
common and you will be left with 3x plus
Q over here so what are the roots of
this quadratic equation guys X is coming
out to be equal to minus P by 3 and
minus Q by 3. this is the answer to this
question any doubt in this question guys
to any student over exactly what the
answer as well no minus P by 3 and minus
Q by 3 will get Vijay you must be doing
some mistake over there
no it is not like that bhavesha
otherwise I would have said
obviously I can speak Hindi in between
but it is not like that deep
as a cello clearance is it clear to
every student over here minus P by 3
minus Q by 3 over here
any doubt to any student over here
blue parts please explain
so see simplification we are doing just
we are taking it over here right and
then you see this part this group and
this group sort of the first group you
can take 3x common out of the second
group you can take Q as common so you
are left with 3x plus P 3x plus p take
it as common so you're left with 3x plus
Q so therefore minus P by 3 and minus Q
by 3 are the roots of this quadratic
equation I hope it is clear which branch
are you from
I am from Infinity learned by SRI
Chandra heratabad I hope you understand
that I hope it is clear
emoji
obviously around I would say
seven eight sample papers in every
subject you must have done by now
please refresh once yashwant I hope it
is clear now Emoji the second part is
clear to you now okay try doing this
question and let me know the answer and
give me some seconds I'm feeling cold
give me some seconds just give me some
seconds
I'm Audible and visible
okay so actually I was feeling a bit
cold
cross multiple yes yes in this question
we have to cross multiply and simplify
see if you have got up till here then
you can simply use factorization
factorization you know that already in a
emoji
oh my God just see this thing you take
it over here see this as a group this as
another group 3Q X Plus p q out of this
group take three axis common out of this
group take q s common so 3x plus P 3x
plus P will be left take it over here so
inside the bracket 3x plus Q will be
left that is how you do factorization
you have studied middle term splitting I
hope it is clear now okay what about
this question guys what is the answer to
this question
welcome to this session
so over here equal roots are there what
is the condition for equal Roots equal
Roots means discriminant is equal to
zero or you can say b square minus 4 a c
is equal to 0 equal Roots means
discriminant is equal to 0 b square
minus four AC is equal to zero now B
over here is the coefficient of x so
this will be equal to 0 2 into K minus 7
the whole Square 2 into K minus 7 the
whole Square minus 4 a is what the
coefficient of x square and C is one so
this into K minus 7 that is equal to 0
over here I hope you understand this is
the situation now let's simplify it you
can write 4 into K minus 7 the whole
Square I can write now 4 into K minus 7
will be there that is equal to 0 now out
of the whole expression in the left hand
side can I not take 4 into K minus 7 as
common so I will be left with K minus 7
minus 1 and that is equal to 0 you got
it guys so can I not say you can if you
can further simplify this will be 4 into
K minus 7 into K minus 8 over here that
is equal to 0
so the two values of K which are
possible over here they are 7 and 8. but
if you just see and you will say that 7
and 8 is the answer it is not correct K
cannot be equal to 7 over here if you
will put K is equal to 7 you see if you
will put K is equal to 7 over here the
coefficient of x square will become
equal to 0. and in a quadratic equation
the coefficient of x square can never be
equal to 0 because then it will cease to
be a quadratic equation so therefore K
is equal to 8 is the only answer and
that is the reason of taking this
question I hope it is clear to every
student over here exactly option C is
correct very good
C is correct only 8 is the answer I hope
it is clear to every student over here
any doubt in this question guys
very good
OK let us take the next thing over here
try doing this question this is a word
problem on the basis of quadratic
equations at T minutes past 2 pm the
time needed by the minutes hand of a
clock to show 3 pm was found rupee three
minutes less than this thing is T Square
by 4 okay this is T Square by 4 minutes
find a t
so again I am saying this is from ncrt
Exemplar only okay its not that I am
taking questions from somewhere
somewhere very different this is an ncrt
Exemplar question
where is the root gone
it means you haven't studied quadratic
equations properly where is the root
goons mean means what guys you can take
4 into K minus 7 is common so K minus 7
will be left over here and minus 1 will
be there this is taking common it's not
that you are doing it for the first time
now again I am saying the same thing
okay
I hope you people understand that
before that I mean obviously we have to
cover the whole thing now I hope you
understand that
okay so you see at T minutes past 2 pm T
minutes past 2 pm
the time needed by the minutes hand of a
clock show uh
3 pm was found to be three minutes less
than T Square by four so team in three
minutes less than T Square by four
three minutes less than T Square by four
and what is the time guys the time
needed by the minutes hand of a clock to
show 3 pm so you see T minutes past 3 pm
T minute is already crossed after 2 pm
so what is the time left for 3 P.M guys
tell me what is the time left for 3 pm
can I not say that the time left for 3
pm is 60 minus t because in one hour 60
minutes are there so the time left for 3
pm will be 60 minus 3 minutes or not is
it clear okay let's see if it is correct
or not tanu okay so let us simplify this
thing so T Square minus 4 3 is a 12 that
is uh six fours are 24
minus four T so from here we can write
it like this T square plus 4 t
minus uh
252 and that is equal to 0 over here now
we have to do the middle term splitting
again I'm hoping that these things are
clear to you you are not doing it for
the first time guys
middle term splitting two six or twelve
two threes are six
so I want 4 over here so how can I get 4
I want 4 right
okay sorry seven twos are Fourteen and
three threes and nine twos are eighteen
eighteen and fourteen is working right
correct so over here I can write 18 T
minus 14 T minus 252 over here and that
is equal to 0 I hope it is clear to you
now you see this is the first group this
is the second group out of the first
group you can take TS common so t plus
18 will be left out of the second group
you can take minus fourteen as common so
again t plus eighteen will be left and
that is equal to 0 now out of the whole
expression in the left hand side you can
take t plus 18 as common so you will be
left with t plus 18 over here and you
will be left with T minus 14 that is
equal to zero so from here two values of
T they are possible minus eighteen and
fourteen but see time cannot be negative
so you will neglect this value so
therefore you will say t is equal to 14
minutes is the answer 14 minutes is the
answer any doubt in the question guys to
any student in the class
any doubt in the question
I hope you understand that khairatabad I
cannot take doubts because see then
everybody will ask na it's not that I I
don't want that but if I start doing
that it will take too much of time there
is no end to doubts right
I hope it is clear by the way that is
not a quadratic equation
by the way the answer is that is not a
quadratic equation you can simplify the
both hand side so x square will get
canceled out it is not a quadratic
equation it is just a linear equation
I hope it is clear
okay see again I'm explaining this see
just I'll explain how the equation is
formed right how the equation is formed
I will explain then you can obviously
solve on your own solution of quadratic
equation you know basically it is given
that at T minutes past 2 pm the time
needed by the minutes hand of a clock to
show 3 pm here to work it very patiently
time is T minutes past 2 pm so what is
the time needed to time needed for 3 pm
is it not 60 minus t guys tell me T
minutes is already past 2 pm what is the
time needed for 3 pm is it not 60 minus
t minutes and that is given to be equal
to 3 minutes less than T Square by 4 T
Square by 4 minus 3 this is the equation
quadratic equation is there solve it you
will get two values time cannot be
negative so I'll take the positive value
is it clear now
I hope it is clear nor hemlata fine or
not tell me because see in one hour
total 60 minutes are there namina in one
hour total 60 minutes are there no it's
not like that smart Samir it is not like
that I hope it is clear now see here to
what I am saying you will understand
here to see
I explain everything in very detail but
this is a marathon session so if I will
do everything like that it will take 20
hours understand that thing otherwise I
don't have any problem in that
I hope you understand that thing okay
bilkul after the class you'll get that
on the telegram channel of infinity
learn class 9 and 10 okay
this is from ncrt Exemplar only hello
bhadru welcome to this session
okay now do the next one guys this is
also from ncrt Exemplar only again I'm
saying so if z bar were five younger by
five years then what she really is then
the square of her age in years would
have been 11 more than five times her
actual age what is her age now
try doing this one and let me know the
answer over here guys
hello uh dank Mima welcome to this
session
please keep your actual names I mean it
is all up to you although so Zeba were
younger by five years then what she
really is so suppose the percentage of J
buys X years so five years ago her her
age would have been x minus 5 right she
really is then the square of her age
square of her age five years ago square
of her age five years ago
this is equal to 11 more than 5 times 11
more than 5 times her actual age so five
times her actual age plus 11 this is the
quadratic equation right
I hope you got it now you can just
simplify this thing open this using a
minus B the whole Square identity you'll
get x square minus 10 X plus 5 5 is at
25 that is equal to 5x plus 11
if you simplify it further you will get
x square minus 15 x plus 14 that is
equal to 0 now this is a very simple
quadratic equation factorizing it is
very easy you you will get x minus 1 x
minus 14 right and that is equal to zero
so the two values of X they are possible
they are 1 comma 14 over here so you
will say that the age of Z by is 1 or 14
but X is equal to 1 is not the present
age of deba Zeba because 5 years
ago also we are talking about now so
five years ago her age would have been
negative and there is nothing called
negative age so neglect the value so
therefore the present age of Z by is 14
years is the question clear exactly
people already got the answer maybe you
form a different board rajendra okay
very good I hope is smart Samir is it is
clear already
okay
any doubt to any student over here
okay very good
hello junk food welcome to this session
okay very good now you see we'll talk
about the arithmetic progression over
here so nth term of nap again see some
of the things I'm not saying for example
I am not explaining what is an AP you
know what is an Apna now don't say that
I don't know AP I'm doing it for the
first time is it like that no now you
are having exams the day of after
tomorrow you cannot say that I don't
know what is an AP guys
then I will bang my head in the wall
right now if you will say that because
day after tomorrow going to have your
exams right so the nth term of an AP is
a n is equal to a plus n minus 1 into d
right nth term is also called many a
times general term and suppose the
number of terms is n then nth term is
the last term it is also called the it
is also called L is it clear
so the nth term of an AP is a n is equal
to a plus n minus 1 into d
now one more thing I would say nth turn
from the last
nth term from last
nth term
from last
is what guys it is L minus n minus 1
into D nth term from last is L minus 1
in in N minus 1 into D where L is the
last term n is already it will be given
D is the common difference so nth term
from last minute times question is also
asked on the basis of this thing right
we are doing the whole syllabus of grade
10 cbse math and we have started from
the very first chapter and we are over
here starting a p now okay so the N term
from the beginning is n is equal to a
plus n minus 1 into D and nth term from
the last is L minus n minus 1 into D
this formula is also very important
now some of the first n terms of an AP
is n by 2 into 2 A Plus n minus 1 into D
now if you manipulate the same formula n
by 2 in place of 2A can I write a plus a
plus n minus 1 into D now if number of
terms is n Only this is the last term
guys yes or no if number of terms is n
Only this is the last term or not so
some of the first n terms of an AP is
also n by 2 into a plus L and this is
very useful I mean so as to save time
many a times I hope it is clear
okay
okay and some of the first and natural
numbers is NN plus 1 by 2 some of the
first n natural numbers is NN plus one
by two this is also it also comes many a
times okay and finding it is also very
easy because n natural numbers is like
this or not one two three four it is up
till n right it is up till n so sum will
be what sum of the first n natural
numbers will be number is n n by 2 a is
one only first term is one only and last
term is n so can I not use this formula
so sum of the first n natural numbers is
n n plus one by two so any doubt in
these formula guys tell me just tell me
quickly so that we can move on to the
questions now is it clear to every
student over here obviously yes laksha
that's what I'm talking about but
obviously I have to explain the formula
at least a bit I'll do that
obviously lunatic there is needless to
say
sum of N what are you talking about okay
actually you are talking about this some
of the first n natural numbers is this
so first see we can use this formula or
not akshit so n by 2 into a a is 1 L is
n or not tell me last term is n Only so
therefore some of the first and natural
numbers is n n plus one by two I hope it
is clear okay World Beauty welcome to
this session I hope it is clear nakshit
ok so let us do some questions on the
basis of AP try doing this one
the sum of fourth and eighth terms of an
AP is this and the sum of the sixth and
tenth terms of this AP is this find the
sum of the first 20 terms of this AP
ok
I'll tell that as well keshav first do
this question I'll explain that okay
some of the first fourth terms and eight
terms of an AP is twenty four so fourth
term and eighth term fourth term and
eighth term of an AP
is twenty four so fourth term is what a
plus three D or not tell me guys a plus
n minus one e to the eight term is a
plus seven d and that is equal to twenty
four over here if you further simplify
what will you get you will get two a
plus 10 D that is equal to twenty four
now you can divide on both these sides
by two guys so what will you get you'll
get a plus 5 D that is equal to 12 right
so this is the first equation over here
now what is the second part and the sum
of the sixth term and ten terms is forty
four sixth term and ten terms so sixth
term
and the tenth term this is equal to 44
so what I can say over here this is a
plus 5 d
Plus
A Plus 90 right this is equal to 44 over
here so from here can I not say 2A Plus
14 D that is equal to 44 and I can
further simplify you can divide on both
the sides by 2 so will you get a plus 70
that is equal to 22. so this is the
second equation
clear or not so you can what you can do
you can eliminate the variable a over
here or not by doing this equation first
minus equation second can I do that guys
so a will be eliminated 7 D minus 5 D is
two D two D is equal to 22 minus 12 that
is 10 so D is coming out to be 5. so if
D is coming out to be 5 what is the
first term of this AP guys I can put D
is equal to 5 over here
so ah 7 into 5 that is equal to 22 if
you simplify a will come out to be sen
Phi is a 35 minus thirteen so the first
term of this AP is minus 13 correct
that we already done over here uh Hal
Sanam exactly now we have to find the
sum of the first 20 terms of this AP so
just put that formula some of the first
20 terms will be what SN is equal to n
by 2 into 2 A Plus n minus 1 into D so
20 by 2 into 2 a is minus 13 into n
minus 1 is 20 minus 1 is 19 and D over
here is 5. so you can simplify this guys
simplify and get the answer any doubt in
this question to any student over here
whatever it you are getting I think this
is 10 over here and this will be minus
26 plus 95 so 95 minus 26 is what guys
this will be
690 will be the answer correct 690 is
the answer any doubt in the question
exactly
is the question very good many students
got it correctly and this is see all of
these questions are again I'm saying
these are maybe a previous year question
from a sample paper from ncrt Exemplar
obviously we are doing about grade 10
boards so why will I take a question
from somewhere else I hope you
understand that now one student was
asking some of the first odd natural
numbers so the first n or the natural
numbers yes so that is also very simple
the first odd natural number is one
three five and so on right so sum will
be what n by 2 into 2 A Plus n minus 1
into doing d n by 2 into 2 A Plus n
minus 1 D is what guys D is 2 or not
tell me D will be two if you are taking
all the natural numbers D will be 2 so
this is the answer you can simply five
so you will get 2 plus 2 N minus 2 so
you see this will get canceled out and
basically you will get n Square so some
of the first n or the natural numbers is
n Square I hope it is clear I hope one
student was asking
sir n square that can also be done you
can keep on putting the formula I hope
you understand that in place of n you
can put n Square that's it
you got it now in place you are talking
some of the first n Square natural
numbers now so n Square natural numbers
will be this n square into n square plus
1 by 2 this will be your answer
okay
so you can keep on doing array you can
keep on finding the lunatic I hope you
understand that there is no end to
questions then you can keep on asking
and we can keep on even in a p also will
if we can keep on doing for 10 hours no
but that that is not feasible right I
hope you understand that thing so
instead of that I have got some privile
I mean relevant questions only you don't
have to bother
very good
so try doing this one let me know the
answer over here you have to find the
value of x so over here actually there
is a trick in calculation right if you
understand that that is good
the it's not that this question is
something you must have done this
question this is there in every book Rd
Sharma r s Agarwal and pre everywhere
you will find this question the house in
a row are numbered consecutively from 1
to 49 show that there exists a value of
x such that the number of houses
preceding the houses house numbered X is
equal to the sum of the numbers of
houses following X so you have to
understand this situation
okay I'll explain that situation see
over here it is basically given that the
houses are numbered like this one two
and so on up till what 49 okay
you have to show that there is a house
numbered X somewhere there is a house
numbered X such that it is given that
some of the houses
preceding the house numbered X so you
tell me before this x minus 1 will be
there or not so it is given in the
question that some of the houses
preceding X basically it is given that
sum of houses preceding X so s x minus 1
is equal to sum of houses after X some
of these houses some of houses after X
so tell me some of houses after X will
be what guys can you tell total sum
minus SX
some of houses after X will be total sum
minus s x or not so total sum will be S
49 and SX is it clear so this is the
thing if you need to understand and if
you understand this you can do the
quickly do the question quickly so what
you can do SX minus 1 plus SX and that
is equal to S 49 just put the formula
over here s x minus 1 is what x minus 1
is number guys so n by 2 so it is x
minus 1 by 2 into 2A 2A is 1 plus n
minus 1 it means x minus 1 minus 1 and D
is 1 only
plus s x is what x by 2 into 2 A Plus n
minus 1 into D so 2A is 2 into 1 plus n
minus 1 that is x minus 1 into D is one
and that is equal to S 49 49 by 2 into
2A plus n minus 1 into D so 2A is 2 into
1 plus 49 minus 1 into D is one over
here okay not able to write over here
okay D is one only I hope it is clear to
you right so this thing you have to
simplify do not open it now first first
you can simplify it you will get the
answer immediately
you see this is nothing but x minus 1 by
2 and over here this is 2 plus x minus 2
so you see this will be canceled out
plus X by 2 and over here you can do
what guys you can do uh if you simplify
this is 2 plus x minus 1 guys 2 plus x
minus 1 is X Plus 1 right this is X Plus
1 and this is equal to if you simplify
this is 41 49 minus 149 9 minus 1 is 48
48 plus 2 is 50. what X plus 2 is 50 50
by 2 is 25 so this is nothing but 49
into 25 if you further simplify this
what is this guys can I say this is 7
into 5 the whole Square
so this is basically seven pies are 35
the whole Square I hope it is clear now
in the same manner over here what we can
take as common
see can I take X by 2 s common X by 2 s
can be taken as common over here x by 2
I can take as common so I will be left
with x minus 1 into X Plus 1 and this is
coming out to be equal to 35 square so
you see this will get canceled out so
now what we are left with we are left
with X by 2 into 2 x and that is equal
to 35 square so you see this will get
canceled out so this is nothing but x
square is equal to 35 square now
obviously you will get two values plus
minus 35 but number of houses can never
be negative so neglect the negative
value therefore you will say that X is
equal to 35 is the answer so house
number 35 is there is it here exactly
very good ration hyperven hello ananya
welcome to this session is it clear
thanks dawar
srishti we did all the formula already I
think you have joined in bit 35 is the
answer tanu you must have done no no no
no no you cannot do like that Ian I hope
you understand that thanks dawar you
never cancel out square see if you have
got something like this don't do this it
is called mathematical illiteracy
nothing gets canceled out like this you
can do because if you will cancel out
like this now your you are leaving a
value basically right so if suppose you
are you have got this you will say only
4 is the answer but it is not like that
now this is plus minus 4. so this is
called mathematical illiteracy I am
sorry for that it's not that I am
mocking you I hope you understand that
Ian
and I hope I'm pronouncing your name
correctly
okay
I hope it is clear
so some of the first n terms is three n
square plus 6n okay this is an important
thing although we did it in the previous
class this question
exactly no no no root also you cannot
cancel like this only variables you
cancel like this right for example I
have seen many students doing like this
that Tan x is equal to tan y so what
they will do they will cancel out this
no don't do that
it is not like that tan is not a
variable it is a notation in the same
manner square root square cube root
those are notations they are not
variables I hope you understand that
n square formula it is correct only we
know that everything is correct because
I remember the answer to this question
okay suppose SN is given Three N square
plus 6 and some student is asking s n is
equal to 3 n square plus 6 n so you have
to find
whatever you may find okay this is given
so what you do in this question can you
not say that A1 is equal to S1 only guys
tell me a 1 is equal to S one or not
some of the first term is equal to
so this is 6 plus 3 is 9. you got it
guys a 1 is equal to S one it is very
logical now can you not say what is s
two s two is nothing but a 1 plus a 2 or
not
so what is S2 this is 3 into 2 square
plus 6 into 2 what is this equal to 4 3
is at twelve six twos are twelve for the
zero six two twelve twenty four now what
is a one we already know a one a one is
equal to nine so 9 plus a 2 is equal to
24 over here so what is a two over here
A2 is coming out to be 15. A2 is coming
out to be 15. now what is d for this AP
the common difference is a two minus A1
right so it is 15 minus
A1 is 9 so this is six now you know the
first term you know the common
difference you can do anything for this
AP I hope this situation is clear yes
sandwich was correct
uh you do better not to do that cut sign
you got it rishit
better not do the cut sign instead of
that you can write upon comparison X is
equal to Y that is better I would say
otherwise nobody is going to can deduct
your marks for that in maths even if you
cancel it nobody is going to deduct your
marks but it does not look good
mathematically I hope you understand
that otherwise no problem that so is the
question is the situation clear I hope
one student was asking this question
thank you okay so let us move on to the
next question try doing this one and let
me know the answer
so if the first second in the last term
of an AP are a b and 2A respectively
then the sum of the AP is given by what
an N plus 1 and N plus 1 to n plus 1 by
2 this is some of the first this is the
sum of the first I mean some of the
squares of first and natural numbers and
some some of the cubes of first and
natural numbers is n n plus 1 by 2 the
whole Square your question was different
vinod
that was there in my mind which you are
asking vinod I hope you understand that
that is this some of these squares of
first and natural numbers if you do this
1 square plus 2 square plus dot dot dot
plus n Square this will come out to be n
n plus 1 to n plus 1 by 6.
okay
this is there in grade 11 and if you do
the cube some of the cubes of first and
natural numbers some of the cubes if you
will do this will come out to be n n
plus 1 by 2 the whole Square this is not
there in great ten syllabus therefore
obviously I will not explain it I hope
you understand that hi Rohit welcome to
this session
ok
ok so let me explain this the first
second and the last term of an AP is
given so first term is already a let it
be like that
second term is B so what is common
difference guys common difference will
be second term minus first term right or
not
second term minus first term and the
last term is given last term means what
a n is given a n is given to a so can I
not say it is a plus n minus 1 into D A
Plus n minus 1 a plus n minus 1 and what
is D in this question D is B minus a and
this is given to be equal to 2A so from
here you can simplify it n minus 1 into
B minus a will be equal to a so you can
say n minus 1 is equal to a by B minus a
and you can say that n will be equal to
a by B minus a plus 1 so if you simplify
what will you get guys B by B minus a
clear B by B minus a this is the number
of terms over here now you have to find
this sum of the first n terms right sum
of the first n terms is what guys do you
know the formula s n is equal to
n by 2 into a plus L can I do because
last term is already given last term is
already given so can I use this formula
it will make it easier so n is equal to
this
B by
2 into B minus a right now first term
over here is a
and last term is 2A so this is the
answer if you simplify this is 3A so
this will be 3 a b by 2 into B minus a
This Is The Answer 3 a b upon 2 into B
minus a any doubt in this question very
good hello Rohit welcome to this session
see I hope you guys understand that if I
am writing something I'm not seeing
backwards because otherwise I mean it
will be a wastage of time now I keep on
going like that but obviously if I solve
it then obviously I Can See Your Chart
right I hope it is clear obviously it is
cbse grade 10 math of which the
examination is on the day after tomorrow
I hope you understand the answer is
correct I know the answer
okay
I hope it is clear
hello nand Kishore welcome to this
session
okay
now what about this guys now we are
doing coordinate geometry and before
actually starting with coordinate
geometry some basic questions on
coordinate geometry will see so
basically you must have studied about
this hello Khushi welcome to this
session exactly it was clear no problem
pallavi maybe you must have done some
mistakes you can check it out okay see
you don't need to bother Nami see
understand one thing very patiently we
are doing a marathon session
it is not possible for me to give you
three four minutes in every question is
it possible if I will do like that this
Marathon session which is there for
around seven hours it will take 10 hours
so I am also a human being you are also
a human being we cannot there we cannot
be there for four hours seven ten hours
so therefore see the concepts even if a
question is not you are not able to do
in some one man no problem have patience
you must know it that's it hello Rohit
welcome to the session so what about
this the image of the point in the
mirror X is equal to 4 x is equal to 4
is the mirror don't forget that
yes that was correct sanvi hello welcome
to the session we'll do that as well
we'll do the whole syllabus this is a
marathon session Amrita okay so you do
the figure over here make the figure
this is your x axis the y axis the
origin X is equal to 4 over here it is
it is somewhere over here guys X is
equal to 4 will be somewhere over here
or not it is clear to everybody now the
point is minus two comma two so minus
two comma 2 will be somewhere over here
right you want its mirror image
it means basically you are considering X
is equal to 4 as a plane mirror you are
considering X is equal to 4 as a plane
mirror you have studied a concept that
object distance is equal to image
distance the distance of the object in
front of the mirror is the distance of
the image behind the mirror it means can
I not say that this distance has to be
equal to this distance or not tell me it
means y coordinate will be 2 only y
coordinate is not changing now x
coordinate Will Change now if you talk
about C this distance this distance is
two units or not distance can never be
negative in the same manner this
distance is 4 units so therefore this
distance has to be 4 plus 2 6 units or
not this distance has to be 6 units now
what will be its x coordinate x
coordinate is six plus four ten so
therefore 10 comma 2 is the answer is or
not tell me option third is the correct
answer is the question clear to every
stone very good option third is correct
answer session hi Mini screen welcome to
the session is it clear to everybody why
are you crying sunshine I hope it is
clear to everybody over here
just give me a thumbs up in the chat if
it is clear to everybody over here so
that we can proceed and we can do more
questions on the basis of coordinate
geometry
okay very good
Ian
okay fine thank you for that okay okay
let's move on to the next thing so you
can try doing this one find the area in
close within the graph of this equation
the coordinate see I am speaking quickly
many times between things so sometimes
it is happening I hope you understand
it's not that I'm doing it deliberately
but I am trying to do it quickly I'm
trying to skip this these English into
speaking things right
it is with practice I'm being honest
right obviously when I was of your age I
was not able to do that quickly it
happens so it comes with practice if you
practice enough number of questions you
have to have patience when you start
something it is the reality of your life
it is not just about math it is about
everything when you start learning how
to drive a car you have to have patience
when you start learning how to do guitar
you have to have patience it happens
with everybody everywhere in this world
okay it is natural hello Warrior welcome
to this session okay silver Priya
so the area enclosed between the graph
of this and the coordinate axis so you
have to make its graph
so what will you do it's a linear
equation in two variables so two points
you need so very simple thing is if you
put X is equal to 0 it will be 8 6 or 48
right
and if you put Y is equal to zero you
will get
sorry if you put X is equal to zero six
eights are forty eight this is eight
sorry
and if you put Y is equal to zero this
is six correct so what you will do you
have to join these points that's it you
will get its graph so this will be
basically 0 comma six and eight comma
zero so this is eight comma 0 and this
is basically 0 comma six so you have to
find the area in close this is the area
which you have to find now area is what
half into base into height this is a
right angle triangle guys this distance
is eight units this distance is six
units so the area of this triangle is
eight six or forty eight or you can do
like this six fours or twenty four
square units that's it
24 square roots now can you tell me the
perimeter of the triangle enclosed by
the graph of this equation in the
coordinate axis 24 is the answer
can you tell me the perimeter of the
triangle in close between the graph of
this equation and the coordinate axis
okay Vijay
that's okay Khushi that's what I was
saying I mean everybody in this world
can do something or the other maybe I'm
doing math but I don't know any other
thing it can happen some other thing I
don't know
potato race question and spiral question
so that was already discussed on the
don't on the uh
board Brahma series please check that
Ram Sundar if possible
okay perimeter of this triangle if you
have to find that's it you have to use
the Pythagoras Theorem right what is
this distance guys if suppose this is X
so x square will be what guys this is 6
square plus 8 square or not so this will
be what hundred so this is nothing but
10 square so therefore X is coming out
to be ten now what is the perimeter of
this triangle perimeter is length of the
boundary so perimeter is X plus six plus
eight or not tell me X is coming out to
be ten so this is 6 Plus 8 8 plus 6 is
14 so this is coming out to be 24 units
so perimeter is also 24 units I hope the
question is clear to every student over
here very good 24 units only 24 if you
will write it will be wrong silver pre
again I am seeing I will I hope you
understand that we have already done
that we have started from the very first
chapter and we are over here at quadrat
coordinate geometry now
okay see if I take like questioned
outside will not be possible understand
that guys it's not I'm I'm saying from
the depth of my heart it is not that I
don't want to take your doubts
if I I have that in my hands I can take
your doubts for two days and three days
I'm being very honest
why only 24 is 24 24 is correct lunatic
okay laksha thank you let's move on to
the next thing so you have got distance
formula so if you have got the
coordinates of two points a x one b x a
x one y one b x two y two so the
distance between the point the points is
square root of x 2 minus x 1 the whole
square is Y2 minus y two y one the whole
Square see there is a proof to each of
these Concepts but again I am not doing
proof overhead because we are talking
about great 10 maths examination only
where the proof of these things is not
as proof is done using Pythagoras
Theorem so square root of x 2 minus x
one the whole square plus Y2 minus y 1
the whole square is the distance between
these two points whose coordinates are
given to you
then you have got section formula
so if the coordinates are the end points
of a line segment are given a x one y
one b x 2 Y 2 and there is a point lying
on that line segment p x comma Y and
that point is dividing a b in that ratio
m is to n now one thing you have to make
sure that a p is not equal to M ratio is
given p b is not equal to and the ratio
of a p and p b is m is to n okay so the
coordinates X and Y can be found using
section formula there is a pattern to
remember this x will be what m x 2 plus
n x 1 upon M plus n in the same manner y
will be m y 2 this is the pattern m y 2
plus n y 1 upon M plus n so that's why
you use this section formula there is a
section formula for external division as
well but that is not in the syllabus I
hope it is clear to you now there is one
midpoint formula as well if you have got
this line segment suppose
I'm taking a simple example 1 3 and
suppose B 5 6 you have to find the
coordinates of the midpoint over here so
it will be X One Plus x 2 by 2 so 1 plus
5 by 2 and Y one plus y two by two that
is three plus six by two so this is the
midpoint using the midpoint formula
midpoint formula is a special case of
the section formula midpoint formula is
the special case of of the section
formula when m is 2 N is equal to 1 is
to one that's it midpoint formula is
nothing different it is just a special
case of the section formula
is it clear to every student over here
OK it is just a special case of the
section formula okay now do I try doing
this question you got this question
himlata case to one question so
determine the ratio in which this line
divides the line segment joining points
a 2 comma minus 2 and B three comma
seven
try doing this one guys
determine the ratio in which this line
so uh divides the line segment joining
the points this a
2 comma minus 2 a 2 comma minus 2 and B
3 comma 7.
is divided by the line
three X Plus y minus 6 is equal to 0
right so you have to find this thing now
suppose the ratio is nothing but K is to
1 the ratio is case to 1 just suppose
the ratio is case to one
so what will be the coordinates of this
point guys the coordinates of this point
using this section formula will be what
m x 2 plus n x one so it will be 3 K
plus 2 by K plus 1 yes or no
and then m y 2 N it means 7 k
n y 1 minus 2 upon K plus 1 using
section formula right now you see this
point is also lying on this line yes or
no it's a common point so therefore the
coordinates of this point will satisfy
this equation yes or no so 3 into
uh
three K plus 1 upon K plus 1
plus y over here is 7 K minus 2 upon K
plus 1
K plus 1
minus 6 that is equal to 0 over here so
what you can do you can just simplify
over here you will get the answer so
this is 9 K plus 3 plus 7 K minus 2
minus 6 K minus 6 that is equal to 0 so
what will you get over here guys
10 K over here and this will give you uh
minus 5 that is equal to 0 so therefore
K is to 1 will come out to be equal to 1
is 2 2. so therefore 1 is 2 2 is the
answer any doubt in the equation 1 is to
2 is coming out over here
okay have I done some mistake
no 3K oh my God yeah that is a mistake
over there this is true over here right
this is 2 yes
so yeah that will come out a bit
different wait in give me some seconds
so this will come out to be uh 6 right
this is six so this will give you
10 K and then this will get canceled out
so this is equal to 2 only right correct
so K is to 1 is 1 is to 5. I hope it is
clear to every student over here so it's
a very normal question and one of the
most important questions according to
your syllabus I hope it is clear
when equal distance is given to you
somnath equal distance is given then you
can use equal distance formula basically
perpendicular bisector as well if you
have got this concept basically
every point on the perpendicular
bisector of a line segment is
equidistant from the end points yes or
no you know this concept every point on
the perpendicular bisector is
equidistant from the end points so over
here you can use equal distance formula
right I mean equal distance formula not
I mean its a situation just that's it
you can take one is to K as well you
will get the same answer
when you will take one is to K when you
will take one is to k then you will get
what ah
if you take one is two k c if you take
one is 2K you want one then you will get
K is equal to 5 in this case Okay Anand
when you will assume one is two k then
you will get K is equal to 5 you will
still get the same answer you get the
same answer for sure
you can assume m is 2 and also you can
assume m one is to N1 as well it is all
up to you why you took three where you
are asking Samantha
oh this is the formula m x two c m x 2 n
x 1 upon M plus n you know this
section formula Samantha
I hope it is clear now
and this is given in the equation itself
this 3 is in the equation itself that's
it ok
now try doing this one a simple question
see I am taking standard questions only
which can come in your examination right
obviously it can be twisted a bit no
problem that so can you find the value
of x minus y over here
if these are the vertices of a
parallelogram taken in order try doing
this one and let me know the answer
vertices of a parallelogram taken in
order so this is 1 comma minus 2
4 comma y over here
and X comma 6 over here vertices of a
parallelogram taken in order minus 3
comma 5 right
correct one of one comma two four comma
five a four comma y exponent 6 minus
five right correct
obviously they will give why not they
will give for that it is mathematically
correct they can give marks obviously so
taken in order we have to find the value
of x minus y so you over here we have to
join the diagonals over here and guys
diagonals of a parallelogram bisect each
other at the point of intersection okay
diagonals of a parallelogram bisect
teaches at the point of intersection
suppose the point of intersection is p
comma Q
so you see over here if you use midpoint
formula in this diagonal P will be what
guys P will be 4 minus 3 by 2 or not and
if you will use midpoint formula in this
diagonal P will be 1 plus X by 2 or not
guys tell me so you see this will get
cancel Dot and X will come out to be
equal to zero now in this same manner if
you use midpoint formula in this
diagonal Q will be what guys Q will be
equal to Y plus 5 by 2 yes or no y plus
5 by 2 and if you again use midpoint
formula in this diagonal what is Q guys
it will be 6 minus two by two so over
here it will get canceled out so what is
the value of y which is coming 4 minus 5
minus 1 Y is coming out to be minus one
so you have to find the value of x minus
y x is coming out to be 0 Y is minus 1
therefore the answer is plus one so plus
1 is the answer any doubt in this
question guys so any student over here
plus one is the answer laksha y minus 1
oh my God
plus one is very good ratio that is
correct
hello Alisa welcome to session any doubt
to any student over you must have done a
mistake in this sign is the question
clear to every stone over here just
confirm in the chat quickly okay
and then we can move on to the next
question over here
is it clear to everybody
okay that's good hello radhe welcome to
this session okay let's move on to the
next one so if the distance between
these two points is five then the values
of X is what try doing this one let me
know the answer in the chart very simple
question it is
so ah what is this chapter guys I mean
chapter number what is this chapter
number
hello Niraj welcome to this session
what is this chapter number I don't
remember it because I think we must take
a break for some time yeah that's what I
am saying
total 14 chapters are there now
not two minutes only
no we will take after this will take
some uh 10 minutes break don't bother
10 12 minutes break I'll eat something
maybe drink something you can also eat
and drink something okay
and then we'll be back okay
this is chapter number seven oh my God
we have done chapter number seven or
what according to the ncrt no I don't
think so okay no problem do this
question first and then we'll take a
break
whatever may be the chapter because
we'll cover it anyways we have got
enough time left no don't bother about
that okay
so if the distance between the points is
this so suppose this point is a and this
point is B
distance between these points is given
it means a b is given to be equal to 5.
so guys you get square root in the
distance formula yes or no so can we
Square on both sides over here itself
yes or no can we Square on both sides
over here itself
so will the square root of the distance
formula get removed
so will I get something like this over
here minus 1 minus 2 the whole Square
plus X plus 2 the whole square if I use
the distance formula and that is equal
to 25 this is minus 3 square that is 9
so therefore X plus 2 the whole square
is nothing but equal to 25 minus 9 that
is equal to 16 which is nothing but
equal to 4 Square so from here can I say
that X plus 2 is equal to plus minus 4
over here so can I say two possibilities
are there X plus 2 is equal to 4 or you
can say x is equal to 2 and the second
possibility is X plus 2 is equal to
minus 4 or you can say x is equal to
minus 6 so therefore X is equal to minus
or X is equal to 2 is the answer 2 comma
minus 6 any doubt in the question to any
student in the class exactly options is
correct and if you see this situation
over here what will be the situation
distance between the points so over here
it will be somewhat like this it will
make it graphically
the point is 2 comma minus 2 so 2 comma
2 comma minus 2 will be somewhere over
here right 2 comma minus 2 and the point
is coming to be minus 1 comma 2 and
minus 1
so minus 1 comma 2 is somewhere over
here you see minus 1 comma 2 its
distance will be this and one point will
be like this or not minus 1 comma minus
six can't will this situation be like
this therefore the distance they are
equal is it clear to every strand over
here so obviously it is not asked in the
question but still I have explained the
situation to you any doubt to any
student over here in the class tell me
only Hindi is not possible radhe I hope
you understand that because there are
many students will not be able to
understand Hindi but in English
anant
Samantha only distance is given distance
between these two points is five so
suppose a b is five Samantha now you see
you get this square root in the distance
formula so if I Square in the first step
that square root will be removed or not
Samantha tell me because square root of
anything Nu square of it so that square
root will be removed or not Samantha so
therefore you will get only this thing
that is the usage of the distance
formula that square root is removed
solve this equation you will get two
values of X so you can solve it I hope
it is clear now Samantha
yeah it is for grade 10 mathematics
Selva
quadrant quadrant is this this is the
first quadrant second quadrant third
quarter and fourth quadrant it is just a
convention in the anti-clockwise
Direction first second third fourth
quadrant in the first quadrant both X
and Y they are positive x coordinate and
the y coordinate coordinate they are
positive in the second quadrant negative
positive in the third quadrant negative
negative in the fourth quadrant positive
negative I hope it is clear
okay so obviously we'll do every chapter
to Raymond don't bother hello welcome to
the session we should add to where we
are adding two
no X plus 2 is coming out to be 4 X plus
2 is coming out to be minus four so two
comma minus OK are you talking about
this oh see we are using distance
formula over here Anand we are using
distance forming you see minus 1 minus 2
the whole Square now this will be x
minus minus 2 so will it come out to be
X plus 2 Anand so therefore we have got
X plus 2 I hope it is clear now ananth
hello nilima welcome to this session
astc rule is not in grade 10
trigonometry all school to college that
is there in grade 11 or maybe of if you
are preparing for ah
like ntsc and kvpy and other things okay
I hope it is clear
okay so I think we must take some break
right so because this is triangles so I
am giving like uh 12 minutes break to
you after that we'll be starting with
triangles okay hello akhil welcome to
this session so just after 12 13 minutes
we'll be starting with it will resume
we'll be resuming this session and then
we'll be doing that okay hello okay I
hope I'm pronouncing it correctly hello
welcome to the session and then we'll be
starting with it okay
wait what is happening
okay guys let me put it for you
foreign
hello everybody I'm back are you able to
uh hear and see me properly
Priya guys
are you guys able to hear and see me
properly
okay
are you guys able to hear and see me
properly in trigonometry can you give
point on how to solve the equations
we'll do that questions we will do those
questions as well Anand don't bother
okay Doraemon welcome to this session
hello laksha welcome to the session
let's wait for some more seconds later
the students join as well and then we
can start with the class okay
then we'll be starting with triangles
over here
okay
hello welcome to this session
we we have already done that thing hello
silver welcome to the session jelly we
have already done that
okay so let's start with it guys this is
triangle this is the basic
proportionality theorem if a line is
drawn parallel to one side of a triangle
26 there are two sides and distinct
points there are two sides are divided
in the same ratio I am not doing the
proof of basic proportionality theorem
because that is already done by you
right proof of basic proportionality
theorem is already done yes or no
ok so if a line is drawn parallel to one
side of triangle to intersect there are
two sides at distinct points other two
sides are divided in the same ratio
suppose this triangle is a b c and if
you are drawing a line parallel to one
side suppose this is d e
so basic proportionality theorem or we
call it thales theorem right all we or
we call it Tales theorem
so if it is by this name you do not have
to bother that what is this thing okay
now BPT is what C if it is given to you
that d e is parallel to BC if it is
already given to you then you can say
then you can say a d by D B is equal to
a e by e c right a d by D B is equal to
a e by e c this is the basic
proportionality theorem all the or the
thales theorem right now its Converse is
also true its Converse is and if it is
already given to you a d by D B if it is
already given that a d by D B is equal
to a e by e c
then you can say that d e is parallel to
BC then d e is parallel to BC
is it clear guys so this is the basic
proportionality theorem this is the
converse of the basic proportionality
theorem
is it clear to everybody over here
hygiene welcome to the session this is
the basic proportionality theorem this
is the converse of the basic
proportionality theorem it means if it
is given to you that d e is parallel to
BC you can say that a d by D B is equal
to a by e c and if its Converse is given
if it is already given that a d by D B
is equal to a by e c then you can say
that d e is parallel to BC this is the
converse of the basic proportionality
theorem fine
now again I am saying the proof of this
basic proportionality theorem is in this
syllabus it can very well ask it can
very well be asked in the examination
okay
now
this is the proof of the basic
proportionality theorem now some of the
corollaries of the basic proportionality
theorem you can see which is used many a
times in question C for example if you
have got this triangle
suppose a b c only
a b c and you are doing like this d e if
it is given parallel like this C
if
d e is parallel to BC if D is parallel
to BC then the very first thing is you
would say that a d by d b
a d by D B is equal to a e by e c
correct
yes or no this is the first thing which
you can say then the second thing which
you can say over here is
a d by a b these are corollaries of
basic proportionality theorem a d by a b
is equal to a e by AC
and you can also say over here
you can also say that a b by a d
a b by a d
is equal to
AC by a these things are used many a
times
so is it clear to everybody these are
the corollaries of basic proportionality
theorem
is it okay with you
okay thanks radhe radhe
okay is it okay so these are the
corollaries of basic proportionality
theorem corollary means statement
derived from a theorem okay and these
can also be used in questions is it
clear to everybody over here
fine now how do you prove these
corollaries You just prove it by suppose
in this one only ah
in this one you take its reciprocal
right if I take its reciprocal like this
DB by a d
is equal to e c by a Maybe I am not
visible to you but I think the things
written on the board is visible to you
right if I write it like this and I take
one I add one on both these sides of
this thing if I add one on both these
sides of this e c by a e
plus one right if I do like this
it's not written properly no problem but
I hope it is okay with you right
weight
so what will happen over here if you
take the LCM you will get DB plus a d
by a d over here and that will give you
e c plus a e by e c plus a e by
of it
it will be e c plus a e by a e right now
you can further simplify it what you
will say DB plus a d is what DB plus a d
is a b so this is a b by a d yes or no a
b by a d and this will be
AC by a so have I got one result over
here guys you see a b by a d a c by a so
you have got this yes you can do that
okay but obviously proving this will not
require minus one I hope you understand
laksha but that can be done it's not a
very complex thing yes but you don't do
that component do and dividendo by that
name rishit I hope you understand that
OK we will do that as well thakur Bhai
do not bother so is it clear these are
the corollaries of basic proportionality
theorem so if it is an objective
question comes you can do it easily I
hope it is clear to everybody over here
that is not in this syllabus directly
not getting means what sayally
you take this say Ali and then you take
its reciprocal DB by a d is equal to e c
by a or not then you can add one on both
these sides so if you add one and take
LCM this will go over here DB plus a d
by a d e c plus a e by a isn't that say
Ali now DB plus a d is a b and e c plus
a is AC you see that just see the figure
you'll get that I hope it is clear hi
last year welcome to the session I hope
it is clear say Ali just see that and
confirm if it is clear to you or not
there are some students will not
understand that they go you will
understand English now but they will not
understand Hindi so unders you have to
think about other people as well okay
I hope it is clear that uh to you and
component no individendo is not in the
syllabus laksha otherwise I would have
explained that but concept I can
experience a very simple thing C if a by
B is equal to C by D then you can say
that a plus b by a minus B is equal to C
plus d by C minus D this is componento
and dividendo this is used many a times
in questions okay I hope it is clear
laksha
okay
now we have to see similarity criteria
what is your doubt salary similarity
criteria this is Triple A similarity
criteracy if in two triangles two angles
are equal the third angle will
automatically be equal by angle sum
property so you can all you can only say
a if a a is getting satisfied
automatically Triple A will get
satisfied so you don't need to show
Triple A every time I hope it is okay
you don't need to show Triple A every
time we'll do that as well dheeraj will
do the whole syllabus yes shantam you
don't have to bother we will do the
whole syllabus this is a marathon
session so what is this thing I see if
it is given that you have got two
triangles okay A a similarity right and
I'll I have I'll have to make the
figures so you have got two triangles
over here suppose a b
C and this is p q r over here so if it
is given to you that angle a is equal to
angle p and angle B is equal to angle Q
see if it is given that a is equal to p
and B is equal to Q in these two
triangles
then
you can say that triangle ABC is similar
to Triangle p q r
similar to Triangle P Q R by a a
similarity Criterion and if two
triangles are similar already
automatically
a b by P Q is equal to BC by q r is
equal to AC by PR
ok
if two triangles are similar
automatically they are corresponding
sides will be proportional ratio of
corresponding sides will be equal you
got it or not if two triangles are
similar ratio of corresponding sides
will be equal
there is nothing called rhs similarity
ananth only three similarity criteria
are there a a triple S and SAS don't get
confused with congruency there is a
difference in similarity and congruency
so I'll write over here so you see there
is no similarity Criterion called AAS
there is no similarity criteria like
this there is no similarity Criterion
like this there is no similarity
Criterion like this there is no
similarity Criterion like this okay
similarity and congruency they are
different from each other I hope it is
clear only three similarity criteria are
there that is a A or you call it Triple
A but because if in two triangles two
angles are equal automatically third
angle will be equal using the angle sum
property so a a similarity Criterion
Triple S similarity Criterion and SAS
similarity Criterion I hope it is clear
now one more thing if you have got two
similar triangles automatically ratio of
corresponding sides of two similar
triangles is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding perimeters as well so
ratio of perimeter of a b c is equal to
the ratio of the
of their corresponding sides ratio of
corresponding sides of two similar
triangles is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding perimeters
no there is no relation between similar
and corresponding corresponding means
according to the name for example if
over here you are using a b c and P Q R
C so if you will write triangle ABC
similar to suppose QPR this statement
will be wrong you got it if you will do
like this it will be wrong is it clear
Rahul because you are working according
to the name a is with respect to P only
B is with respect to Q only and C is
with respect to R only so it means you
cannot change the name as per your wish
that would be wrong if you do so but
yeah both the names can be changed
correspondingly for example I can write
b c a i can write BCA similar to qrp
that is correct this thing I can do you
got it or not Rahul so corresponding
names can be changed I hope it is clear
again I am repeating the ratio of
corresponding sides of two similar
triangles are equal and the ratio of
triangles is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding perimeters as well I hope
it is clear to you
okay
now the second one is SSS you just go
according to the name that is side side
similarity Criterion so if you have got
two triangles I'll make over here
obviously they are not perfect figures I
hope you understand that because it's
just a roughner I'm not ex making the
exact figure
so if something like this is happening
if in two triangles ratio of
corresponding sites are equal it is
given to you A B by P Q is equal to BC
by q r is equal to AC by PR if this is
given to you
if this situation exists then you can
say that triangles are similar a b c is
similar to Triangle p q r and the reason
being Triple S similarity Criterion and
if they are similar then automatically
corresponding angles will also be equal
a is equal to p b is equal to q and C is
equal to R okay if two triangles are
similar automatically ratio of
corresponding sites are equal and
corresponding angles are equal I hope it
is clear to you again over here as well
ratio of corresponding perimeters is
equal to the ratio of corresponding
sites as well I hope the concept is
clear to everybody there is a proof to
each of these similarity criteria but
that is not in the syllabus it is given
in ncert if you want to know the reason
you must know I will never say not to
know but because Day After Tomorrow is
your examination so please don't do
research today it will waste your time
no it is not that ratio is equal Rahul
sites are not equal ratio of
corresponding sites are equal
I hope it is clear honey if in two
triangles ratio of corresponding sites
are equal then the triangles are similar
and corresponding angles will be equal I
hope it is clear honey
only Hindi is not possible Ajay I hope
you understand that
okay now the third situation is SAS side
angle side just read the name it is
according to the name only things are
working according to the name over here
okay that if you have got two triangles
something like this if I am doing like
this suppose
it is a b c and weight
it is p q r over here if suppose it is
given that ah
ratio of a b by P Q
is equal to BC by q r okay and the
included angle see a b and b c we are
using so therefore angle b p q and Q are
we are using therefore angle Q included
angle only angle B is equal to angle Q
if this thing is happening then you can
say that the triangles are similar to
each other then triangle ABC is similar
to Triangle p q r the reason being SAS
similarity Criterion they are similar by
SAS similarity Criterion and if they are
similar
automatically ratio of corresponding
sides will be equal a b by P Q is equal
to BC by q r
is equal to AC by PR automatically ratio
of corresponding sites are equal and
automatically corresponding angles will
also be equal a is equal to p and C is
equal to R is it clear or not tell me so
these are the only similarity criteria
no there is no congruency over here Ian
because we are talking about similarity
in congruency what happens ratio of
corresponding sides is equal to one you
understand that but in similarity
ratio of corresponding sites can be one
also and other than one also so
congruency is a special case of
similarity so all congruent triangles
are similar but all similar triangles
may not be congruent you got it what do
you mean by similarity two things which
look like each other are similar but
congruent means two things which look
like each other and they are of the same
size as well
exactly honey why not they can be in
ratio form they can be in irrational
number also na ratio of corresponding
sides can be an irrational also you got
it or not
sites when corresponding sites are equal
then that is not a similarity criteria
that is congruency
you got it that is a special case of
similarity when ratio of corresponding
sites are equal then the triangles will
be congruent I hope it is clear now
Rahul
okay
now do this question on the basis of
similarity wait before this I will
explain just give me some seconds before
this I will explain one more thing to
you and that is also important weight uh
space is not there maybe first do this
question and then I'll explain okay
its also double it can be anything now
ratio of corresponding sides can be
anything double triple root 3 times 100
times anything miriala but when the
ratio of corresponding size is equal to
1 it means corresponding sites are equal
or not mireala so that is a special case
of similarity when the triangles are
congruent
so congruency is a special case of
similarity all congruent triangles are
similar but all similar triangles need
to not be congruent I hope it is clear
now okay
try doing this one guys this question
uh you have to find uh
D in terms of P and R you have to find D
in terms of P and R okay
D in terms of P and R actually the
question was big therefore it is taking
two slides you have to find this D in
terms of P and R
that's it
try doing this one and do it quickly
guys
so over here as well we are going to use
similarity so let us name these
triangles over here suppose this is a b
C
d and e right so basically over here can
we not say that triangle
a c e you see over here a c e is similar
to Triangle
b c d
a c e is similar to B C D the reason
being a a similarity Criterion because
if you see a c e and B C D what is
happening this angle is common or not
this angle is common and also this is 90
this is also 90. so in these two
triangles two sides are equal so if in
two angles are equal if in two triangles
two angles are equal then this triangles
are similar by a a similarity Criterion
and the ratio of corresponding sides
will be equal because if two triangles
are similar ratio of corresponding sites
are equal so can we say over here that a
e by b d
a e by b d is equal to
AC by b c over here can we say that
ratio of corresponding sides of two
similar triangles are equal now you see
what is a e a e is d
what is b d b d is R what is AC over
here guys you see this is 7 so this is
also 7 or not so AC can be written as P
plus 7 or not tell me P plus 7 and BC
over here is p only
so if I cross multiply D will come out
to be P plus 7 into R by P so this is
the answer this is a D in terms of P and
R is it clear
no you did a mistake I think rishit that
is correct very good
yes Rahul that is correct see this is an
objective question but questions like
this can be asked as a subjective
question or not tell me so when it is an
objective question you do not need to
write these things as well you can
directly do this thing these things you
can think in your mind but if it is a
subjective question you have to write
everything possible because if you will
not write everything possible in a
subjective question if you will not give
the proper logic behind everything you
will not get full marks very good result
that is correct hello Anita welcome to
this session pankaj I think you must you
must have done some mistake that is
correct group Prasad that is correct AC
by DC uh what are you talking about
no y a c by DC a c by DC there is no
correlation between them hello Anita
welcome to this session I am doing a e
by b d is equal to AC by b c c why will
I take the third pair there is no need
of that why will you take e c by DC tell
me
is there any need of e c by DC there is
no need of e c by DC so why will you
take that it will waste your time now
I hope the question is clear to every
student in the class exactly that is
correct that is correct nilima
ah multiplied by R as well last year
it's b or d
which one are you talking about C this
is B this is B this is d
okay
are you talking about this thing maybe
confusion in this weight
it is B OK BC AC by b c I hope it is
okay now AC by b c it is
okay venkat I hope it is clear now
hemlata
yeah maybe due to my bad handwriting I'm
sorry for that
I hope it is clear now
okay
so uh which one is the correct answer
option D
okay now one more thing I would like to
explain see it very patiently
the ratio of corresponding sides of two
similar triangles is equal to the ratio
of their corresponding perimeters is
equal to the ratio of their
corresponding angle bisectors is equal
to the ratio of their corresponding
medians is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding altitudes
and all of these can be proved using
similarity and they can be asked as
proof based question or many a times it
can be asked as an objective question
where you don't need to write anything
and directly find the answer you got it
suppose I'll show over here if you have
got two triangles two similar triangles
they are already similar it is given to
you as similar triangles so a b c over
here
and suppose p q r
suppose this is a median median you
understand this is the midpoint if you
take this this is the midpoint okay so a
b c d p q r s ok so these are already
similar if
triangle a b c is similar to Triangle p
q r then ratio of corresponding sides of
similar triangles then obviously a b by
b c sorry A B by P Q is equal to BC by q
r
is equal to AC by PR that is correct
everybody understands that and this is
also equal to the ratio of their
corresponding medians a d by P S as well
and suppose in place of this median
angle bisector is there then then also
ratio of corresponding sides of two
similar triangles is equal to the ratio
of their medians is equal to the ratio
of their corresponding angle bisectors
is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding altitudes as well
all of these concepts are important
Rahul I am not doing any different thing
okay nilima no problem I will explain
this thing it will take some time only
see nilima over here
it is already given that a b c and P Q R
are similar triangles correct so it
means it is already given that a b by P
Q is equal to BC by q r or not millima
tell me this is already given to us now
it is given that a d is the median so
therefore D is the midpoint in place of
BC can I write 2bd over here tell me and
in place of q r can I write 2q over here
I can write 2 q s sorry so this will get
canceled out so b d upon q s
have I got it
now basically a b c and P Q R were
already similar so therefore B is equal
to Q or not tell me because
corresponding angles of similar
triangles are equal
so if you see this triangle a b d and p
q s in these two triangles we have
proved a b by P Q is equal to b d by q s
c over here and angle B is equal to
angle Q so can you not say over here the
triangle a b d
is a b d is similar to triangle tqs can
I say that by s a s similarity Criterion
can I say that nilima and everybody else
that is not in the syllabus jitendra
is it clear to everybody so see we have
already proved a b d to be similar to
pqs so can we not say that a b by P Q is
equal to a d by P S so c a b by P Q is
equal to a d by P S so have we proved
that ratio of corresponding medians of
two similar triangles are equal
ratio of corresponding medians of two
similar triangles is equal to the ratio
of their corresponding sides in the same
manner you can prove again repeat here
to what I am saying it is very important
because three four questions are on the
basis of this thing I mean which can be
asked
let me repeat properly and here to it
very patiently I request you the ratio
of corresponding sides of two similar
triangles is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding
medians is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding angle bisectors is equal
to the ratio of their corresponding
altitudes is equal to the ratio of their
corresponding perimeters all of any one
out of these can be asked as a proof
based question or can be used in
objective question as well you got it
I hope it is clear no tomorrow obviously
not tomorrow you can do self study
rishit otherwise it will waste your time
I hope it is clear to everybody over
here
see miriala SAS similarity Criterion
again I will repeat suppose you have got
two triangles ratio of this upon this is
equal to this upon this so you have got
s s s
and the included angle is equal
in two triangles ratio of two sides and
the included angle is equal then the
triangles will be similar by side angle
side angle is included between the sides
they are similar by SAS similarity
Criterion
this is grade 10 maths cbse grade 10
maths
BPT is the basic proportionality theorem
or the thales theorem Anita I hope it is
clear please don't put another links
over here hello hi and please don't spam
if you understand we are studying over
here I hope the concepts explained over
here is clear to every student in the
class okay so let's move on to the next
thing over here what about this question
try doing this one and let me know the
answer in the chat you have to find the
value of x do it quickly and let me know
the answer
obviously you have to do these things
now you cannot say that see if I will do
everything over here it will not fulfill
your purpose because you have to do your
examination on your own isn't it an
honest thing tell me guys even if I
write everything over here it's not
going to help you in the long run you
have to do your examination on your own
or not tell me
okay so what is the value of x over here
so if you want d e parallel to a b over
here what we can say can I not say that
a e upon e c
a e upon e c is equal to b d upon DC or
not tell me basic proportionality
theorem
Anita you were asking
okay
okay let's see if it is correct or not
rishit very good AE by e c is equal to b
d by DC using the basic proportionality
theorem just put the values 3x plus 19
divided by X plus 3 that is equal to 3x
plus 4 upon X see it is looking complex
but it is very simple believe me you can
cross multiply you will get 3 x square
plus 19x and that will give you what
guys that will give you 3x square plus
4X
plus nine X plus four threes are twelve
so what you can do 3x square 3x square
will get canceled out over here and this
is 6 x is equal to 12 will come 6X is
equal to 12. so from here x will come
out to be 2 this is the answer any doubt
in this thing very good it is correct
very good group Prasad rishit wasima
swamya Fatima
you have written this spelling wrong
please change the spelling
okay I hope the question is clear to
every student it's a direct simple
question on the basis of the basic
proportionality theorem now let's do a
twisted question on the basis of the
basic proportionality theorem only try
doing this one and let me know the
answer over here
so none of the question which I am
taking over here is a very different
question you will get all of these
questions in almost every book
so what is the answer over here it is
given in this question that
just see the figure it is given over
here that this is parallel to this this
is parallel to this
and it is given this
to be parallel to this
okay I made it dirty only but still you
will be able to understand it from the
figure only try doing this one and let
me know the answer guys
hello anju
hello shot Creator welcome to this
session so over here what we can say
guys see
x m and x n are drawn parallel to B A
and C A so you see x m is parallel to B
A just see the figure properly
x m
is parallel to B A over here right it
means this is parallel to this over here
so can I say over here guys using the
basic proportionality theorem
okay so can I say that t b upon t x just
see that t b upon TX
is equal to T N upon TM guys yes or no
using the basic proportionality theorem
corollary of the basic proportionality
theorem in the same manner it is given
that x n is parallel to ca x n is
parallel to ca
this is given to you
so what we can say over here guys can I
not say that
TX upon TC just see this TX upon T C is
equal to
t n upon t m using the corollary of the
basic proportionality theorem yes or no
just see it very patiently and tell me
if it is clear or not we can do this
over here exactly
obviously are you talking about that
examination that entrance of SSC staff
selection commission are you talking
about
so over here ah
see t n upon t m t n upon TM so we can
put the left hand side to be equal so I
can say over here that t b by t x t b by
t x is equal to TX upon t c can I not
say so from here if you cross multiply
will you get t x square is equal to t b
t c yes or no t x square is equal to t b
t c this is the answer is it clear to
every student over here
option three is correct very good baru
sonali exactly laksha
is it clear now Rahul again you can see
just see it properly you will understand
it Rahul just see what is written over
here see if x m is parallel to this
Rahul can you not say t b by t x to be
equal to T N upon t m using the
corollary of basic proportionality
theorem which I had explained in this
class itself now Rahul if you are taking
X and to be parallel to AC so can I not
say t x upon T C is equal to T N upon TM
tell me Rahul this thing will come now
you see in these equations the right
hand side they are equal so the left
hand side will also be equal you see
over here so you cross multiply you will
get the result I hope it is clear now
clear or not
what happened aragya what are you asking
not able to understand your doubt this
is cbse grade 10 math we are talking
about over here
the examination of which is there my
name is misbah Carolyn
okay very good congratulations if it is
clear and I hope Rahul it is clear to
you
now we are going to talk about the
concepts in this chapter circles so see
it very patiently a circle you know what
is a secant in a circle a secant is a
line which passes through two points of
a circle okay a secant is a line which
passes through two points of a circle
tangent is a line which which
intersects this circle at one point only
and that point is called the point of
contact this point is called the point
of contact clear or not
what happened not able to understand
that again what are you asking please
rewrite your question
see we are right now targeting cbse
grade 10 math if this is these things
are relevant according to your state
board syllabus then you can obviously be
here okay baru
I hope it is clear to everybody over
here what is the tangent and what is the
secant right
now some of the other points number of
tangents infinitely many tangents can be
drawn on a circle if you have got a
circle you can make infinitely many
secants infinitely many sequence to a
circle and you can also make infinitely
many tangents as well because at at
every point of the circle you can make
one tangent so to a circle infinitely
many tangents can be made and infinitely
many secants can be made clear or not to
a circle
secant and chord same no last year's
secant and chord is not the same because
you take the concept of secant as a line
you can say that a quad is a part of a
secant okay because secant we consider
as a line okay but a chord is a line
segment for example you take it a b so
quad is a line segment now I hope you
understand that
I hope it is clear now last year chord
is a part of the secant you can
understand that because secant is a line
and chord is a line segment
okay
now there is only one tangent to a point
of this circle if you have got a circle
at any one point only one tangent can be
made on one point of the circle only one
tangent can be made you cannot make more
than one tangent at a point of the
circle I am sorry for my bad figure this
is not a tangent it's it has become a
secant no problem at every point of the
circle only one tangent can be made now
the tangent to a circle is a special
case of this secant you understand this
situation like this the tangent to a
circle is a special case of the secant
you take a circle over here
and you see suppose this is Center I am
making secants okay secant secants
secants secants and then you've got a
tangent what is happening over here guys
you are you seeing that these two points
are coming closer to each other these
two points are coming closer to each
other are you seeing this these two
points are coming closer to each other
so you can say that a tangent to a
circle is a special case of a secant are
you also called limiting case of a
secant
the tangent to a circle is the limiting
case of a secant you got it the tangent
was a limiting case of the secant
power of point formula that is not in
the grade 10 syllabus we are doing only
cbse grade 10 mathematics I hope you
understand that rishit right now over
here we have got something in our mind
we have got our
Motif fixed before this class so if I
deviate from that we have to cover the
things on time right hello anju welcome
to this session I hope it is clear to
everybody that attention to a circle is
a special case of a secant now last one
is there is no tangent to a circle
passing through a point inside the
circle it's a simple thing if you have
got a circle and there is a point inside
the circle through this point you can
make infinitely many secants but if a
point is lying inside the circle you
cannot make even one tangent through
that point to that Circle you can make
infinitely many secants through a point
lying inside the circle but you cannot
make even one tangent through that point
lying inside the circle
see Samantha if you have got a circle
you can make a pair of parallel tangents
for example you have got a tangent
through this tangent only one parallel
tangent can be made got it or not and
that will be the diametrically opposite
Point through a given tangent only one
tangent can be made parallel to that
tangent but infinitely many parallel
secants can be made okay but infinitely
many parallel secants will be made hi
pranaya welcome to this session
what is your question on you I haven't
seen your question please write it once
again
three thermos not able to understand
that Allah what is that three thermos
okay
now there is only one and one t into a
circle passing through Point lying on
the circle so if you've got a circle and
there is a point on it only one tangent
can be made through that point lying on
the circle through a point lying on the
circle only one tangent can be made now
if you have got a point lying outside
the circle you can make a pair of
tangents if you've got a point outside
tangents from that point to the circle
if a point is outside this circle you
can make a pair of tangents to this
circle from that external point
if a point is lying outside the circle
you can make a pair of tangents two
tangents can be made from a point which
is lying outside this circle
in this chapter only two theorems are
there we'll see that in the next Slide
the theorem one is the tangent to a
circle is perpendicular to the radius
through the point of contact it means if
you have got a circle and this is its
there is a tangent at a point
so if you join the corresponding radius
through this point the tangent and
radius will be perpendicular through the
point of contact
total I don't exactly remember the name
ah that is DPT
and two theorems in circle yeah that you
can say two theorems are there yes
yes you are talking about the basic
proportionality theorem the proof of
which can be asked in the examination
and two theorems in the circle the first
one is the tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius to the point
of contact I got it hello Ram Charan
welcome to this session
is it here now I am not doing its proof
I hope you understand that if you want I
will do it as well but I am assuming
that these things you have done right
instead of that we can do some question
like you do its proof like this yes or
no if you remember it maybe I'll do it
once again for you so what you will do
this is the radius of the circle right
now you can assume some points suppose a
b
and C over here right and suppose the
point of contact is p so if you join
these points over here if you join this
over here if you join this over here
right so what you are seeing suppose
this is x y and this is Z over here
right so this is also radius this is
also radius I hope you understand this
is also radius so over here and suppose
this is O over here that's how you do
that right so op is equal to the radius
of the circle op is equal to radius now
what is O A if you see the figure o a is
equal to R plus x a r plus x a and that
is greater than radius or not just see
the figure in the same manner OB is
equal to what R Plus
y b r plus y b that is greater than R
this is y okay in the same manner what
is OC
OC is R plus z c and that is greater
than R right so what you will say of all
the distances between this line of all
the distances between AC and the center
of the circle o of all the distances
between AC and the center of the circle
o op is the shortest distance you got it
you will write this in your answer
exactly no only proof will not be of
five marks tushara obviously there will
be a question with that I hope you
understand
no no it's not like that Richard
obviously try to take a concept which is
there up till grade 10 don't take a very
Advanced concept I hope you understand
that because this is a great 10 math now
this is grade 10 math so don't take some
concept which is beyond the syllabus of
grade 10 I hope you understand that so
what you will see of all the distances
between AC and O op is the shortest
distance and the shortest distance
between a point and a line is the
perpendicular distance hence you will
say that OC AC is perpendicular to o p
you can say is it clear so that is the
proof of the tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius to the point
of contact will do everything in the
syllabus Rahul we have started from the
very first chapter we'll do it up till
the last chapter because this is a
marathon session exactly laksha you're
right
we'll do that as well Girish no problem
using Pythagoras you are talking about
yeah maybe that can be done hello
welcome to this session is it clear to
every student over here just comment in
the chat with a yes or no so that we can
move on to the next thing over here is
it clear guys
okay let us take the next thing the lens
of tangents drawn from an external point
to a circle are equal so the length of
tangents drawn from an external point to
a circle are equal you've got this
circle you make a pair of tangents from
this point to this circle over here this
is the center and you join it see I am
not writing everything I hope you
understand but if it is asked in the
examination you have to write everything
possible that is given to proof
construction proof everything you have
to do right or not so what you will do
over here in triangles if you take
triangles
o a p and o b p over here in these two
triangles you see over here o a is equal
to O B radius of the same Circle yes or
no radii of the same Circle o p is equal
to op is common op is equal to op is
common
and also over here ah angle a is equal
to angle B you have to write over here
okay since the tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius to the point
of contact tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius through the
point of contact so therefore can I not
say therefore triangle o a p is
congruent to Triangle o a p is congruent
to Triangle OBP right why rhs congruency
Criterion is it clear right angle
hypotenuse because these are right angle
triangles they are hypotenuse they are
equal and a side apart from the
hypotenuse they are equal so they are
congruent by rhs congruency Criterion so
if they are congruent by rhs we can say
p a is equal to p b by cpct they are
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles so these triangles are
congruent by cpct therefore p a is equal
to PB and that is the proof that the
length of 10 is drawn from an external
point to a circle are equal again I am
saying you have to write given to proof
construction and true everything you
have to mention in your answer is it
clear
no you cannot directly use that
jaswinder it is not in the syllabus of
cbse you cannot directly use alternate
segment theorem
I hope it is clear you cannot use
anything which is not you cannot use
anything directly in your subjective
answers which is not there in ncert you
understand that very clearly but
obviously if it's an objective question
and you know some like alternate segment
theorem or something called p t square
is your p n to p b if suppose some
question like this is asked you can do
it quickly because you know some
Shortcut things right so if you know you
can do it but in a subjective answer you
cannot use any shortcut which is not
given in ncrt I hope it is clear to
everybody over here now one more thing
is coming from here see if this angle is
X this is also X or Not by c p c t if
this is why this is also y by cpct yes
or no guys so now this is a separate
question which can be asked in the
examination it can be asked prove that
radii through the points of contacts or
maybe
weight ah
prove that the radio let me think this
statement proof that the
um
radii are equally inclined to the line
segment joining the center and the
external point you got it you understand
this is the line segment joining the
center and the external point of a of a
pair of tangents then the radii are
equally inclined to it or not tell me
because X these two angles are equal so
radii are corresponding radiar equally
inclined so that can be asked to proof
in the examination now that can also be
asked prove that a pair of tangents
drawn from an external point to a circle
is equally inclined to the line segment
joining the external point to the center
of the circle you got it
it was nice only but I was unable to
rephrase it I hope it is clear suppose
this can also be asked to prove these
angles to be equal and this statement
will be like this prove that
uh a pair of tanges drawn from from an
external point to a circle they are
equally inclined to the line segment
joining the external point and the
center of the circle you got it it means
this tangent and this tangent they are
equally inclined to this line segment
this can be asked in the examination as
a proof I hope it is clear to every
student or not tell me
these things can be asked so you don't
need to be confused that what is being
asked it is very simple I hope it is
clear to every student over here now one
more thing can be asked over here I will
explain
weight in this thing only
suppose you have got a circle you've got
a circle
and something like this is there
see you have studied that the tangent to
a circle is perpendicular to the radius
through the point of contact so this
will be 90 this will be 90 this is the
center of the circle suppose external
Point P this is suppose a and b
so can we not prove over here that angle
o plus angle p is equal to 180 yes or no
this can also be asked to prove that
proof that the angle made between a pair
of tangents drawn from an external point
to a circle and the angle made between
the corresponding radii through the
points of contacts they are
supplementary that can be asked in the
examination we already did three minty
quiz sessions yesterday at is as well
from 6 30 to 8 30 and we did many good
questions in that session can please see
that recording Aditya
exactly laksha you got it or not this
can also be asked that o plus p is 180
and this statement will be like this
that prove that the angle made between a
pair of tangents made from an external
point to a circle and the corresponding
radii through the point of contact they
are supplementary so o plus p is equal
to 180 can be asked its very simple
because you see this angle is 90 this is
90. the tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius to the point
of contact so you can use angle some
property in o b p a quadrilateral in
this quadrilateral you can use the angle
sum property sum of all these angles
will be 360. now this is nineteen ninety
ninety Plus 90 is 180 therefore o plus P
will be also 180 is it clear
Girish is it clear now I hope it is
clear now Girish because you see 1990
180 sum is 180 total sum of all these
angles C sum of I'll write over here if
you see
sum of angles o
o b p a
o b p a that is equal to 360 or not tell
me
is it clear but over here you know that
wait
over here you know that angle a is 90
angle B is 90. so therefore o plus P
will come out to be 180 or not tell me
is it clear to everybody fine
with reference diagram you drew please
write it once again because your chart
has gone up
triangle a b is an equilateral please
write it once again so that I will see
it okay till then you can try doing this
question let me know the answer please
rewrite your doubt it has gone up I was
not able to see it
so you see using these things I had
explained five six questions basically
and they can be asked in whichever way
possible and this is
a bit different question not very
complex it's a direct question only so
what is the answer to this question guys
tell me you have to find the angle of
aqb angle aqb over here
okay what about other students rishit
got 70 keshav also got 70 wasima Guru
very good that is the correct answer
basically see right now I have explained
if you see a o b p if you see AO BP over
here guys quadrilateral aobp this is 90
this is 90. so can I not say that angle
aob angle aob plus angle P will be 180
right now we have studied that property
so aob will be what guys angle aob plus
angle P is for T that is equal to 180
degrees over here so from here angle aob
will come out to be what guys this will
come out to be 140. now you have studied
in grade nine that angle subtended by an
arc of a circle at the center is twice
the angle subtended by it at any point
on the remaining part of the circle it
means that if you have got a circle
and you this is the center you take an
arc of it so angle subtended by an arc
of a circle at the center
tushara please rewrite it because I'm
explaining it and I know your doubt will
go up please copy and paste thus you
just have to copy and paste angle
subtended by an arc of a circle at this
Center
is twice the angle subtended by it at
any point on the remaining part of the
circle it means this angle is twice of
this is twice of this in the same manner
you see this Arc is making this angle at
the center and this Arc is making this
angle at a point on the remaining part
of the circle so therefore angle aob is
nothing but two times of angle AQ B
it is nothing but two times of angle a q
b over here
so from here what is angle a q b guys
angle a q b will come out to be 70. any
doubt in this question to any student in
the class
I hope it is clear in a few questions
the reference to diagram you drew in the
last panel A and B are join it is also
proven okay we will tell that no problem
is it clear massively repeated question
exactly but it is a bit twisted
therefore they ask it many a times okay
so tushara is asking one doubt I got
your doubt to Shara that they asked to
prove it uh
an equilateral triangle right ok so what
happens in those questions basically I
think in that question tushara this
angle is given if I am not wrong
basically tushara something like this is
given maybe I'm sure maybe I'm not
correct maybe this angle is given to be
60 tushara yes or no
this angle only English is not possible
you write because many students they
will not understand English Hindi
yes or no
okay angle subtended by an arc of a
circle is twice the angles of ah
scithesia the angle subtended by an arc
of a circle at the center is twice the
angle subtended by it at any point on
the remaining part of the circle you
have studied it in grade nine if you
have got a circle over here this is an
arc so this angle at this Center is
twice the angle
twice of all of these angles you have
studied that now in grade nine scient I
hope you understand
I hope it is clear now nilima
OK so you see tushara is asking how to
prove that this triangle is an
equilateral triangle ABC or this is an
equilateral triangle basically Tushar
writes a simple question you have
studied that the lens of tangents drawn
from an external point to a circle are
equal so this is equal to this or not
tushara lens of tangents drawn from an
external point to a circle are equal and
you know that angles opposite to equal
sides of a triangle are equal so these
angles will be equal or not to Shara now
you can use angle some property in this
triangle to Shara so can you not say 2x
plus 60 is 180
foreign
so from here you will get X is equal to
60 only so if you have got X is equal to
sixty sixty sixty sixty this is an
equilateral triangle or not is it clear
to Shara
no then that then you cannot prove it to
be an equilateral triangle it is not
necessary it is not compulsory that
every time it will be an equilateral
triangle it is not like that I hope you
understand that
what is your dot Sports gaming is there
any doubt okay you are talking
is it clear now to every student over
here any doubt to anybody guys
in these Concepts I hope this is clear
right
okay
now try doing this one guys you have to
find the value of r
b c is given to be equal to 5 a b is
twelve fine try doing this one let me
know the answer over here
BC is given to be equal to 5.
a B is 12.
and you have to find the value of the
r that is the radius of the circle you
have to find the radius of the circle
what happened game over by this
information will solve ID questions
based on no its not like that vinay
there are many other Concepts in IIT
even in Foundation there are many other
Concepts
even in Foundation ntse kbpy ioqm there
are many other Concepts which is not
there in cbse grade 10 math
okay I don't remember its answer
although hi ragul welcome to this
session
angle drawn from diameter is not able to
understand that
angle drawn from the diameter angle in a
semicircle is a right angle VIP Sports
gaming
hello Rahul welcome to the session okay
sure you people maybe this is a famous
question you must be remembering the
answer so you see this is given to be 90
degrees the first thing which you can
think of is can I use the uh Pythagoras
Theorem can I say AC square is equal to
a b square plus b c Square over here
so it is the first thing which you can
think so this is 12 square plus 5 square
and that will come out to be equal to if
you simplify 144 plus 25
169 and that is equal to 13 Square so
basically AC Square is 13 Square so you
can say AC will come out to be 13
centimeter so basically AC is nothing
but 13 centimeter I hope it is clear up
till here
no doubt in this question
now what we can do we have to find the
radius of the circle so how we can do
over here guys
ah
so see we have to find radius so can we
join these things over here guys we can
join these things these are radius of
the circle
radii of the circle let me think if if
there is any shortcut if if I can think
of
yeah in this question there is a
shortcut which can be used yes see this
is also R this is also R yes or no
now can I not say this thing is 12 minus
r guys and this thing is 5 minus r can I
say that
I'm sorry this thing is 5 minus r so
this is also 5 minus r or not because
lens of tangents drawn from an external
point to a circle are equal basically C
cube is equal to c r is equal to 5 minus
r or not lens of tangents drawn from an
external point to a circle are equal in
the same manner a p is equal to a r is
equal to 12 minus r or not lens of
tangents drawn from an external point to
a circle are equal tell me if it is
clear to you now you see what is AC over
here AC is nothing but
a r plus RC or not a r plus c r or not
now AC is 13 over here what is a r a r
is 12 minus r and CR is 5 minus r so
what you will get over here guys if you
simplify you will get 2R is equal to
17 minus 13 that is equal to 4 so from
here R will come out to be equal to 2
centimeter is the equation clear to
every student in the class exactly hemla
correct yeah but that you cannot use in
a school examination that is very good
ratio maybe you are preparing for some
competitive exam like if you are proving
if you are doing this write ntsc kvp by
then these things you can do it directly
but if it's a subjective examination if
you have to prove it you cannot do it
directly I hope it is clear yeah two is
the correct answer hello Rahul welcome
to the session what you want me to prove
VIP Sports gaming
yeah this is the tangent all of these
are tangents right all of these are
tangents
okay inscribed means see the word
inscribed here itself suggests that this
triangle is touching all of these ah
sides that's it
p b q
okay are you talking about that see this
is 90 tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius through the
point of contact this is also 90 this is
given to be 90 B is 90. so if you use
the angle sum property in this
quadrilateral can I not say this is also
90 tell me so therefore this becomes
this is R this is also R this is R this
is also you got it or not
I hope it is clear now samya
even if you prove it to be a square then
also it is done even if you prove it to
be a rectangle then also it is done no
problem in that
I hope it is clear I hope it is Clear
Sight Asia to every student
this is an ncrt Exemplar question and
these these questions can very well be
yeah otherwise it is a square only but
even if it is not a square you can even
if it is a rectangle then also your work
will be done yes or no and this question
obviously it can come in the examination
this is an ncrt Exemplar question okay
try doing this one let me know the
answer this is a tricky question
I am not saying that this is very tough
obviously it can be it can come in the
examination why this question is very
tough you have got a question which is
tougher than this in ncert as well
you have got that circles chapter I
think in in one question Heron's formula
is used yes or no and that question is
much more tough than this question yes
or no
okay
that question in which Heron's formula
is used in ncrt that is tougher than
this question it is it is simpler than
that one
I hope it is clear try doing this one
let me know the answer over here guys
yeah I don't remember the number of the
question whatever it is
so therefore see I am not taking all of
the ncrt questions because I am assuming
that you have already done the ncrt
questions now because needless to say
You must have done because you are going
to have examinations the day after
tomorrow
okay now let's do this the length of the
length L of a tangent drawn from a point
a to a circle is this so you have got a
circle over here you are drawing a
tangent from this point like this
suppose external point a
to this circle is four by three of the
radius suppose the point of contact is p
this thing is given to be 4 by 3 of the
radius okay you have to find the
shortest distance
from a to the circle what is the
shortest distance from a to the circle
see if you see the center of the circle
o
can I not say and suppose this is B
can I not say that we have to find a b
over here just see the figure and tell
me shortest distance of a from the
circle is a b or not tell me the
shortest distance between the circle and
the point a is a b
okay no problem bait blade okay let's
see Guru is it clear to everybody over
here shortest distance of point a from
the circle is a b over here now
basically we can use Concepts we can
join this thing and this will be 90 or
not because the tangent to a circle is
perpendicular to the radius through the
point of contact now op is also equal to
the radius or not guys tell me according
to the question op is equal to the
radius of the circle clear or not now if
you talk about triangle Opa it's a right
angle triangle so can we use the
Pythagoras Theorem can I say that o a
square is equal to op square plus p a
square over here guys
so what is O P Square o p square is R
square plus four R by three the whole
Square correct
now if you simplify what will you get
you will get just simplify it you can do
this this will be 16 upon 9 right so
this will give you basically 25 R square
by 9. so basically O A will come out
what guys O A will come out to be equal
to 5 R by 3. O A will come out to be 5r
by 3. now we have to find the value of a
b read the question properly so a b is
what if you see it patiently a b is
nothing but O A minus OB yes or no OB is
also radius now O A we already have got
5r by 3 this is 5 R by 3 minus r so if
you simplify this will give you 2 R by 3
so basically 2 R by 3 is the answer or
not tell me a b is equal to 2 R by 3 is
the answer but the answer is not in that
form the question is given
the length L of the tangent is 4 by 3 of
the radius so basically L is given to be
equal to 4 by 3 of the radius so in
place of R can I write 3 l by 4 in place
of r
can I write 3 l by 4 over here 3 l by 4
this will get canceled out so can I not
say that the answer is equal to l by 2
guys tell me L by 2 is the answer any
doubt in the question to any student
over here very good option C is
charactership
the shortest distance between a and the
circle will be a b or not just tell me
very logical thing it is is it clear
very good Muskan any doubt to any
student over here in this question
any doubt to any student in the class
guys
again I will say see you have to find
the shortest distance of this point from
the circle so common sense shortest
distance of this point from the circle
is a b or not it means we have to find a
b it is very simple now it is already
given that the length of the tangent
from a to the circle is 4 R by 3 it is
given in the question read it now this
is R so in Triangle Opa can you not use
the Pythagoras Theorem o a square will
be equal to R square plus 4r by 3 the
whole Square Solve It O A will come out
to be equal to 4 5r 5 by 3 R okay now we
have to find a b a b is nothing but O A
minus OB see the figure O A we have got
this OB is also radius so this has to be
two R by three so this is the answer but
the answer is not in the form of radius
one more information is given
L length of the tangent is given to be
equal to 4 by 3 r l is equal to 4r by 3
so from here R is 3L by 4 or not so over
here you can put R is equal to three L
by 4 you will get L by two is it clear
now
laksha is it clear
Krishna is it clear ragul is it clear
scytheja yashwant everybody else is it
clear
this is a tricky question but I hope it
is clear now it's not very tough but I
hope it is clear now
okay let us take the next thing now
now we'll do trigonometry okay very good
now let's do trigonometry now
so this thing obviously this is a right
angle triangle and we are talking about
this angle over here okay
sine Theta cos Theta these things are
clear needless to say you are going to
have exam the day after tomorrow so I am
again assuming that these things are
clear to you needless to say yes or no
needless to say so sine Theta is what
this is perpendicular this side opposite
to angle is perpendicular this side
adjacent to the angle is the base and
hypotenuse is fixed so you know what is
sine Theta tan Theta and cos Theta right
needless to say that sine Theta is p by
H cos Theta is B by H tan Theta is p by
B cot is reciprocal of tan so it is B by
P
cosec is reciprocal of sine so it is H
by P and SEC is reciprocal of cosine so
it is H by B clear or not basic thing it
is now one more thing I would say
it depends on the angle suppose I take
this angle Alpha so sine Alpha will
change right perpendicular for this
angle is B over here so in this triangle
sine Alpha is B by H in this triangle
cos Alpha is equal to P by H it is not
ah every time the same it it works
according to the angle I hope it is
clear ganta
see for every question there is no
specific trick you have to write
everything nilima
okay
please we will do that ok trigonometry
questions we'll do that we'll do that
don't bother
we'll do that we'll do some questions
don't bother okay I thought some other
proofing questions will do that have
patience
so I hope it is clear to everybody in
the class that it depends on the angle
so you don't have to it's not hard and
fast that every time sine Theta is p by
H you have to work according to the
triangle
OK and before that one more thing is
there see you can say over here that
sine Theta into cosec Theta will be one
or not tell me because they are
reciprocals of each other yes or not
guys if I say what is uh SEC Theta into
cos Theta
that is also one right in the same
manner tan Theta into cot Theta is also
1 because that they are reciprocals of
each other clear or not and one more
thing comes here only the tan Theta is
equal to sin Theta by cos Theta right or
not tan Theta is sine Theta by cos Theta
so in the same manner if you take cot
Theta it will be cos by sine right or
not exactly
exactly but many a times it will waste
your time rishit it will work with proof
practice only in a relationship I hope
it is clear
now trigonometric ratios for some
specific angle C when you move on to
higher classes grade 11 or if you are in
some Foundation thing like ntse and all
that so you must have done more than
this as as well but up till grade 10
ncrt cbse grade 10 you do angles up till
90 only 0 to 90. so how do you remember
this
you have to remember for sign right sine
0 is 0 sine 30 is half sine 45 is 1 by
root 2 sine 60 is root 3 by 2 sine 90 is
1. now in order to find the values for
cos what you do take the values of sine
in the reverse order yes or no in the
reverse order so cos 0 is equal to sine
90 is equal to 1 cos 30 is equal to sine
60 is equal to root 3 by 2 at 45 they
will be equal now cos 60 is equal to sin
30 is equal to half cos 90 is equal to
sine 0 is equal to 0 now tan Theta you
already know that is sin Theta by cos
Theta so it is sine a by cos a over here
you just have to divide and you have to
remember so 0 by 1 is 0 1 by 2 root 3 by
2 1 by root 3 in the same manner you
will get you got it now sine tan 90 is
not defined because 1 by 0 is not
defined division by 0 is not defined now
for others cot second cosec you have to
take reciprocals of sine cos and tan any
doubt in these
I cannot I cannot say the almost every
branch is good only siteja exactly yes
ragul therefore I am doing it quickly
okay is it clear to everybody any doubt
in these things guys how to remember
these values I needless to say these
values must be on your tips you have got
exams Day After Tomorrow you cannot
comment upon that I hope you understand
that okay
so try doing this one this is an ncrt
question only but many a Time students
have problem in this therefore I had
taken this question
so in Triangle opq right angle at p o q
is equal to 10 OP minus p q is equal to
2 you have to determine the value of
sine Q Plus cos Q that's it
okay try doing this one so over here
guys you can make a triangle and better
to assume values right right angled at P
this triangle is right angled at p and
this is O P Q so can I not say that P Q
is X if I assume p q to be X so op will
be X plus 2 or not tell me op will be X
plus 2 that's it
and oq is given to be equal to 10 that's
it so now you can use the Pythagoras
theorem in this right angle triangle
because you see o q square is equal to
op square plus p q square right so you
can use the Pythagoras Theorem this is
10 Square and that is equal to op square
is X plus 2 the whole square and P Q
square is x square now you can
take the values over here this will be
100 over here
and this is x square plus 4X plus 4
plus x square so what you will get over
here you will get 2x square plus 4X
let's do it quickly 2 x square plus 4X
uh
minus 96 right that is equal to 0 so
divide on both these sides by 2 Guys you
will get x square plus two x minus
that is equal to 0 so what will you get
over here guys 8 6 or 48 so what I can
say over here guys
I can say X Plus 8 into
x minus 6 I will get yes or no
yes so from here the value of x is minus
8 comma six so distance cannot be
negative so I'll neglect this value so X
is equal to 6 is correct right so this
is 6 this is 6 and this is 6 plus 2 8.
so if we have got these values we can
easily find exactly very simple yes so
let's find the value of sine Q Plus cos
Q so what is sine Q over here
perpendicular upon hypotenuse so 8 upon
10 plus
cos Q is based upon this so 6 upon 10 so
don't change the values it will be
easier
14 by 10 so that will be 1 by 4 1 by 4
is the answer any doubt in the question
to any student over here
tell me
is it clear to every student in the
class
okay and one more thing I would say in
this although it is not related to this
question but I would explain one simple
concept using this question see many a
times what I have seen I am explaining
over here maybe I am not visible to you
what I have seen many a times what
students do and I have seen teachers
also unfortunately a b c this is 90
so
so suppose it is this angle is Theta and
suppose sin Theta is given to be equal
to maybe three by five
right so what people do this is
perpendicular and this is hypotenuse
this is base I have seen students doing
p is equal to 3 and H is equal to 5. if
you are doing like this you will not get
full marks it will be wrong I hope you
understand that
because this is just a ratio you cannot
say p is equal to 3 and H is equal to 5
it will be wrong
poor gaming if uh in the last question
poor gaming if I am assuming PQ to be X
so op will be X plus 2 or not I hope it
is clear poor gaming
okay
yeah that is the same thing black glass
C whatever it is whatever be the method
of remembering things if you practice
enough number of questions automatically
you remember
you cannot do that also black glass
which you are saying that is very good
that is tricky but in the examination
you cannot do that now it is all
practice if you practice you will be
able to remember sine Theta cos Theta
and tan Theta values I hope it is clear
now this thing is clear or not if you
say p is equal to 3 if you say p is
equal to 3 and H is equal to five it is
mathematically wrong and your marks will
be deducted for sure even if your answer
is correct because this is the ratio of
two things so you have to say that P is
equal to sum 3x and H is equal to some
5x where X is the common variable X is a
common factor over there you got it
exactly otherwise it yeah that can be
correct
in that question if you take o p is
equal to X then also you will get the
same answer PSI Theta I hope you
understand that
so is this thing clear to everybody
please don't do that please don't p is
equal to 3 and H is equal to 5 like that
it is not that this is the ratio P can
also be 6 and this can also be 10 this
can be 12 and this can be 20 right it is
the ratio of two things I hope you
understand that if you are taking things
directly you will not get full marks 100
you will not get full marks I hope you
understand that guys so don't do that
I hope this question is also clear
okay now try doing this one this is a
very simple question again you have to
find the value of tan Y and Tan x over
here
try doing this one let me know the
answer what is the answer over here
so over here as well D is the midpoint D
is given as the midpoint so can we not
assume that this is X this is also X it
will save our time now we have to find
the value of tan y so this uh why is
this total guys why is this total so tan
y will be what I'll find tan y tan is
perpendicular by base So Tan Y is
nothing but b c upon AC s or no b c upon
AC and Tan x is what guys it is DC upon
ACS or no DC upon AC perpendicular Pawn
base so this will get canceled out it is
b c upon DC or not BC upon DC now what
is b c over here BC is equal to 2x DC is
equal to X only so the answer is 2. is
it clear to every stone very good that
is the correct answer very good ratio it
is not being asked so you can directly
say 2 is the answer Kesh up I hope you
understand that
one is to 2 is not the answer 2 is the
answer see actually in the actual
question it was caught therefore I had
taken tan just to confuse you maybe it's
a simple question only I hope it is
clear to every student in the class
right
ok
now let us see trigonometric identities
over here again I am not proving the
identities although there is a proof to
each of these identities this is cos
Square Theta obviously using a right
angle triangle and Pythagoras Theorem
these identities are proved so sine
Square theta plus cos Square Theta is
equal to 1 sine Square Theta can be
written as 1 minus cos Square Theta
depending upon the situation in the same
manner cos Square Theta can be written
as 1 minus sine Square Theta depending
upon the situation okay
Now 1 plus tan Square Theta is equal to
SEC Square Theta So Tan Square Theta can
be written as 6 Square Theta minus 1
depending upon the situation and SEC
Square Theta minus tan Square Theta can
be written as 1 depending upon the
situation now one thing is very
important over here which you must
remember can I use a square minus b
square identity over here SEC Square
Theta minus tan Square Theta I can write
SEC theta plus tan Theta
into SEC Theta minus tan Theta
SEC Theta minus tan Theta that is equal
to 1. so what does it mean it means that
SEC theta plus tan Theta is Theta minus
tan Theta they are reciprocals of each
other it means suppose the value of SEC
theta plus tan Theta is X the value of
SEC Theta minus tan Theta will be 1 by X
or suppose if the value of SEC Theta
minus tan Theta is anything P the value
of SEC theta plus tan Theta is equal to
1 by P so suppose I am asking a simple
question if if suppose it is given that
if SEC theta plus tan Theta is equal to
any value you can take maybe it is
trigonometrically it can be wrong
because I am not using ranges and all
that thing maybe it is fine
so can you tell me what is the value of
cot Theta over here
what is the value of quad Theta guys if
SEC theta plus tan Theta is 5 can you
tell me what is the value of cot Theta
try doing this and let me know the
answer quickly if SEC theta plus tan
Theta is equal to 5 what is the value of
cot Theta which you can find over here
so if you apply this identity I mean the
expanded form of that identity you can
do it easily otherwise you will do waste
your time it will be wasted your wasting
your time so you have to find quad Theta
in this question so what what we can do
over here
what we can do over here guys
see SEC theta plus tan Theta we know in
the question so can I not say what is
SEC Theta minus tan Theta SEC Theta
minus tan Theta is the reciprocal of SEC
theta plus tan Theta this is equal to 1
by 5 you got it so what I can do I have
to find the value of cot Theta suppose
this is the first equation and this is
the second equation so I want to
eliminate SEC Theta can I do like this
first equation minus second equation SEC
Theta will be eliminated it will be
canceled out so I will get 2 tan Theta
right I will get 2 tan Theta is equal to
5 minus 1 by 5 correct so this will be
25 minus one twenty four by five so this
is twenty four by five so from here can
I not say that tan Theta is coming out
to be 12 upon 5 this is 12 upon five so
can I not say that cot Theta is
reciprocal of it it is 5 by 12. is this
clear so you can do it quickly like this
5 by 12 is the correct answer I I had
asked cot Theta I hope it is clear to
every student trishanth keshav five by
twelve very good navedram ravindran I
hope the question is clear so this is a
very important result which you can use
in doing questions suppose over here cos
Theta is being asked so if suppose cos
Theta is being asked what will you do
you will add the equations right or not
you will do 1 plus 2 So Tan Theta will
be eliminated out so you will get 2 SEC
Theta is equal to 5 plus 1 by 5 so this
is what 25 plus 1 26 by 5 over here
and over here you will get SEC Theta to
be equal to
13 by 5 so you will get cos Theta is
equal to 5 by 13.
I hope it is clear to you so like this
you can do questions
this is an important result I hope it is
clear to you
in the same manner if you see this
identity one plus quad Square Theta is
equals x square Theta everybody knows
that and depending upon the need you can
write cos Square Theta is equal to cos x
square Theta minus 1 and cos x square
Theta minus cos Square Theta is equal to
one but you can use a square minus b
square identity over here cos x square
Theta minus Square Theta can be written
as
cosec theta plus cot Theta a plus b a
minus B identity cosec theta plus cot
Theta into
cosec Theta minus cos Theta right cosec
Theta minus cot Theta and that is equal
to 1 what does it mean it means that
cosec theta plus cot Theta and cosec
Theta minus Square Theta they are
reciprocals of each other if you know
suppose cosec theta plus cot Theta is
six then the value of cosec theta minus
cot Theta will be equal to one by six if
suppose the value of cosec theta minus
cos Theta is eight then the value of
cosec theta plus cos Theta is one by
eight is it clear to every student in
the class
this thing must be clear so suppose I
ask a question if
if suppose it is given that cosec Theta
minus cot Theta
if suppose cosec Theta minus cot Theta
anything you can take I am just taking
random values okay it can be
trigonometrically it can be wrong if you
talk about domain and range when you go
on to higher classes but I am just
trying to make you this concept clear
suppose this is 10 right so can you tell
me what is the value of sine Theta
can you tell the value of sin Theta guys
if cosec Theta minus Square Theta is
equal to 10 can you tell what is the
value of sin Theta am I Audible and
visible guys nobody is writing anything
are you guys able to hear and see me
are these things not clear to if it is
not clear please write in the chat so
that I can explain it once again but I
hope it is clear
okay
no siteja we have to find the value of
sine Theta I want the value of sine
Theta
tell its answer please quickly
uh okay is it something like that okay
maybe some big values must be coming no
problem in that see suppose this is the
first equation
so see I know the value of cosec theta
minus cot Theta and I know that cosec
Theta minus cos Theta and cosec theta
plus Square Theta they are reciprocals
of each other so can I not say that the
value of cosec theta plus cot Theta the
value of the cosec theta plus cot Theta
will be 1 by 10 yes or no because they
are reciprocals of each other now I want
the value of sine Theta so I can treat
these equations as linear equations in
two variables can I not add these
equations I can add 1 and 2 over here so
you see cot and cot will get canceled
out what will I get over here I will get
2 cosec Theta 2 cosec Theta is equal to
10 plus 1 by 10 yes or no 10 plus 1 by
10 this will be 100 plus 1 100 1 by 10
over here so cosec Theta is what guys
over here cosec Theta
is is equal to 101 by 20 now I want the
value of sine Theta so sine Theta will
be what sine Theta will be 20 upon 101
this is the answer is the question clear
to every student over here 20 upon 1
very good group Prasad very good keshav
yeah you are also almost correct wasima
but you must have done slight mistake
I hope this thing is clear to every
student over here so this is also one
identity extended form of this identity
which can be used in questions I hope it
is clear now suppose I am asking one
question it has come in in my mind and
then we can move on to the next slide
simple question only suppose if
sine theta plus cosec Theta
a very simple question sin theta plus
cosec Theta is equal to 2
can you find the value of sine raised to
the power
2023 theta plus cosec raised to the
power
2023 Theta
can you tell what is the answer to it
if sine theta plus cosec Theta is equal
to 2 can you find the value of sine
Theta raise to the power 2023
okay and cosec Theta raise to power
these things can be asked in the
examination in objective questions
especially in these years in like in the
second in the last two years these type
of questions they are asked
so over here
it's a trick question it's a simple
question basically see sine 90 is what
sine 90 is 1 cosec 90 is also 1 yes or
no so sine 90 Plus cosec 90 is 2 or not
tell me sine 90 Plus cosec 90 is 2 so
can I not say Theta is nothing but if
you compare these things Theta is
nothing but 90 only
so basically sine Theta is 1 because
sine 90 is 1 and cosec 90 is also one so
one raised to the power 2023 question
one raised per 2023 it will be two only
so whether it is sine raised to power
2020 to Theta or cosec raise to power
two thousand twenty two three I will get
the same answer I hope it is clear yeah
it's a very easy it will be two site
okay are you talking about that other
thing I hope it is clear to every
student over here in the class
foreign
now let us do this thing can you try
doing this one let me know the answer
can you tell me what is the value of cot
Theta over here
if 9 sine Square theta plus 2 cos Square
Theta is equal to 3 can you find the
value of cot Theta
what is the answer to this question guys
so again it's a it's an identity based
question only you can manipulate it a
bit right 9 sine Square Theta 9 sine
Square theta plus 2 cos Square Theta
3 can be written as what guys three can
be written as 3 into 1 over here right
so basically one is nothing but sine
Square theta plus cos Square Theta I can
say over here so sine Square theta plus
cos Square Theta over here so this is
nothing but three sine Square theta plus
three cos Square Theta I hope it is
clear 3 sine Square theta plus 3 cos
Square Theta
3 sine Square Theta you can take over
there
it will give you 6 sine Square Theta
and that is equal to 3 cos Square Theta
minus two cos Square Theta is equal to
cos Square Theta right now I want quartz
cot Theta so I will take sine Square
Theta over here so cos Square Theta by
sine Square Theta cos Square Theta by
sine Square Theta is equal to 6 so can I
not say that cot Square Theta is equal
to 6 so we are not talking about the
negative value although you will get
plus minus Root 6 but we are neglecting
negative value until grade 10 cbse math
so this will be Root 6 Root 6 is the
answer exactly I hope the question is
clear to every student over here
will it effectively take two plus one
which question are you talking about
black glass 2 plus 1 will be wrong now
are you talking about this question
not able to understand your doubt
black glass Musical
what is your doubt
I hope this question is clear to every
student over here
ok now see this is an ncrt ah
why will you do two plus one not able to
understand that
two plus one for three no that is also
okay two plus one for three
but will you get anything after that
black glass I mean it can be done it is
not hard and fast I am not saying that
this is hard and fast but it will make
it more complex now why will you think
like that you got it or not black black
glass
I mean it it is simple if you do like
that it is ok two plus one for three it
will not fulfill your purpose if you
think
it will not fulfill your purpose right
it will make it more complex I I think
okay
okay now this is an ncert question only
you have to prove it right so basically
uh if you was if you if you will take
sine and cos over here it will make it
very complex
oh yeah I was just thinking also maybe
see I'm not able to think right now
everything I hope you understand that no
problem you can think also
it's not that there is one method for
one question right
yeah that's what I am thinking
see you just can change in place of
three you can write like this or not
tell me
Aruna in place of three you can write
this three sine Square theta 3 cos
Square Theta now this you can subtract
over here and this you can subtract over
here so will you get this Aruna now you
want cot Square cot Theta you can divide
it over here so will you not get cos
Square divided by sine square is equal
to 6 Aruna cot Square by sine Square
will be cot Square so cot is equal to
root six although you will take all you
will get a negative value as well but
you will neglect the negative value
because up till greater than
trigonometry we are not talking about
other angles up till great uh
apart from 90 degrees up till 90 degrees
only you talk about right in the first
quadrant basically 0 to 90 degrees I
hope it is clear now this is an ncert
question if you will convert things in
sine and cos then also will get the
answer but it will waste your time so
instead of doing that we have got tricks
to do this type of question right
take is also its also not a very ah like
big thing which can be done over here
so what we can do over here is if you
take the left hand side guys over here
what we will get
so you'll get SEC theta plus tan Theta
minus 1 SEC theta plus tan Theta minus 1
over here
divided by tan Theta
minus SEC Theta in place of this one in
place of this one can I get SEC Square
Theta minus tan Square Theta can I put
SEC Square Theta minus tan Square Theta
in place of that is it clear or not tell
me
now what I can get over here I can just
simplify see this is SEC Theta minus tan
Theta SEC Theta minus tan Theta minus 1
and over here out of these things can I
take minus 1 s common so SEC Theta minus
tan Theta will be left say Theta minus
tan Theta will be left now for this
thing what I can do a plus b a minus B
identity I can use so it will be SEC
theta plus tan Theta into SEC Theta
minus tan Theta right Sig Theta minus
tan Theta I can do I hope it is clear to
you now out of the whole expression in
the denominator out of the whole
expression can I take SEC Theta minus
tan Theta is common in the denominator
so what will I left you see SEC Theta
minus tan Theta minus 1 over here and in
the denominator if I take SEC Theta
minus tan Theta s common
so I'll be left with what guys I will be
left with
minus 1 plus SEC Theta
okay it is not happening basically
it means
wait
so it is SEC theta plus tan Theta it is
not happening I did some
ok so it means basically this is not
doing anything I hope it is clear
yeah I got it
no no rationalize there is nothing
called rationalization in this thing
rishit because these are not irrational
numbers that is not rationalization that
is fitting in an identity I hope it is
okay
only Hindi is not possible Right
tan sign error
wait wait
no no sign I had taken correctly only
SEC theta plus tan Theta SEC Theta minus
tan Theta
sine is correct only with SEC theta plus
this is SEC theta plus tan Theta yeah
that's what I was thinking
SEC theta plus tan Theta minus one sec
Theta percent ok so it is okay with you
guys so this will get canceled out yes
or no so I am left with what I am left
with 1 by 60 that's what I was thinking
that why I'm not getting it so SEC Theta
minus 90 right so the answer is not in
this form cell we can also again
manipulate it I hope it is clear no it
will work yeah yeah I hope it is clear
now so ah now nothing is happening now
so nothing is happening so what we must
do now tell me
let us convert into sine n cos that's it
so this will be 1 by cos minus sine by
cos yes or no minus sine by cos
so yeah so you see we've got the answer
if you simplify this will be 1 by 1
minus sine by cos
and this will go in the numerator cos
will go in the numerator so it will be
cos by 1 minus sign so we have got the
answer I hope it is clear so yeah one
student rishit I think was saying if I'm
from yeah if I'm taking your name
correctly rishita rishit that is not
rationalization that is fitting in an
identity rationalization is a different
thing no not conjugate as well why
conjugate see you talk about conjugate
and rationalization when you have got
irrational numbers or complex numbers
something like that now so that is not
rationalization or taking conjugate I
hope you got it kalvi because that is
fitting in an identity basically you're
fitting things in an identity that's it
is it clear to every student over here
no that is nothing called conjugation I
mean that you do in case of irrational
numbers or complex numbers when you
study in grade 11. so I hope it is clear
to everyone in in this class any doubt
to anybody please click write in the
chat so that we can move on to the next
question
this was an NCR this is an ncrt question
but still I had taken it because you can
make sure in your mind that everything
you every time you don't need to convert
in sign and cost many a times tricks
work like sample for example this is a
trick na you have to think that in your
mind that over here I have to put this
okay
trishanth you just have to put SEC
Square minus tan Square over here you
can do that trishanth now you see out of
this thing I can take minus 1 s common
and this thing can be written like this
trishanth you see this now in the
denominator trishanth can I take SEC
minus tan s common so you see this will
be left in the denominator after
simplification you see the same thing
over here and over here they will get
canceled out so we are left with 1 by 6
minus one by time change in sign and cos
you will get the answer is it clear
trishanth
smart this is a smart trick only this is
a smart trick only for this question
no no no this is not lengthy if you will
change in sign and cost so you see many
a times if things are lengthy but it is
tricky but if you change in sign and cos
you have to work too much now you have
to fix an identity the thing which was
which rishit was saying you have to do
that I hope you understand my point now
what about this question
wait this is not working
give me some second okay
okay now how do we do this question this
is a previous year question only cbse
previous year question
welcome to this session
what about this question
this is the cbse previous year question
so every time many things can be used
basically trigonometric identity
questions are a combination of
trigonometric identities and algebraic
identities as well you got a
transposition no transposition will not
be needed in this question ratio
so maybe more than one method is there
in a high akshaya welcome to the session
it's not that only one method will be
used more than one method can also be
used in questions it's not that they are
fixed hi Lakshmi welcome to this session
so let's do this question will use
identities over here
so you have studied this identity right
A minus B the whole Cube identity in
grade nine this is a cube minus B Q
minus 3 A square B minus 3 A square B
plus 3 a b square right you have studied
this you see a minus B the whole cube is
what AQ minus B Q minus three A square B
plus three a b square so if you take the
left hand side over here of this thing
in place of sine C in place of a I am
writing Theta because a is boring Theta
I will do it quickly okay so it is sine
raised to the sine response 6 Theta so
can I write it like this sine Square
Theta the whole raised to the power 3
over here right like this
now ah
in place of sine Square Theta I want 1
minus cos Square Theta over here and cos
Square Theta I will leave it as it is
see I want cos Square Theta only now you
see the right hand side I want cos
Square Theta only so I will try to
change everything in cos square or not
tell me now sine Square can be written
as 1 minus cos Square again 1 minus cos
Square Theta the whole Cube now open
this bracket this is 3 cos Square theta
3 cos Square Theta minus three cos
raised to the power 4 Theta ok now we
can use a minus B the whole Cube
identity over here so it is a cube that
is 1 Cube minus
cos Square Theta the whole Cube will be
what guys cos Square Theta the whole
Cube will be cos raised to cos 6 Theta
and then it is ah
minus 3 A square B a square is 1 square
and B is this so minus 3 cos Square
Theta it is plus 3
3 a b square a is 1 and B is this cos
Square Theta will be what cos raised to
the power 4 Theta that's it we are just
using identity and this will remain as
it is this will remain 3 cos Square
Theta minus 3 cos raised to the power 4
Theta so you see over here this will get
canceled out this will get canceled out
have we got the answer guys this is 1
minus cos raised to the power 6 Theta
which is equal to the rhs
I hope it is clear hello and welcome to
the session please don't spam guys
please don't spam cradle because other
students will get confused hi haran
welcome to this session
I hope this is clear to every student
over here any doubt in this question
guys
we are doing that only Anand see that's
what I am saying it is about practice
and it is about knowing algebraic
identities as well if you know every
algebraic identity properly you will be
able to do questions many a times
basically proving trigonometric
identities require many other Concepts
as well it's not only trigonometry you
require rationalization you require
rearrangement many times so it will
require practice please do not spam over
there
hello shinchan lovers I hope it is clear
to every student in the class any doubt
in this session in this thing guys
any doubt to any student over here
please confirm in the chat
okay
so try doing this one this is again a
very famous this type of questions these
are you will you will say
normal questions they are they can be
asked many a times so try doing this one
let me know the answer over here
that what will be the value of 5 5 sine
Theta minus 3 cos Theta conventional
questions these are basically
none of the questions which I have
discussed over here is outside from even
r s Agarwal
okay okay
you can see just you can see you will
get it see scytheja in place of this
thing just see that we can write it like
this sine Square Theta the whole Cube
sine Square Theta is 1 minus cos Square
Theta the whole Cube now use a minus B
the whole Cube identity that you can do
on your own you will get this thing
now in place of sine Square Theta I have
used 1 minus cos Square Theta after
simplification I have got this simplify
you'll get the answer
is it clear naveindran
Shin-chan lovers naveindran Sai Teja is
it clear now
okay
do by the side of me I mean it's not
like that if you will just see the board
you will not be able to do it now how
will you do this type of question C it's
again something see I'm being honest
every time you will not get a new
question in the board examination now
you'll get questions which you have
already seen earlier so questions you
must be remembering that how to do it
see I want to find the value of this
thing so can I say like this if you see
this 5 sine Theta minus 3 cos Theta if
you take its Square 5 sin Theta minus
three cos theta plus can I take it this
is three sine Theta
3 sine theta plus 5 cos Theta the whole
Square
so what will I get if I simplify it see
it very patiently this is what this is
25 sine Square Theta 25 sine Square
Theta and that will give you
minus 30 sine Theta cos Theta
30 sin Theta cos Theta okay
plus 9 cos Square Theta you will get 9
cos Square Theta you just see on the
board you'll get it I am sure about that
and this is 9 sine Square Theta over
here and this will give you plus five
threes or 15 into 230
sine Theta cos Theta
and this will give you 25 cos Square
Theta a plus b the whole Square identity
and a must be the whole Square identity
now you see 30 sine Theta cos theta plus
30 sin Theta cos there is getting
canceled out now what is this 25 plus 9
is what 34 so 34 sine Square Theta 34
cos Square Theta so is it 34
sine Square theta plus cos Square Theta
guys
so sine Square theta plus cos Square
Theta is nothing but one so can I say
this is equal to 34 tell me this is
coming out to be equal to 34 exactly
very good you people already got the
answer go cool you see
this is 34. now you see the value of
this thing is already given in the
question that is 5. so can I not say
this thing 5 sine Theta
minus 3 cos Theta the whole Square
the value of this thing is 5 so I will
say plus 5 square and that is equal to
34 or not tell me guys so from here can
I not say that 5 is sine Theta minus 3
cos Theta
the whole square that will be equal to
34 minus 25 that is 9. so from here can
I not say that 5 sine Theta minus 3 cos
Theta will be equal to plus minus 3 this
is the answer is the equation clear to
every student in the class tell me is it
clear plus minus 3 is the answer very
good option 2 is the correct answer very
good harun rishit somesh navindran
siteja I hope it is clear to every
student over here
so let us move on to the next thing over
here guys
is it clear to everybody just confirm
once in the chart so that we can move on
to the next thing
OK very good
now try doing this one the angle of
elevation of a cloud from a point 60
meter above a lake is 30 degree and the
angle of depression of the reflection of
the cloud
in the lake is 60 degree find the height
of the cloud over here
see I'll re-explain like that see
whenever you get a question like this
sine cos is there sine cos is there so
what you will do just see it very
patiently grease you'll understand it
quickly if I take square of this
Plus
square of this I rearrange it right so I
can use a minus B the whole Square
identity I will get this I can use a
plus b the whole Square identity I will
get this Girish okay Girish now you see
this will get canceled out Girish fine
now you see 25 plus 9 sine Square Theta
25 plus 9 is 34 25 plus 9 is 34 so 34
sine Square theta plus cos Square Theta
Girish sine Square zero plus cos square
is one so therefore it is 34. now Girish
it is given in the question already that
sine theta 3 sin theta plus 5 cos Theta
is five you see over there so therefore
this is 5 Square so thirty four minus 25
will be 9 or not Girish so therefore the
value of this thing will be what you
have to take the square root of both the
sides therefore plus minus three is it
clear Greece
is it clear okay rishit I don't remember
the answer Girish just confirming the
chart if it is clear or not
sorry we can move on to the next
question okay very good try doing this
one this is also one of the famous
questions these are
so the angle of elevation of a cloud
from a point 60 meter above a lake is
30. so you have got a lake this is the
level of the lake okay
so from a point 60 meter above a lake
there is a point P 60 meter above the
lake
from this point angle of elevation of
the cloud is given this is the cloud
suppose C okay is 60 degree ah wait what
is given
30 degree so angle of elevation is 30
degree over here fine
and it is given that and the angle of
depression of the reflection of the
cloud in the lake is 60. so see this is
cloud its image Its Reflection will be
somewhere over here or not tell me its
image will be somewhere over here and
the angle of depression of from that
point is given to be 60. it is given to
be 60 over here right now you have to
find the height of the cloud that is the
question you have to find the height of
the cloud
find this this situation is clear now
suppose the height of the cloud is this
obviously above the lake suppose it is X
you have to find the height of the cloud
above the lake that is X over here
okay
now you see this is also 60 or not tell
me guys this thing is 60.
so this thing will be what guys this is
x minus 60 or not this thing is x minus
60 over here okay
now one more thing the this is a
reflection guys so height of the cloud
above the lake and the depth of its
image below the lake will also be X or
not tell me depth of its image below the
lake is also X I hope it is clear to you
depth of its image below the lake is
also X now this is y over here this is
90. so suppose uh
suppose this point is a this point is a
now we have to use trigonometry two
times and we'll get the answer so if you
talk about triangle p a c over here if
you talk about triangle Pac can I take
tan 30 over here guys tan 30 will be
what x minus 60 by y over here tan 30 is
1 by root 3.
so why will be what guys y will be root
3 into x minus 60. this is the first
equation in the same manner if you take
triangle p a d if you take p a d
triangle can I take tan 60 over here tan
60 will be what guys perpendicular upon
base so X plus 60 by y you see the
figure properly X plus 60 by y now you
see tan 60 is root 3 so y will be what
guys y will be over here X plus 60 by
root 3.
I hope it is clear now you see they both
are y this is why this is y so they both
will be equal or not over here so I can
say root 3 into x minus 60 that is equal
to
X plus 60 by root 3 this is the thing so
if you cross multiply root 3 into root 3
will be equal to 3 so it is 3 into x
minus 60 that is equal to X plus 60 over
here let us simplify it further so this
will be 3x minus six threes are 18 that
is equal to X plus 60 and this will give
you 2x is equal to ah 240 over here so
therefore X is coming out to be 120
meter therefore the height of the cloud
above the lake is 120 meter is the
question clear very good everybody got
the answer scient very good harun Guru
Prasad anju samesh any doubt to any
student over here in the class okay
Navin run very good see again I would
like to add one more Point needless to
say
I am explaining these things you people
are getting the correct answer but you
have to do it in a subjective
examination okay rishit
so you have to write everything possible
see I am not writing everything due to
lack of time obviously otherwise it will
take 15 hours but needless to say you
have to write everything possible in
your examination you cannot skip
statements I have checked answer sheets
of many students they get the answer
correctly they do not give proper
reasons they do not write statements
many a times I have seen that they write
units they do not write correct units
right so you have to make sure that your
answer is wholesome it's not just about
correct answer it must be written in a
perfect manner so as to get full Mark so
if you know something properly you must
get full marks there is no point getting
even one mark less if you know
everything in the question paper I hope
it is clear to every student over here
any doubt in that
ok so I guess ah this will be areas
related to circles so I guess uh we'll
we are going to take a break right I am
going to take a break
only one formula is there will do
questions we'll do everything you don't
have to bother so taking one more break
of uh 13 14 minutes okay after that
we'll be resuming with the class no
laksha right now I'm not doing that I'm
doing up till Foundation levels okay
after the doubt after the break we'll do
that because I have to like drink water
and I have to get fresh for some time
okay
if the figure is clear the question must
be clear see there is a lake for you
samya cloud is there 60 meter sorry a
point is there 60 meter above it angle
of elevation of the cloud from that
point is given and then angle of
depression of the image of the cloud
inside the lake is given that is 60. now
Samia if this is X this will also be X
because object distance is equal to
image distance because this is a
reflection you have studied in physics
now samya this is 60 so this is also 60
so this will be x minus 60. now if you
talk about this triangle somya can you
not get this thing you see tan 30 is
equal to x minus 60 by y
so from here tan Thirty is one by root 3
so y will be root 3 x minus 60 just see
this in the same manner if you talk
about triangle p a d you see the figure
tan 60 will be what guys X plus 60 by y
so from here you can find find Y in
terms of xiaomia so using both equations
y you can compare so from here you will
get this and solve this for X you'll get
the answer is it clear somia
is it clear now
I hope it is clear soumya please confirm
in the chart yeah obviously we are
talking about board exams only haran so
it will be easy only it's not going to
be tough
some one or two questions are taken
tough deliberately but those questions
will also not come in the examination
tough questions will not come it's a
board examiner obviously needless to say
so I hope these concepts are clear to
every student over here we are taking a
13 14 minutes break and then we'll be
doing the other left out chapters will
going we are going to cover the whole
syllabus you don't have to bother about
that 0 0 plus 2 is 2 only okay
ok fine
so uh
so let us do that guys
so I am writing 15 over here but it will
not take 15 minutes but still I am
taking writing that okay
foreign
welcome to
the session are you guys ready
why are you guys writing your comments
and your uh removing your comments what
happened
so are you guys ready okay so let's wait
for some more seconds later the students
join and then we can start like actually
some like 34 30 40 more seconds were
left yes I'm back again you people are
also back
okay no doubt hello haran welcome to
this session so I think four chapters
are left right that area is related to
circles surface areas and volumes and
statistics and probability right
hello I think four more chapters are
left right or not
yep hello vinayak welcome to this
session hello venkatsai welcome to this
session
okay
so I think will wrap up like around at
around I think I don't I although I
cannot say like 6 30 maybe or maybe 6 45
will be able to complete this session
right hello Karima welcome to this
session Karima hello triveni
hello Virat welcome to this session
okay so guys we are good to start now so
let's start with it I'm doing good I
hope you are doing good as well yeah
obviously I'm I'm a bit tired
so it's natural nothing no problem in
that right I want full marks from you
people if you are here if you have done
if you have prepared well for your exams
there is no point of losing marks you
must get full marks right there is no
point losing marks in unnecessary things
right you must get full marks if you
have already prepared properly the day
before tomorrow you are having exams
so I hope very well for you people so
let's start with it guys the next
chapter is uh wait
okay this is not working no problem
okay
so it is uh areas related to circles so
let's start with it hi site Asia okay
another very good okay so let's start it
with it very simple topic this is areas
related to circles
so if you have got a circle over here
wait guys there is some issue just give
me some seconds
okay
so if you have got a circle over here
and its radius is R so its area is you
already know that is pi R square and
diameter is two times of the radius so
radius can be written as d by 2 right it
can be written as d by 2 so therefore
area is also equal to Pi into d by 2 the
whole Square which will come out to be
equal to Pi d square by four any doubt
in that and circumference of a circle is
2 pi r and in place of 2R you can write
Pi d as well clear or not now if you
have got a semi circle over here
semicircle radius is R so you see for
total Circle it is 2 pi r so for half of
this circle it will be pi r so
circumference a perimeter of a
semicircle will be what guys pi r but
you have to take the diameter as well in
this perimeter of a semicircle so
therefore it is pi r plus Dr the
perimeter of a semicircle is pi r plus
Dr clear and area of a semicircle will
obviously be half the area of the circle
I hope it is clear
obviously you will get full marks if you
have prepared well
yes very well you will do that you
people can do that okay
now area of a quadrant quadrant is one
fourth of a circle guys it is one fourth
of a circle so its area will be what one
fourth of the area of the circle area of
the circle divided by four now perimeter
of a quadrant will be what guys for
total Circle it is 2 pi r
for total Circus Circle it is 2 pi r so
one fourth of it is this part divided by
4 plus you have to include the radii as
well to 2R so perimeter of the quadrant
will be pi r by 2 plus 2R
I hope it is clear to everybody over
here any doubt in this
please don't talk about those things
please it is not good rishit please
delete your comment if you can so I hope
these things are clear any doubt in
these things guys very basic things they
are
okay
what is not clear haran
okay fine no doubt fine
oh my God there is some problem with
this thing give me some seconds
okay fine
now area enclosed by two concentric
circles if you have got a circle like
this and there is another circle inside
it so basically what is the area of the
ring this is the ring guys so area of
the Ring will be suppose outer radius is
capital r smaller radius inner radius is
small R so area of the Ring will be what
area of the Outer Circle minus area of
the Inner Circle so you can take Pi is
common so capital R square minus R
square you can use the identity it will
be capital r plus r into small R minus r
is it clear hello Krishna welcome to
this session
yes you guys we are doing these things
only any doubt to any student over here
in these things tell me
so why I am explaining this formula this
is a very simple thing but many a times
if question is complex like values are
complex and if you will calculate like
this it will waste your time for example
I have got capital r to be equal to just
suppose
13 and small are to be equal to 6 so if
you will calculate like this if you will
not take pi as common it will waste your
time or not tell me so if you will use
this formula you can do the question
quickly Pi is equal to 22 upon 7 capital
r plus small R will be
13 plus 6 capital r minus small R is 13
minus 6. 13 minus 6 is
7 so therefore you'll get the answer
quickly this time so this is what guys
19 whatever it is square units you got
it so therefore I am explaining this
formula that many a times you have to
take common so as to do calculations
quickly
uh this is areas related to circles hi
lunatic welcome to this session any
doubt in this exactly last year correct
hello Krishna so this thing you can do
easily so as to do questions I mean you
can learn this formula so as to do
questions quickly when things are like
this when you will put the value of R
over here and Pi then it will make it
very complex right it is not deleted
vijayalakshmi if you talk about cbse
okay
okay can you give me some seconds this
thing is not working actually
give me some seconds guys
give me some seconds please
I'm sorry for the delay guys there was
some issue okay so you have to find the
perimeter of a sector of a circle of
radius 7 centimeter whose central angle
is 102 degrees can you do this question
we are doing cbse grade 10 math FF
gaming
so you have to find the perimeter of a
sector of a circle a sector of a circle
you have to find its perimeter when its
central angle is 120 degrees you have to
find its perimeter and radius of the
circle is already 7 centimeter over here
so how can you do this question
tell me so perimeter will be what guys
length of the arc is L so length of the
arc plus two times of the radius or not
tell me its perimeter will be length of
the arc plus two times of the radius
now length of an arc is what guy is
Theta by 360.
Theta by 360 into 2 pi r so 2 into 22
upon 7 into R is also 7 plus 14 so this
is the perimeter of this sector you can
simplify
so you can simplify this will be 44 by 3
plus 14 over here so what will you get
over here guys
so you'll get 86 upon 3 centimeter so is
the equation clear to every student over
here so why I am taking this question
44 upon 3 is not the answer I had taken
this question just to make sure that you
have to include the radii as well you
are finding the perimeter of a sector so
you have to include the radii as well
otherwise your answer will be wrong
therefore I had given this question
is it clear to everybody over here 51
upon 67 I don't think so this is the
answer you see Theta by 360 into 2 pi r
2 pi radius is 7 and 2 into
7 you will take so this is correct only
yeah this is correct
yeah this is the answer any doubt in
this question guys
will do that lunatic do not bother if it
is there in the syllabus we'll do that
after this any doubt to any student over
here so perimeter of a sector if you
have to find you have to include the
radius as well otherwise it will be
wrong it is six by three is the answer
is it clear very good somia that is
correct
you write C perimeter of this sector
will be what length of the arc plus this
plus this or not tell me so therefore
length of the arc plus 2 times of the
radius length of the arc is Theta by 360
into 2 pi r just calculate and two times
of the radius just calculate you will
get the answer is it clear now yuvraj
I hope it is clear now you Raj
no that is area of a sector we are not
finding area it is perimeter last year
you can write in the perimeter form in
the fraction form that is correct nobody
is going to deduct your marks but but
lunatic you have to make sure that the
fraction is in the simplest form you
have to simplify it I mean simplest form
means the numerator as well as the
denominator they must be Co prime
numbers you have to make sure that it is
simplified okay I hope it is clear
now let's see the next thing over here
some issue is happening guys
ok so sector of a circle what is the
sector of a circle guys
okay so you have got a circle over here
and suppose this is the center of the
circle
oapb is the minor sector okay fine so
basically
this is a and this is B and this is p
suppose the central angle is Theta right
so over here o a p b is the minor sector
or not tell me o a p b is the minor
sector and o a q b is the major sector
this is the major sector because it is
its area is more than a semicircular
region this is a minor sector because
its area is lesser than a semicircular
region
yeah obviously you have to simplify
rishit although they must not cancel
marks deduct marks but you have to
simplify I hope it is clear now area of
this sector Theta by 360 into Pi R
square length of the arc is Theta by 360
into 2 pi r this is the length of the
arc it is Theta by 360 into 2 pi r any
doubt in that and one thing you have to
make sure in your mind there is a
Formula which will save your time area
of this sector suppose I am assuming to
be a so a is equal to LR by 2 area of
this sector is equal to length of the
corresponding Arc into R by two a is
equal to LR by 2 area of a sector is
equal to length of the corresponding Arc
into radius by two is it clear to every
student over here just please comment in
the chat quickly so that we can move on
to the next slide is it clear to
everybody a is equal to LR by 2 area of
a sector is equal to length of the
corresponding Arc into radius by 2. this
will save your time many a times
especially in objective questions I am
not doing its proof again I am saying
there is a proof to it as well and that
is not a very complex proof
oh my God there is some issue guys
okay
now some of the arcs of major and minor
sectors of a circle is equal to the
circumference of the circle simple logic
it is if you have got a circle over here
and this is the minor Arc and this is
the major arc minor Arc means Arc lesser
than a semicircle major arc is Arc more
than a semicircle so minor Arc suppose
and major arc is L Dash so minor Arc
plus major arc is equal to circumference
of the circle as simple as that an area
of the minor segment suppose this is
Theta suppose this is a and major major
sector suppose a dash so area of the
minor sector plus major sector it will
be the area of the circle that's it any
doubt in this I am explaining these
things because they are used in
questions
lunatic C if you have got this sector a
it is its area is a so a is equal to
length of the corresponding Arc into
radius by 2 length of the corresponding
Arc into radius by two is it clear to
you
exactly not no not in subjective
questions ishan they will not give a
question like that in subjective
questions don't bother about that but in
objective if it is used you can directly
say for example I ask a question a
simple question suppose area of a sector
anything I can give I'm just giving
random values suppose area of a sector
is 56 centimeter square and radius of
that circle is
7 centimeter can you find the length of
the corresponding Arc if suppose this
question is given to you and you will
use the conventional method it will
waste your time or not in objective
questions tell me area of a sector is
this length of the corresponding Arc you
have to find if the radius of the circle
is given can you tell me what is the
answer to this question can you find the
length of the corresponding Arc
so you can use this formula a is equal
to LR by 2 over here area of this sector
is given you have to find the length of
the corresponding Arc radius is 7 by 2
so 7 8s are 56 so length of the
corresponding Arc is equal to 8 through
the 16 centimeter this will be the
answer
16 centimeter is the answer if you want
its proof proof is also very simple it
is not complex if you want I can explain
the proof of it as well
it is not working guys give me some
seconds
so length of the corresponding Arcy I
will explain over here if you want
ah C A is what guys you see over here a
is what Theta by 360 into Pi R square
right Theta by 360 into Pi R square is
the area of a sector now over here what
I can do is what I can do over here is
can I write this thing like this if you
understand it properly ah
can I write this state this expression
like this
Theta by 360 into 2 pi r
into R by 2 can I not write it like this
tell me
this thing can be written like this yes
or no
can be written like this now this is
nothing but length of the corresponding
Arc therefore it is l r by 2 that's it
so therefore a is equal to LR by 2 is it
clear to every student over here the
proof of it so if if suppose it is asked
in a subjective examination you can do
like this is it clear to every student
over here
no I have I did it its proof already
lunatic you see over here you can do
this if it is asked in a subjective
examination I hope it is clear to you
lunatic
okay
give me some seconds guys it is not
working actually
otherwise it will waste our time just
give me some seconds
foreign
actually there is some issue over there
last year no problem but still in spite
instead of wasting time uh we can move
on to the next thing right so try doing
this question we have to find the area
of the Shaded region shaded region is
this guys this region this region this
region and this region try to find the
area of the Shaded region over here
hello Shivam welcome to this session
we'll do that as well we'll cover the
whole syllabus bhanupriya don't bother
okay we'll do that as well area of the
major sector will be area of the if
suppose in the previous thing only if
any question is there suppose you've got
this question and you have got this
thing this is Theta so this is radius so
area of the major sector will be what
area of the circle minus area of the
minor sector that's it you got it or not
bhanupriya
is it clear to you
soumya is it clear at suppose one more
thing you can do in this this angle
central angle will be what 360 minus
Theta or not so central angle for major
sector is this or not tell me somewhere
so area of the major sector can be found
like this or not Theta minus three sixty
Three Sixty minus Theta upon Three Sixty
into Pi R square so actually both of
them are same things only you can find
the area of the major sector like this I
hope it is clear samya now you have to
find the area of the Shaded region
that's it so basically one two three
four sectors are there
so area of each sector will be what a by
360 area of first sector into Pi R
square Pi into 7 Square in the same
manner for the second sector is pi Theta
by 360 into Pi into
7 Square
for the third sector it is
C by 360 into Pi into 7 Square for the
fourth sector it is d by Three Sixty
into Pi into seven square if it's asked
in subjective examination you will do
like this I hope it is clear to you
right now what you can do you can simply
take Pi R square by 360 that is pi into
seven square upon Three Sixty s common
so inside the bracket you will be left
with a plus b plus C plus d now A B C D
is a quadrilateral over here so some of
the angles will be 360 only so basically
this is 360 this is also 360. so your
answer is pi into 7 Square to 22 upon 7
into 7 square is the answer very good
154 centimeter square is the correct
answer is it in centimeter only yes 154
centimeter is the correct answer is it
clear to everybody
shaded region is in this syllabus Greece
it is not like that it is there in the
syllabus
shaded region is there in the syllabus
if you see the sample paper
ok now you have got segment of a circle
see sector Arc is clear to you or not
just confirm with a yes or a no in the
chat sector and R can all of these
things is clear to you or not
so that we can move on to segment
okay
okay very good
thanks yuvraj okay so this is the minor
segment right minor segment and this
will be the major segment this is the
major segment
minor segment and major segment now how
will you find the area of the major
segment when you know the area of the
minor segment so same logic area of the
major segment when you know the area of
the minor segment will be what area of
the circle minus suppose area of the
minor segment is a just suppose area of
the minor segment is a then area of the
major segment will be this that's it is
it clear to everybody
so if area of the minor segment is a so
area of the major segment will be Pi R
square minus a that's it
okay now area of the minor segment how
will you find this is Theta this central
angle is Theta
so area of minor segment a p b area of a
p b is what guys isn't it area of the
sector o a p b area of the sector o a p
b minus area of the triangle o a b yes
or no
tell me guys
clear or not now area of this sector you
know it is Theta by 360 into Pi R square
area of this sector is Theta by Three
Sixty into Pi R square area of this
triangle you can you have to find in the
examination if it is a subjective
question you have to find the area of
the triangle o a b you cannot use the
formula directly although the formula is
R square sine Theta by 2 R square sin
Theta by 2 and there is also one more
formula or R square
sine Theta by two cos Theta by two these
both the both of these are the formula
to find the area of triangle o a b is it
clear
obviously we can do that no major
segment area of the major segment means
area of the circle minus area of the
minor segment we can do like that poor
gaming
equilateral triangles area is root three
by four into Side Square
no that is not half a b sin Theta oh
that is not in the syllabus it is in
vectors in grade 11 only rishit you
cannot use that in grade 10. that
formula you can use in objective
examination you see mcqs you can use
this formula but if it is a subjective
paper you have to find the area of that
triangle is it clear to every student
over here
I will do that do not bother I will do
that see so this formula I have already
shown over here now see its derivation
it is not very tough it is a simple
derivation have patience and see on the
board
now you have got this circle over here
this is the center and you've got this
triangle
you have got this suppose o a b
so I want the area of the triangle o a b
so what will I do I will drop a
perpendicular from here I will drop a
perpendicular from here this is radius
this is also radius now you see angle
aob is equal to Theta
angle aob is Theta now one more thing
you can understand from here that
suppose this is C this point is C
suppose so we can say over here if you
will be able to prove triangle OAC
OAC is congruent to OBC or not tell me
guys they are congruent by
rhs congruency Criterion can we say that
yes or no they are congruent by High
three when you welcome to this session
exactly you are right so they are
congruent by rhs congruency Criterion so
if this total was Theta so this will be
Theta by 2 or not tell me and this will
also be Theta by 2 it means angle AOC
is equal to angle b o c
is equal to Theta by 2 by cpct is it
clear up till here guys tell me
everybody is clear with this thing now
one more thing
okay so if this is X this is also X
AC is equal to BC I'm assuming over here
AC is equal to BC is equal to X this is
also coming by cpct only right now you
just have to use trigonometry if you
talk about triangle AOC over here
triangle AOC if you see this triangle
can I say that ah
if I say what is sine Theta by 2 sine
Theta by 2 is what guys over here it
will be perpendicular upon hypotenuse so
X upon r or not so over here x will be
equal to R sine Theta by 2 yes or no
guys
tell me just see if it is clear or not
up till here in the same manner if I
take cos Theta by 2 cos Theta by 2 will
be
OC upon R yes or no OC upon R so over
here OC will be R cos Theta by 2.
it is clear to everybody's basic
trigonometry now now what is area of
triangle OAB this only you have to
understand now area of triangle OAB is
half into base into height so half into
a b into OC half into a b into OC so
that will be half into a b is what a b
is 2 times of X you see a b is 2 times
of X so 2 times of X is R sine Theta by
2 this is R sine Theta by 2 and OC is
equal to R cos Theta by 2.
so you see over here this will be
canceled out and we have got R square
sine Theta by 2 cos Theta by two
is it clear to every student in the
class the derivation of this formula I
had explained this because it will come
in the examination and you have to do
that actually
now you will ask from where the other
formula comes from where the other
formula comes I will explain that see
there is a Formula called
when you move on to grade 11 there is a
Formula like this
sine of 2 angle a suppose is equal to 2
sine a COS a
2 sine a COS a got it
two sine a COS a sine two a is equal to
2 sine a COS a okay so it means if I
have this if I have sine of 2 into Theta
by 2.
so can I write it 2 sine Theta by 2 cos
Theta by 2 Tell Me 2 sin Theta by 2 cos
Theta by 2
can I write it like this yes or no hello
Sam reads welcome to this session so
therefore if I take this expression
suppose I am multiplying by 2 over here
and dividing by multiplying by half over
here
now if I take this expression if I take
this thing
is this equal to
this thing guys this is nothing but sine
Theta or not tell me just see it and
tell me it is equal to sin Theta guys so
therefore this will come out to be R
square sine Theta by 2.
any doubt in this these both of these
formula is clear to you or not just
comment in the chat quickly so that we
can move on to questions on the basis of
these topics
is it clear to everybody guys
obviously for sure nobody can say haran
why will I lie to you
okay
so these formula can be used now let's
do questions over here
a chord of Circle of radius 10
centimeters subtends are right angle
subtends a right angle at the center
find the area of the corresponding minor
segment but I hope it is clear now abhir
Vishal I hope it is clear now
see this formula sine 2 a is equal to 2
sine a COS a so therefore sine 2 into
Theta by 2 will be 2 sine Theta by 2 cos
Theta by 2 seat patiently okay so this
is nothing but sine Theta so I have
already explained this one I am
multiplying by 2 over here and dividing
by 2 over here if you see this
expression isn't it equal to sine Theta
so have I got R square sine Theta by 2
I hope it is clear now rishit hello
bandana rishit is it clear now
is it clear now
Vishal is it clear now
please confirm in the chart if it is
clear or not
no we cannot use the formula in the
examination directly in subjective
questions we have to prove it lunatic
therefore I am explaining otherwise I
would not have explained it
please understand that I am not
explaining anything extra I am just
explaining things according to your
exams only I will not explain a single
thing extra because we don't have enough
time right
I hope uh rishit you see this thing sine
2A is equal to 2 sine a COS a so sine 2
into Theta by 2 will be 2 sine Theta by
2 cos Theta by 2 or not Richard tell me
so over here if I multiply by 2 and
divide by 2 this thing will give you
sine Theta or not Richard tell me is it
clear now
next slide formula is the same thing now
oh my God it is the same thing rishit
is it clear
this was the derivation of the formula
you just can use trigonometry to find
the height of this triangle and base of
this triangle that's it
I hope it is clear please confirm
quickly
if it is mentioned that you have to use
assumed mean method then you have to use
that abhir obviously two methods are
there in statistics Euler's formula is
not in the syllabus it is there in grade
eight
I hope it is clear rishit okay fine it
will be clear rishit again I am saying
it's not a big deal so let us move on to
the next thing you will be able to
understand I'm sure about that don't
take tension about that okay
I hope it is clear right
ok now let us take the question so we
have to find the area of the minor
segment so you have got this figure
you have got this thing and it is given
over here that the subtends are right
angle this is subtending a right angle
radius is 10 over here right we have to
find the area of the minor segment now
one thing is clear from this question
even if you don't use the formula you
can find the area area of the minor
segment will be what area of the sector
Theta by 360 into Pi R square that is pi
into 10 square now this is a right angle
triangle you see guys this is a right
angle triangle so this area you can
easily find half into base into height
that's it is it clear to every student
in the class this will be the answer
please simplify I am not simplifying
these things right
you do not need to get scared you will
do good in your exam study table is it
clear to every stone I am not simply
fine please simplify because things are
not multiples and all that you can do it
right it's not a very tough thing
this is four times and this will be 25
please simplify on your own this is 50.
I hope it is clear to every student in
the class
now this second part you have to find
the area of the major sector not major
ah you have to find the area of the
major sector this angle is 90 guys so
this angle will be 270 or not tell me
because total is 360 so area of the
major sector will be Theta by 316 into
Pi R square
Theta by 360 into Pi R square Pi is
you can put the value you'll get the
answer any doubt in this question guys I
am not simplifying it further because
instead of that we can see the next
question
I'll explain that Muskan is it clear to
everybody in this class please tell that
whatever it is Rishi I hope you
understand this can be done is this
clear to everybody over here
any doubt to anybody in the class please
tell me guys
please confirm
okay
suppose many a times it is given to you
many a times a question like this is
also there when it is given that this
chord is equal to the radius of the
circle what will you do in those
questions it is given many a times that
this chord is equal to radius of the
circle suppose in this same question it
is 10 and 10 it is given that this chord
is equal to radius of the circle okay
so if this chord is equal to radius of
the circle this is also radius so this
triangle will become an equilateral
triangle or not tell me
no no we had I had already taken the
break this triangle will become an
equilateral triangle or not guys when it
is given that this chord is equal to
radius of the circle yes or no
exactly it will become an equilateral
triangle so every angle of an
equilateral triangle is 60 degrees right
so this is 60 60 and 60. you do you
don't need to write all the angles but I
am saying that okay so the area of the
corresponding minor segment will be what
guys area of the corresponding minor
segment area of the sector that is Theta
by 360 into Pi R square Pi into 10
square minus area of the equilateral
triangle is root 3 by 4 into Side Square
this formula you have to remember area
of an equilateral triangle is this
centimeter Square
is it clear to every student in the
class exactly
everything I am discussing HS is gaming
it's it's not that see if you and don't
understand the concept there is no trick
like that which you will understand in
one day and you will be able to do it
very quickly I hope you understand I
will not lie to you see I'm being very
honest
is it clear any doubt to any stone
please confirm in the chat
please confirm in the chart if it is
clear or not
so that we can move on to the next thing
over here
guys please confirm so that we can move
on move on to the next question
okay
now the next thing is you have to find
the area of the Shaded region this is a
very I think previous year question only
find the area of this shaded region over
here
so how will you do questions like this
guys
you have to find the area of the Shaded
region in this question
so over here it is given that uh
circle of radius 27 there is a mistake
over here please ignore that quadrant of
a circle of radius 28 centimeter
quadrant of a circle of radius 28
sentiment see needless to say if it is
written that it is a quadrant it means
this angle will be 90. quadrant means
central angle is 90. so you have to find
the area of the Shaded region now over
here this is B guys this thing is B okay
so can you use Pythagoras Theorem can
you not say that b c square is equal to
28 square plus 28 square so it will be 2
into 28 square so from here what is BC
guys BC will come out to be 28 root 2
centimeter yes or no BC is equal to 28
root 2 centimeter now what is this
radius radius of this semicircle this
will be what guys R will be equal to 14
root 2 centimeter or not tell me guys 14
root 2 centimeter now area of the Shaded
region will be what
area of the Shaded region over here will
be area of this semi circle yes or no
area of if I write b e c area of BEC
minus suppose I name this area as x
minus X or not now area of b e c will be
what guys it's a semi circle so Pi by 2
into radius square radius is this or not
so 14 root 2 the whole Square yes or no
guys tell me minus what is X the region
this region what is its area it is area
of this quadrant minus area of this
triangle so area of the quadrant is pi
by 4 into radius square radius is what
Square minus area of this triangle will
be what half into base into height so
half into 28 into 28 is it clear up till
here guys now don't put the values
directly it will waste your time that's
what I am saying over here H as
hshsg gaming
exactly your right Wiki exactly your
right
no yadnesh will cover that correctly so
see don't simplify these things
separately it will waste your time I'm
explaining a trick I mean it's not a
very big trick guys come on it's
mathematics basic mathematics see I can
do like this Pi by 2 into 14 square into
root 2 square is 2 so this will get
canceled out open up this bracket this
is pi by 4 over here now you see what is
28 square if you see 28 square it is 2
into 14 Square guys so can I not write
it like this 2 square into 14 Square so
this is nothing but 4 into 14 Square you
got it
basic mathematics so this is 4 into 14
Square
now you see minus minus plus so plus
half into 28 into 28 basic calculation
so you see this is getting canceled out
now you see Pi into 14 Square minus Pi
into 14 Square canceled out so this is
your answer 14
so 28 into 14 I think it will be 392
only 392 centimeter square is the answer
is it clear to every student in the
class
exactly Richard is it correct it is
correct what about other students you're
not writing your answers this is a very
famous question
is it clear to every student in the
class please comment in the chat quickly
so that we can move on to the next thing
have you got how we are doing yes raghav
I were I was but I was not able to make
through I'm being honest
because I did not study back then
okay is it clear to every stone in the
class please come in quickly so that we
can move on to the next thing over there
okay fine
so what about this guys try doing this
see this is basically like this
so we have to find the area of the Loon
it's a simple question see this is a
semicircle a big semi-circle and there
is a small semi circle on the top of it
like this
you have to find the area of this region
area of the region which is outside the
bigger semicircle but inside this
smaller Circle that region is called a
loon
I don't know why it's called a lunar I
don't need to know it either why will I
know it I just want to find its area so
you have to find the area of the Loon
you got it
so how how will I do that
so basically suppose area of this region
is X
this region is X
area of this region is X so area of the
Loon will be what see the figure area of
the Loon will be what
it will be the area of the smaller
semicircle area of the smaller
semicircle is pi by 2 into radius is
what diameter is one so radius will be
one by two right
1 by 2 square minus X or not tell me
area of the Loon will be area of the
semicircle minus X so that will be
basically Pi by four twos are eight Pi
by 8 minus X I hope it is clear it means
I have to find the area of this minor
segment first
I hope it is clear so you see this is
the center of the circle small
semicircle join it
now you see diameter of the bigger
semicircle is two so radius will be 1 1
this is also one this is also one you
got it so what does it mean that if I
name this suppose this is a b c a b c is
an equilateral triangle or not guys tell
me a b c is an equilateral triangle so
this angle is equal to 60 only you got
it so basically what is the re area of
the region X that is ah
minor segment that will be area of the
sector with central angle 60 that is
Theta by 360 into Pi R square pi r is 1
for the bigger semicircle minus
this equilateral triangle root 3 by 4
its side is 1 only so one square so this
is what six six are thirty six so it is
pi by 6 minus root 3 by 4 that is the
area of the
region X over here you got it guys
so area of the Loon will be what just
put X over here Pi by 8 minus inside the
bracket you can put Pi by 6 minus root 3
by 4 if you simplify this what will you
get just simplify you'll get the answer
this is pi by 8 minus Pi by 6 Plus root
3 by 4 over here
so this will be what guys Pi by 8 minus
Pi by 6 will what if you simplify Pi by
8 minus Pi by 6 it will be 6 minus minus
2 pi yeah minus two Pi eight six or
forty eight
so this will be twenty four so basically
it is root 3 by 4 root 3 by 4 minus
Pi by twenty four root 3 by 4 minus Pi
by 24
centimeter square root three by four
minus Pi by 24 centimeter square is the
question clear to every stone in the
class
is the question clear to every stone in
the class
any doubt to any student over here
OK sir I will take that
so this is a good question and I hope
this question is clear to every student
over here
so I don't know I don't need to know it
either that why this is called a loon
maybe some logic is there I don't know
that I just need to find its area that's
it
okay so I think this was a doubt of one
of these students that when you have got
a 60 degree root 3x4 area over here root
three by four into Side Square you get
an area like this I hope it is clear to
every student over here
right
okay so let us move on to the next thing
over here we already just did this
question and we are done with the areas
related to circles now we are over here
with surface areas and volumes see
formula they are already clear to you
let us do it quickly although so you
have got a cuboid see needless to say I
will not say what is a cuboid and what
is a cube and what is a cone and what is
the cylinder you all you people already
know that you've got exam day after
tomorrow right so if length breadth and
height it is given l b h volume is l b h
obviously cubic units needless to say
lateral surface area is 2 into L plus b
into H right and total surface area is 2
into lb plus b h into HL any doubt in
these Concepts tell me
any doubt in any order of these Concepts
formulas
see again I am saying there is a
derivation to each of these formulas but
obviously the derivation of any out of
these form is not as in the examination
so there is no point of discuss
discussing those derivation over here
you are having exam day after tomorrow
right one thing is left over here l b h
many a times the length of the longest
diagonal is asked see the figure is not
proper over here I'll make it for you
over here C
the length of the longest diagonal is
asked many a times over here so you see
this is the cuboid for you and you have
to find the length of the longest
diagonal so the longest diagonal is this
or not suppose this is X
so length of the longest diagonal is
asked or the or the length of the
longest Rod which can be put inside a
cuboidal room is asked
ah
basically it is practice I would say
Wiki because see shortcut is there for
these things I mean logic is there to
understand things but for cone when you
talk about cone when you talk about
sphere there is no shortcut to remember
the formula I hope you understand that
so there is no point of knowing shortcut
for two three things and for two three
things you don't know the shortcut so it
will mess it up automatically right so
it is all about practice if you practice
enough number of questions I'm being
very honest see I can also give you x y
z tricks you will not be able to
remember those tricks as well I'm being
honest otherwise I can also I mean learn
that and tell you and then you'll be
happy oh my God that sir was very good
but in the long run they are not going
to help I hope you understand that
yeah that's what I am saying bold gaming
but in the long run in problem solving
those are not going to help I'm being
very honest if you practice questions
automatically you will be able to learn
if you if somebody is struggling with
formula it means that person is not
practicing enough questions
okay see over here
so the length of the longest diagonal is
this suppose this is the uh length this
is breadth and this is height now we
have to find this you see you can join
this one
so you see this is also B this is a
right angle triangle guys suppose this
is y over here right so in this right
angled triangle can I say that y z y
square is equal to l square plus b
square can I say that using the
Pythagoras Theorem and in this right
angle triangle you see this right angle
triangle this one this right angle
triangle can I not say that x square is
equal to Y square plus h Square now in
place of Y Square can I put l square
plus b square over here guys
because I have already got y square is
equal to S square plus b square
plus h square is there
so from here guys
can I not say that X is equal to square
root of L square plus b square plus h
Square so this is the length of the
longest diagonal of a cuboid or the
length of the longest Rod which you can
put inside a cuboidal room any doubt in
this
okay bold gaming any doubt in this thing
guys you must get full marks if you have
practice 97 sample papers oh my God
is it clear to every student over here
okay very good bold gaming give me some
seconds guys there is some issue give me
some seconds I'll be back within some
seconds
okay I hope it is clear the length of
the longest diagonal which you will get
inside a cuboid is this thing right now
you have got a cube over here suppose
its Edge is a so volume is a cube
obviously a cube cubic units right to
lateral surface area is 4 a square total
surface area is six a square see lateral
surface area is something which is
relative for example I have got this
thing if I am putting it like this its
lateral surface area is this but if I
put it like this its lateral surface
area will change or not tell me so
lateral surface area is something which
is relative but total surface area does
not depend on the position I hope you
understand that we'll do that as well
bold gaming will be doing the whole
syllabus do not bother hello srinivas
welcome to this session
I did full marks in cbse grade 10 math
okay so any doubt to any student over
here in the same manner the length of
the longest diagonal which of a cube
will be what guys suppose this is X so
the length of the longest diagonal of a
cube will be what
C it is square root of L square plus b
square plus h square but as it is a cube
so all of them will be equal or not tell
me all of them will be equal a square
plus a square plus a square so therefore
it will be square root of 3 a square yes
or no so this will be root 3 a this is
the length of the longest diagonal which
can put inside a cube
many rest leaves
exactly or right rishit
obviously
so any doubt in these things guys just
be clear are these things clear to every
student over here
guys
I'm sorry for speaking in Hindi if you
are not able to understand I hope these
things are clear to you
OK very good
now you have got a cylinder over here so
if its radius is R height is H needless
to say its volume will be Pi R square H
again I am saying the same thing that I
am not explaining from where these
formulas are coming because we are doing
according to the exam so over here we
are not going to prove the formula they
are not going to come in the examination
its lateral surface area is 2 pi RH its
total surface area is 2 pi r into R plus
h total surface area is basically
lateral surface area plus area of the
top and the bottom top is circular
bottom is also circular so both of them
will come will make 2 pi R square in
terms of area so you can take 2 pi RS
common so 2 pi r into R plus h is the
total surface area of a cylinder of a
solid cylinder now you cannot use the
same formula everywhere it depends on
the situation
I hope it is clear
okay clear cello now you have got a cone
over here so
something called slant height is there
in a cone you can directly use
Pythagoras Theorem you can say that
using Pythagoras Theorem L square is
equal to R square plus h Square over
here right
and a curved surface area of a cone is
pi RL if you want to find its total
surface area it will be curved surface
area Pi RL plus area of the circular
base that is pi R square so you can take
pi r s common pi r s common pi r into L
plus r is the total surface area of a
cone I hope it is clear to you right
again it depends on the situation
suppose it is a tent so you will not
include its base it will not be written
in the question you have to understand
from the question itself what are you
writing as such
hsg gaming
thank you bold gaming what are you
asking please uh ask your question once
again if you have written any doubt
ok now the next thing is a sphere so for
a sphere its volume if its radius is R
so its volume is four by three pi r cube
with surface area is 4 Pi R square now
hemisphere half of a hemisphere right so
its volume will be half of the volume of
a sphere that is 2 by 3 pi r Cube curved
surface area will be what guys half of
the curved surface area of a sphere so
that will be this will be what guys this
thing will be 2 pi R square right
not two things are there if it's a solid
hemisphere it means you have to include
the base as well it means in case of a
solid hemisphere total surface area will
be its curved surface area plus area of
the base so therefore total surface area
of a solid hemisphere will be 3 Pi R
square right but if it is not solid it
will be open at the top so not have to
take the area of the base in that case
it's
curved surface area is equal to the
total surface area and that will be 2 pi
R square only any doubt in these formula
guys
any doubt to any student over a piece
confirm in the chart if you are there in
the class
please confirm if it is clear to you
guys these things are clear or not so
that we can move on to the questions
on the basis of surface areas and
volumes one more thing is that that is
frustum of a cone but it is not in this
syllabus these days I don't know why
okay so let's start with the questions
guys try doing this one and let me know
the answer if possible if you're trying
the sum of the length breadth and height
of a cuboid is this and the length of
its diagonal is this then you have to
find the total surface area of the
cuboid so what is the answer over here
guys
so sum of the length breadth and height
of a cuboid is given L plus b plus h
over here
is 6 root 3 centimeter correct
and the length of its diagonal is given
length of the diagonal will be what guys
I had derived that formula in this class
itself that is square root of L square
plus b square plus h square and that is
equal to 2 root 3 centimeter over here
right so can I Square on both these
sides guys so will I get L square plus b
square plus h square and if you do this
square of this expression what will you
get 2 square is 4 root 3 square is 3 so
4 3 is at 12 this will be okay we want
the total surface area of the cuboid so
basically we have to square over here as
well because we can use the identity L
plus b plus h the whole square is equal
to
6 root 3 the whole square right six root
3 the whole Square now what will be L
plus b plus h the whole square if you
use the identity this will be L square
plus b square
plus h square plus 2 into l b plus b h
plus HL l b plus b h plus HL and that is
equal to what is this guys this is 60
the 36 into root 3 square is 3 so 36
into 3 is what 90 and
108 right yes 108 centimeter Square
now you see we already know the value of
this 12 we already know the value of L
square plus b square plus x square that
is 12. so I can put the value of L
square plus b square plus x square to be
12 over here 12 into 12 plus 2 into l b
plus b h plus HL and that is equal to
108 centimeter Square so from here can I
find the value of 2 into l b plus b h
plus HL over here and that will come out
to be equal to
96 centimeter Square so this is the
answer to this question so any doubt in
this question guys to any student over
here very good you must have done some
mistake Karthik 96 is the correct answer
exactly not able to read questions
picture
okay so if there is a problem at your
end I think bold gaming because maybe
internet issue is there
yeah that's what I was saying
I hope it is clear bold gaming everybody
else in the class the question is clear
or not please confirm in the chat
quickly so that we can move on to the
next question quickly I hope it is clear
right
okay hello very good
and what about the next question now see
this the area of canvas required for a
conical tent of height 48 meter and base
radius 14 meter how can you do this
got it
see I hope you understand that I am
doing a bit quickly I hope you
understand that because of time issue as
well
am Audible and visible to everybody in
the class I think there was some glitch
just confirm in the chat I'm Audible and
visible to everybody in the class
thanks a lot am Audible and visible guys
okay fine I think there was some glitch
okay fine yeah you have to find the area
of the canvas required so area of the
canvas required will be obviously its
curved surface area because it's a tent
so you don't have to include its base
this is radius this is height this is
slant height so you have to find
basically the curved surface area only
Pi RL so you see 22 upon 7 radius is
base radius is 14 you don't know the
slant height so slant height you have to
find in this question now how do you
find this slant height guys slant height
is square root of R square plus h Square
so R square is 14 square and H square is
48 square so what is that coming out to
be
tell me guys what is that coming out to
just calculate and tell that over there
no no after this calculation because it
is just square root and all that what is
that coming out to be guys
height is 48 and base radius is 14 meter
and you have to find the slant height so
what is that coming out to be
because I will take this square root and
all that will take time and it is not
any I think
uh ok maybe I can take some Shortcut if
you want to understand because I can
take like this 2 square can be taken as
common so 7 square plus 24 Square I can
do right
so basically this will come out to be 2
square root of 7 square plus 24 square
and this is basically this will give you
ah
576 plus 49 that is 625 so yeah this
will come out to be I think 25 and this
is 50 only correct
50 meter so it is 50 over here so this
will be seven twos or fourteen
this is 2 sorry
so what is the answer over here 2200
2200 meter Square any doubt in this
question to any student over here guys
exactly any doubt to any and any stone
see have you seen the calculation over
here actually I am also a bit lazy I am
being honest with you
I will never do this choir and I'll
never do this square and I'll never add
that I I'll just never do that but you
will you will see this trick over trick
is very simple seven twos are 14 now so
two square can be taken 20 48 is 24 into
2 so 2 square can be taken as common and
now this I remember this I know that it
will give us 525 so therefore 50 is the
answer
I hope it is clear
right
yeah
let us take the next question the
internal and external radii of a
spherical shell are three centimeter and
five centimeter respectively it is
melted and recast into a solid cylinder
of diameter 14. find the height of the
cylinder also also find the total
surface area of the cylinder
please do not talk about games at least
please you people are going to have exam
no it's not a mind blowing trick it is
not something like that but yeah it is a
trick you can understand
so
it is a spherical shell so spherical
shell will somewhat look like the C it's
a three dimensional thing I will not be
able to make over here but at least you
can think like this if you if you will
see a shell it will look like this or
not
so in order to find the area of the
shell what you have to do you have to
take the area of the outer sphere area
of the outer sphere will be what four by
three pi
uh
5 Cube minus 4 by 3 pi
4 by 3 Pi 3 Cube yes or no this will be
done over here and that is given to be
equal to it is melted and recast into
solid cylinder of diameter 14 so its
volume will be Pi R square H diameter is
14 so radius is 7 Pi R square H this is
the situation or not guys tell me this
is the situation exactly
that will also be done Shivam don't
bother about that that will also be done
ah shivratan
okay Krishna I am Audible and visible to
everybody over here
okay so from here I can take 4 by 3 Pi s
common so 5 Cube minus 3 Cube will be
there and this is like this Pi into 7
square into H now you see Pi will be
canceled out so you can simply fight
further this is four by three
this will be what 125 minus 339 here is
27 so this is basically 98 now this is
77049 into H over here this will get
canceled out 9 49 into two so basically
height of this cylinder is coming out to
be four twos are eight by three
centimeter is it centimeter yeah
is it clear to every student over here
just after this chapter sudarshan
now also find the total surface area of
this cylinder so total surface area of
the cylinder is what 2 pi r into R plus
h that is the total surface area of the
cylinder
I hope it is clear
total surfacer of this cylinder so it is
2 into 22 upon 7
into R is what
R is 7 only
and R is 7 plus h is eight by three you
can simplify this you will get the total
surface area of the cylinder just
simplify this this will be the answer
any doubt to any student over here guys
any doubt to any stone in this question
whatever it is you don't need to do that
if you want you can do that as well no
problem three two six two point six
seven centimeter but don't do it like
this it will make it more complex
otherwise you can leave it like that
only okay
whatever it is rishit this thing I don't
have enough space as well and although
you can do it it's all up to you so it
is seven threes at twenty one twenty one
plus eight is what twenty nine by three
twenty nine by three into forty four you
can do the calculation I hope it is
clear to everyone any doubt in these
questions just confirm in the chat only
two chapters are left that is statistics
and probability
any doubt to any student yes akhil
whatever it is just do it just do the
calculator multiplication is there now
you don't need to divide and all that
leave it like that it will be the answer
no problem that
if you will not write the unit correctly
even if you have done everything
correctly half mark will be deducted for
sure
sample paper we already have done
sudarshan on the Infinity Run class 9
and 10 YouTube Channel please check out
the playlist named as Sprint sessions
most of the questions are related to CBS
you only some are previous year
questions some are from ncrt some are
from ncrt Exemplar from where will I get
cbse questions
yes
yes rishit
now do this question a solid sphere of
radius 10.5 centimeters melted and
recast into smaller solid cones each of
radius 3.5 centimeter a height three
centimeter over here
okay fine find the number of cones so
formed so the number of cones will be
what over here guys
a solid sphere of radius 10.5 centimeter
is melted and recast into smaller solid
cones each of radius this and height
this find the number of cones so form so
number of cones will be what guys if you
find the number of cones
it's a simple problem it will be the
volume of the solid sphere that is four
by three pi r cube right R cube is 10.5
into 10.5 into 10.5 I am writing like
this so as to make the calculation
easier divided by volume of a cone
so smaller solid cone so volume of a
cone is one by three Pi R square H R
square is what over here 3.5 into 3.5
and H height of each cone over here is
three now it is a mathematical crime if
you are multiplying this and multiplying
this and dividing in the last step I am
repeating it once again it is a
mathematical crime if you are doing
calculation like that this is not
deleted from the syllabus please check
out the sample paper sudarshan
okay it is there in this syllabus
obviously I have seen the syllabus as
well sudarshan
okay so over here I can cancel out this
this and this so this is what guys three
times this is three times this is also
three times and see this will be
canceled out over here so you have got
the answer quickly answer is what guys 4
into
4 into 3
into 10.5 this is the answer any doubt
in this question guys
so this is 6 into 21 21 into 6 so 76 is
126 is the answer any doubt in the
question to any student in the class
guys tell me
one sec 126 is coming out to be the
answer rishit
I think I remember the answer to this
question any doubt to any student over
here
it's ok you don't need to be sorry
sudarshan obviously see you are going to
have exam we all I have also seen
everything there for 126 is the correct
answer any doubt to any student exactly
any doubt to any student over here in
the class so that maybe you must have
done some calculation mistake rishit no
problem you can check it
is it clear
guys 140 I don't think so 126 is the oh
my God sudarshan no it's not like that
126 is the answer I have done it before
also that's why I'm
maybe remembering it
yes
so guys just confirm in the chat is
there any glitch at your end am I
Audible and visible to everybody over
here just confirm in the chat
is there any glitch at your end
from my end is there any glitch at your
end you are able to hear and see me
properly right please confirm in the
chat
okay fine please other students also
please confirm in the chat quickly is it
okay for everybody or maybe I'm also I'm
feeling that there is a glitch
OK it is okay then it is fine then it is
fine thank you for that
okay try doing this question guys and
after that we'll be doing statistics a
right circular cone has for its base a
circle having the same radius as a given
sphere the volume of the cone is one
half that of the sphere the ratio of the
altitude of the cone to the radius of
its base
try doing that guys
the volume of the cone is one half to
that of the sphere the ratio of the
altitude of the cone to the radius of
the base it's a simple question only it
is given that a right circular cone has
for its base a circle having the same
radius as a given sphere it means you
have got a cone over here suppose its
base radius is r and suppose height is H
right and you have got a sphere
you have got a sphere I am sorry the
figure is not perfect you do not need to
bother about that right
having the same radius as the given
sphere so radius of the sphere is this
now it is given that volume of this cone
is one half of that of the sphere so
volume of the cone will be what 1 by 3
Pi R square H Guys 1 by 3 Pi R square H
is equal to one half of the volume of
this sphere so volume of the sphere is
four by three pi r Cube that's it this
is the situation just simplify you'll
get the answer Pi Pi will get canceled
out three three will get canceled out
two twos are four over here you see R
square and R will be left over here
right so basically you are getting H is
equal to 2 R you have to find the ratio
of the altitude means height only
altitude of the cone means its height
only so you have to find the ratio of
the altitude to the radius it means the
answer is two is to one
two is to 1 is the answer any doubt in
the question guys exactly it's a simple
question hi there welcome to this
session
any doubt to any student over here
yeah two is to one this is a very simple
question I mean it's a formula based
question only nothing much in that this
statement is a bit twisted on all that
but the question is very easy I hope it
is clear to every student in the class
ok now let's start with Statistics right
so I will repeat the things in
statistics mean median and mode is there
in statistics for mean only two methods
are there in your syllabus if you talk
about cbse grade 10 syllabus
mean using grouped I'm sorry mean using
direct method and mean using assumed
mean method now the formula to find the
mean using direct method is X bar it is
mean is represented by X bar it is Sigma
f i x i upon Sigma F I will do the
questions on the basis of these Concepts
so X bar is equal to Sigma f i x i upon
Sigma f i okay
and the assumed mean method is X bar is
equal to a plus Sigma f i d i upon Sigma
f i where D I are deviations right these
are deviations and a is the assumed mean
right d i are the deviation and a is the
assumed mean assumed mean method is also
called the shortcut method assume mean
method is also called the shortcut
method there is one more method called
Step deviation method but that is not in
this syllabus these days
okay I hope it is clear now if
mensuration we already did it actually I
I I think it was not you were not there
in the class
now one more thing if nothing is
mentioned in the question I would every
time prefer assumed mean method because
assumed mean method is for you only to
make calculations easier I hope you
understand the reason of studying assume
mean method mathematically there is no
difference between assumed mean method
and direct method assumed mean method
step deviation method can be derived
from direct method there is a proof
which is given in ncert as well but we
are not doing the proof because it is
not in the examination
it is deleted yes it is correct no it is
not given in the syllabus Guru Prasad if
you are in cbse please don't use
something which is not in this syllabus
so you can use assume Min method I would
prefer assume mean method more than
direct method although if nothing is
given in the question it is free for you
can use any method possible so let us
take the
give me some seconds
give me some seconds guys
give me some seconds guys there is some
issue
give me some seconds I'll be back within
some seconds guys just be there in the
class
foreign
wait guys there is some issue
I am sorry for the disturbance
foreign
Audible and visible to you
okay
so let's start with it guys
so
okay fine now this is the formula to
find the median that is L plus n by 2
into c f minus c f upon F into H where L
is the lower limit of the median Class C
F is the cumulative frequency of the
class preceding the median class will do
a question H is the frequency of sorry H
is the class size f is the frequency of
the median class so we'll do a question
on the basis of this we'll be able to
understand right hello Murthy welcome to
this session we'll do questions directly
right there is no point discussing the
formula only we'll do questions right
now mode is L plus h into f 1 minus F 0
upon 2 f 1 minus F 0 minus F2 now you
see the pattern F 0 1 2
this is the frequency of the modal class
frequency of the modal class
frequency of the class preceding the
modal class it means frequency of the
class before the modal class frequency
of the class succeeding the modal
classes is frequency of the class after
the modal class and in the same manner H
is the class size L is the lower limit
of the modal class so any doubt in this
formula guys
please confirm in the chart if the
formula is clear to you so that we can
do the questions on the basis of this
formulas any doubt in the formula to any
stone in the class
just confirm in the chat quickly if you
are there guys
okay fine so let us do questions guys
yeah one more formula is there that is
the empirical relationship between mean
median and mode that is mode is equal to
3 million minus 2 mean so you can expect
an objective question an McQ on the
basis of this formula
mode is equal to one median mode is
equal to three median minus 2 mean
we'll do that we'll do questions Vicky
don't bother okay no problem
okay so let's start with the question
guys
obviously again I am saying this formula
is very important you can expect an McQ
on the basis of this formula mode is
equal to 3 million minus two mean so
let's start with it if the difference of
mode and median of a data is 24 then the
difference of median and mean is what
can you tell the answer
ah maybe yeah we are going to do that
sudarshan
we are going to do that
say the difference of mode and median of
a data is 24 so can you find the
difference of median and mean what is
the answer to this one
so it is on the basis of that formula
only guys C if you see this formula what
is the formula mode is equal to three
median minus 2 mean right 3 median minus
2 mean
overhead mode is equal to 3 million
minus two mean now can I write it like
this c one median I can take over here
or not so I can write it like this mode
minus median I can write it like this
mode minus median and over here two
median was left or not 2 median minus 2
mean yes or no
I can write it like this
now what I can do I can take 2s common
so 2 into median minus mean yes or no
median minus mean so this thing you can
do now you see difference of mode and
median is given difference of mode and
median is given to you 24 over here you
have to find the difference of median
and mean difference of median and mean
will be what guys 24 divided by 2 the
answer will be 12. any doubt in this
question to any student in the class
is it clear that is correct rishit
sudarshan
oh no its not 5 hours it's now I think
it is six six hours now yes Ashwin is
the question clear yes is it is clear it
is correct Wiki any doubt to any student
over here
just confirm in the chat quickly so that
we can move on to the next question
okay fine let us move on to the next one
see X plus 2 x and x minus 1 are the
frequencies of these numbers mean of the
distribution is 14.5 can you find the
value of x over here
can you find the value of x over here it
is given that for these values you see
values we represent by x i or not 12 15
and 20.
12 15 and 20 and their frequencies are
given frequency is what X plus 2 x and x
minus 1 right frequencies are given like
this 12 15 and 20 X plus 2 x x minus 1
right and the mean is given to us now
how will you find the mean guys mean is
nothing but Sigma f i x i upon Sigma f i
yes or no this is the mean and this is
given to be equal to 14.5 you have to
find the value of x from this question
so Sigma f i x i will be what guys just
multiply them and add so it will be 12
into X plus 2 plus 15x
plus 20 into x minus 1 20 into x minus 1
divided by
some of the frequencies so what is that
equal to X plus 2 plus x minus 1
X plus 2 plus X also yes and that is
equal to 14.5 over here I hope it is
clear to you now let's simplify this
what will you get guys C 12x plus 15 x
plus 20 x so that will be
47 x 47 X plus you will get
plus 4 over here right and that is equal
to what guys you see this is nothing but
3x plus 1 so it is 3 X Plus 1 multiplied
by fourteen point five so you can
multiply and tell me what are you
getting
43.5 X Plus fourteen point five over
here you are getting
so if you take it on this side and if
you take it on this side what will you
get over here guys you will get ah
3.5 x and that is equal to 10.5 that is
10.5 so basically X will be equal to
what three x is equal to 3 is the answer
any doubt in the question to any student
in the class
exactly 43.5 yes X is equal to 3 is the
answer hello poke gaming very good
rishit any doubt to any student in the
class its a direct question on the basis
of the concept of mean
foreign
in the class
exactly three is the answer very good
keshav rishit
what is your doubt Karthik you can
please write your doubt see the concept
of mean is what Sigma f i x i upon Sigma
f i or not tell me Karthik so Sigma f i
x i means multiply these multiply these
and multiply these and then you have to
add them Karthik divided by Sigma f i it
means add all the frequencies and that
is equal to 14.5 in the question solve
this equation for x that's it solve this
equation for x you'll get the answer I
hope it is clear to you
right
I hope it is clear now trishanth
is it clear now trishanth see
calculation part you can think right
because
that can be done
okay fine
now let's do this one see I'll rewrite
for you run scored is given and number
of batsmen is there you have to find the
mean of the runs so I'm writing it again
over here so that it is visible to you
and it will be easier for me as well so
0 to 40 and
forty eighty eighty one twenty
till then you can try doing 81 21 2060
120 160 and 160 200 right so these are
the class intervals over here and the
frequencies are also given frequencies
are 12 20
and 35
30 23.
these are the frequencies over here
right 12 20 35 30 23 these are the
frequencies now if nothing is mentioned
in the question I every time prefer to
use assume mean method so for that first
we have to find the class marks over
here first we have to find the class
marks class Mark of this class interval
will be 20 for this it will be
60 and then you will get 100 and 140 and
180 over here
I hope it is clear to you guys now over
here we can find see the middle most
value we can assume the assume as the
assumed mean the middle most value we
can take at as the assumed mean now we
can find the corresponding deviations
deviation is x i minus a you remember
the formula so 20 minus 100 will be what
guys minus 80
minus 40 0 40 and 80 over here right now
what do you do guys you find f i d i yes
or no fidi you have to find
so d i and f i so this will be minus 960
and this will be minus 800 this will be
0 this will be 1200
and this will be 8 freezer 24 and
suppose 2 is left
1840 right I hope it is clear
okay
so I hope it is clear to you now we have
to find Sigma f i d i right we have to
find Sigma f i d i over here now what is
Sigma f i d i guys let me calculate it
over here so it is 960 and 800 it is a
bit calculative I hope you understand
that
so this is minus this and this will be
if you calculate 1200 Plus
1840 so what it will be guys 0 4
3040 now if you will simplify over here
3040 minus
1780 what it will come out to be equal
to
1260 you're getting right 1260 you are
getting
I don't know that
lcf what is lcf we already did that so
we have got 1260 over here now what is
Sigma f i over here guys can you tell me
what is Sigma f i
Sigma f i is what guys
120 Sigma f i right so mean will be what
guys mean if you use the formula it is a
plus Sigma f i d i upon Sigma f i right
A Plus Sigma f i d i upon Sigma F I
assumed mean over here is 100 plus Sigma
f i d i Sigma f i d i is coming out to
be 1260 divided by Sigma f i is 120 this
will get canceled out
so this is what guys ah
wait ah there is some issue over here
so basically it is coming out to be 126
upon 12 right 126 upon 12 so what will
you get over here
so 10.5 I think some calculation mistake
is there
I think some calculation is mistake is
there guys
oh yeah 1760 we will get some
calculation mistake we have done
oh that's what I was thinking at least
do some calculation guys and let me know
if it is correct or not otherwise it
will waste our time
let me check it quickly because actually
I remember the answer to this I'm being
honest I remember the answer to this
so 960 plus 800 it will be
1760 correct
okay I did a mistake over here this is 6
over here right yeah I got it guys will
get the answer quickly don't bother
yeah so this will be 3040 minus 1760
right so this will be what 0
twelve hundred and eighty right so
assume mean was hundred so this is 100
plus 1280 divided by 120 correct this is
so this will get canceled out and then
you can get 128 divided by 12 over here
so 4 3 0 12 4 3's are twelve four twos
are eight so this will give you what 100
plus uh
10.67 so this will give you 110.67 so
any doubt in this question guys to any
student in the class exactly any doubt
201 in the class guys
tell me
yeah 10.67 or 10.66 it is all up to you
it is you can write like that that would
be correct and one more thing if you
have got the answer you have to write a
statement as well only this much is not
possible at last you have to write hence
the mean number of runs is 110.67 then
that will be the answer least cumulative
frequency there is nothing like that
although in the concept of median
cumulative frequency will be used a lot
I hope the question is clear to you let
us take the next question
so over here you see the concept of
median is there I'll once again write it
for you for me as well so this is 0 to
20 and then 20 to 40.
so you see the frequencies are already
given frequencies are what 2x 4
X
and 8 and 4 right so when you find the
median guys let me check if it
everything is correct 0 20 20 40 40 60
60 80 100 correct so 2x 4 4 x 8 4
correct so when you find the median you
have to find the cumulative frequency
you know that so cumulative frequency
will be what guys 2x then 2x plus 4
then 6X plus 4
then 6X Plus
12 then you will have 6X plus 16 right
so this is the these are the cumulative
frequencies over here now you see median
is already given in the question that is
55 median is already given so what is
the median class this will be the median
class or not tell me median is already
given 55 so median class median will
follow in this will fall in this
category in this ah class interval right
so the formula for median is what L plus
h into n by 2 minus c f upon F right
and that is equal to 55 now lot what is
L over here L is the lower limit of the
median class that is 40 plus h is the
class size that is 20. now what is n by
2 see this sum of the frequencies is
nothing but n or not tell me
some of the frequencies the cumulative
frequency of the last class interval is
sum of the all frequencies so what is n
by 2 if you find n by 2 it will be 3x
Plus 8 or not this is 3x Plus 8 so put
it over here 3x Plus 8 now what is c f c
f is the cumulative frequency of the
class preceding the median class
cumulative frequency of the class
preceding the median class so this will
give you minus 2x minus 4 divided by
this is 4 guys this is not 9.
cumulative frequency the class preceding
the median class divided by f is the
frequency of the median class f is the
frequency of the median class that will
be 4X over here right so this is 4X and
that is equal to what 55 just simplify
and solve this equation you will get the
answer so you see 4 5 20
and I can write it like this 5 into
see this is 3x minus 2x is X
Plus 8 minus 4 is 4
divided by
X over here
and you see this will get subtracted so
it will give you 15 now you see five
threes are 15 over here if you cross
multiply and simplify you'll get X plus
4 is equal to 3x if you solve this
equation you will get X is equal to 2 so
X is equal to 2 is the answer is it
clear to every student very good Guru
Prasad that is the answer hi Pavan
welcome to this session is the question
clear to every student in the class any
doubt in this question
AC is equal to 13
what are you writing juluru pallavi not
able to understand that
is the equation clear to every student
in the class
tell it quickly
just tell that quickly so that we can
move on to the next thing you know that
there is nothing much in these things it
is all about practice if you know the
formula if you have practice enough
number of questions you will be able to
do that nothing more than that I mean
hello Suman welcome to this session okay
let us take the next one okay we already
did that is the same question actually
it was an objective question I did not
remember that so 2 is the answer okay
we already did many mcqs this is a
marathon session starting from 2 pm
today Lakshmi
and we have already conducted many
sessions on the infinity learn class 9
and 10 YouTube channel named as board
Master Series and the sprint series
please check the playlist on that
channel on this channel basically not
that channel okay
okay so you have to find the mode of
this class interval is this data is
given you have to find the value of x
what is the answer to this question guys
yes Lakshmi
so what is the formula to find the mode
guys mode is L plus h into F1 minus F 0
upon 2 F1 minus F 0 minus F2 2 F1 minus
F 0 minus F2 and that is given to be
equal to 38 in this question okay
now see if mode is equal to 38 so what
is the modal class over here this will
be the modal class or not because 38
will ah
fall in this category now L is what
lower limit of the modal class H is the
class size that is 10 now what about f 1
F 0 f 2
. so you see you do like this or not
tell me
one zero one two so F 0 1 2 you got it
or not guys you do like this
or here f 1 minus F 0 will be what can I
do it directly f 1 minus F 0 16 minus 12
is 4 divided by 2 f 1 that is 32 minus F
0 is 12 minus F2 is equal to X so this
is the situation just simplify you'll
get the answer any doubt in this
question guys so you can simplify it
quickly you see this will be what guys
10 into 4 divided by 32 minus 12 is 20
minus X and that is equal to what 8 over
here now 8 Pfizer 40. if you simplify
and solve 5 is equal to 20 minus x x
will come out to be equal to 15 and that
is the answer any doubt in this question
to any student very good rishit it is
correct
15 is the answer I did it earlier as
well sukhpal
any doubt to any student in the class
it's a direct question on the basis of
mode
is the equation clear yes 15 is the
correct answer very good Suman
okay 15 is the correct answer Shaheen
maybe you must have done some mistake
just check it that's what I am saying it
is these things are calculative now see
I am doing it correctly because of some
time issues you can see but that does
not mean you can take five minutes in
this question this is a five mark
question only if you talk about your
board exams so don't bother okay
foreign
Ty
probability and two things are there one
is theoretical probability or you call
it classical probability right
theoretical probability or you call it
classical probability clear now there is
one more thing which is called as
experimental probability
or you call it empirical probability
empirical probability so basically you
call it experimental or empirical
understand what I am saying it was there
in grade nine experimental probability
was there in grade nine you call it
experimental or empirical
because in experimental or empirical
empirical means on the basis of your
experience because you have done some
activity earlier and on the basis of
that result you are judging prop you're
finding probability for example you have
tossed a coin thousand times earlier and
out of that you have got 100 times heads
and 400 times head tails so now when you
toss a coin what will be the probability
of getting ahead tell me now when you
toss a coin the probability of getting
heads will be 600 upon thousand that
will be 0.6 so over here you are you are
finding the probability of an event on
the basis of Prior experience so
therefore it is empirical probability or
experimental probability but theoretical
probability or classical probability in
that case you are not doing any
experiment you are finding probability
on the on the basis of set of all
possible outcomes now you will ask that
why we are doing these different types
of probabilities the answer to it is
every time you will not be able to do
the actual experiment suppose you want
to launch a satellite will you launch
this satellite 50 times tell me it's
it's very uh
okay gaming thanks for that
okay we'll do that question don't bother
so over here when you launch a satellite
you will not be able to do the
experiment again and again and on the
basis of that experiment you will find
the probability you cannot do that now
so in that case there is no other way
out but to find the theoretical
probability only I hope you understand
that so therefore we study experimental
experimental probability in those cases
but in grade 10 we do theoretical
probability that is classical
probability
I am sorry in case of launching a
satellite we do ex theoretical
probability not experimental probability
because you cannot launch the satellite
again and again right
so there is a difference in the formula
of experimental probability and
theoretical probability in experimental
probability probability of event is
number of trials in which an event occur
number of Trials
in which
e happened or E occurred
you can write like this divided by total
number of Trials trials means number of
times are doing an experiment total
number of Trials you got it
so in this you were actually doing the
experiment but
you see both are conceptually same but
practically different
in theoretical probability the formula
is number of outcomes favorable to e
upon total number of possible outcomes
total number of possible outcomes you do
not know the actual outcomes you are
talking about possible outcomes only
again I am saying you have to write this
formula for sure in your answer I have
seen many answer sheets where students
don't write the formula you have to
write the formula in your answer
obviously if it's a one mark question no
problem of it but if it's a three mark
question you have to write the formula
understand that very patiently
okay
and over here we assume that the
outcomes of the experiment are equally
likely equally likely means what when
things have equal possibility of coming
for example when you roll a die the
possible outcomes are one two three four
five six right
so they they have equal chances of
coming or not tell me when you roll a
die
probability of all of them will be equal
that is probability of one probability
of two probability of three probability
of four and all of them up till
probability of 6 that is equal to one by
six or not tell me they have got equal
chances of coming
so therefore they they are known as
equally likely outcomes now there is one
more word it is not written random
experiment you must have seen random
experiment means an experiment in which
you know all possible outcomes but you
don't know the exact outcome you got the
difference an experiment in which you
know all the possible outcomes which you
don't know the exact outcome for example
before the experiment you know that in
this box five green balls and six red
balls and all that are there but you
close your eyes and then you are taking
one ball so in your mind you knew that I
can get a ball out of these colors but
you do not know the exact outcome so
that experiment is called a random
experiment
exactly shine that can be done is it
clear to every student over here the
difference between experimental
probability and theoretical probability
it must be crystal clear to you and
again I am saying I will say this 100
times you have to write this formula and
this word is of uttermost importance
number of possible outcomes you do not
know the exact outcome you only know
what are the possible outcomes so I hope
it is clear to everybody over here
now one more thing these are
complementary events complementary
events means you I'll I'll explain using
an example suppose you roll a die the
possible outcomes are one two three four
five six right these are the possible
outcomes now probability of getting one
will be what guys when you roll a diet
is one by six now what is the
probability of getting not one
not one will be five by six or not tell
me you see it is five by six
can you see that it is one minus
probability of getting one can you see
it is one minus probability of getting
one because you see probability of
getting one was one by six isn't it five
by six over here
so these events are complementary events
getting getting e and getting not e
getting one and not getting one
so therefore they are complementary
events we represent them by e and e Dash
or many a times e and e bar
I hope these things are clear to you
guys any doubt in these things
I hope it is clear
okay so these are known as complementary
events and I had explained everything
over here I guess right
now one more logic is there a simple
concept is there wait
okay before this I'll explain two three
concepts on probability and then I'll
explain that
okay so probability of an event e is
greater than equal to zero
and less than equal to 1 right
probability of an any event is greater
than equal to 0 and less than equal to
one you can understand it over here see
when you roll a die the possible
outcomes are one two three four five six
or not tell me the possible outcomes
when you roll a die are one two three
four five six now what is the
probability of an event e tell me what
is the probability of an event e over
here
it will be every time it will be 6 now
because total number of possible
outcomes is six it cannot change now in
the numerator minimum you can get 0 na
tell me because you are counting
outcomes so it can never be negative so
minimum value will be zero or not tell
me minimum value will be 0 and maximum
value will be 6 na because total number
of possible outcomes is six so can the
number of actual outcomes more than the
total number of possible outcomes use
your logic
we already did that I think you were not
you were not there in this session that
is not there in grade 10 syllabus I hope
you understand that Deepak therefore
unnecessarily it will confuse students
you have to understand that okay so
therefore minimum zero must come so 0 by
6 is the minimum probability and maximum
probability six by six or not tell me
one and minimum is 0 or not tell me
so when the E when the probability of an
event is zero that event is called an
impossible event
that event is called an impossible event
when the probability of an event is 0
and when the probability of an event is
one that event is called a sure event
you got it that event is called a sure
event now when you roll a die
the set of possible outcomes are these
can you tell me what is the probability
of
even prime number can you tell that
just asking a question
what is the probability of getting an
even prime number when you roll a die
tell me
what is the probability of getting an
even prime number when you roll a die
we'll do that Lakshmi obviously after
this we'll do that don't bother please I
will do that
so the probability of getting an even
prime number when you roll a die
probability can never be greater than
one with their
2 is the only even prime number on this
Earth You got it two is the only even
prime number on this Earth so
probability of getting an even prime
number when you roll a die is one by six
now what is the probability of getting 7
when you roll a die can you tell that
what is the probability of getting seven
when you roll a die
we'll do that Suman what is the
probability of getting seven when you
roll a die
you can never get seven when you roll a
die because it is not in any of the
possible outcomes so its probability
will be zero so getting 7 is an
impossible event when you roll a die
getting seven when you
getting 7 is an impossible event when
you roll a die okay
I hope these things are clear to you any
doubt in these things guys to any
student over here
yeah getting seven is an impossible
event when you roll a die now can you
tell me what is the probability of
getting a number when you roll a die
what is the probability of getting a
number when you roll a die tell me
probability of getting a number when you
roll a die
so obviously you can get only a number
very good so one
probability of getting a number when
your roll a die is one so getting a
number when you roll a die is a sure
event you will for sure get a number
only when you roll a die you cannot get
any other thing right so I hope these
concepts are clear to every student in
the class now let us do questions before
that understand the situation over here
the first situation is of cards
so in a very shuffled deck of cards 52
cards are there 52 cards are there
where 13 cards are there in one group
okay 13 cards are there in one group
now some cards are 13 cards are known as
Spades 13 are known as clubs 13 are
known as diamonds 13 are known as Hearts
okay now Spades and clubs are black
cards okay
Spades and clubs are black cards and
diamonds and hearts are red cards
diamonds and hearts are red cards I hope
it is clear now each of these group
you've got a king a queen a Jack and Ace
2 to 10 cards total 13. now what happens
there is one thing called face cards
something called face cards so in each
group one king is there one Queen is
there one Jack is there they are known
as face cards why face cards the simple
logic is because they have got faces
made on them because they have got
faces made on them so in each group you
have got three face cards in each group
you have got three face cards so total
how many face cards will be there in a
well shuffled deck of 52 cards total
three into four twelve face cards will
be there
I hope the concept is clear to every
student in the class any doubt in this
thing guys
total 12 face cards will be there
exactly
no Ace is not a face Cardinal therefore
I am saying only a king a queen and a
jack is a face card because faces are
made on them that's it simple logic is
there that faces are made on them
we'll see that Allah
okay fine
now let's do question one card is drawn
from a well shuffled deck of 52 cards
find the probability of getting a king
of red color what is the probability of
getting a king of red color
what is the probability of getting a
king of red color
so you see two red groups are there that
is hearts and diamonds so two kings of
red colors are there red color are there
so 1 upon 26 is the probability of
getting a king of red color is it clear
1 upon 26 is the probability of getting
a king of red color 1 upon 22 that's
correct
now what is the probability of getting a
face card guys tell me simple question
what is the probability of getting a
face card
so total 12 face cuts are there I had
explained the previous slide itself so
its probability will be 12 upon fifty
two four threes are twelve four runs
four four threes are twelve so three by
Thirteen is the probability of getting
face cards I hope it is clear 3 by 13
Guru Prasad exactly
we already have done mentee sessions
yesterday in which we did many good
questions
see tomorrow you can do self study I
hope you understand you cannot attend
sessions if you are having examination
the day before day after tomorrow it
will be it is not good I would say so
what is the probability of getting a
spade
tomorrow please do self study revise
every concept properly because you
cannot do attend sessions tomorrow it is
not good I would say otherwise I would
have done I don't have any problem in
that c
ok so what is the probability of getting
a spade 13 Spades are there so
probability will be 13 upon 52 so that
will be one by four probably you are
getting Spade is one by four now if I
ask what is the probability of getting
neither a king nor a queen can you tell
that neither a king
nor a queen
can you tell what is the probability of
getting neither a king nor a queen
okay others maybe it can happen like
that
so probably neither a king nor a queen
how many kings and how many queens are
there see eight Kings and eight Queen
sorry Four Kings and Four Queens are
there so apart from these things how
many cards are there 52 minus eight
right so what will you get guys 44 so 44
cards are there which are neither King
nor Queen so this is the probability yes
or no
so 11 upon 13 is the answer any doubt in
this question 11 upon 13 is the answer
exactly Lakshmi Guru Prasad
adarsh I am taking this session since 2
pm in the afternoon I think you have
joined right now others this is a mega
marathon session we have started from
the very first chapter and there are
some students who are there in the class
since the very start
okay
I hope the question is clear to every
student in the class
very good
okay
now if you have got two coins two coins
are tossed simultaneously that is the
probability of getting at least one head
and at most one hit can you tell that
two coins are tossed simultaneously what
is the probability of getting at least
one head and at most one head
see when you toss I'll explain the
outcomes in case of coins have patience
see on the board
for one coin the outcomes are head and
tail how will you write the outcomes for
two coins write the outcome of one coins
one coin like this one time and then
again write it two time write the
outcomes of one point two times not two
times right heads and two time right
tails you got it
now how will you write outcome for three
coins write the outcome for two coins
head head tail head head tail tail tail
and then again write the same thing head
head
tail head
tail
and Tail Tail now what you will do four
times right heads four time right right
heads and four time right Tails so
that's how you write outcomes in case of
coins I hope it is clear
now the question is at least one head at
least means what minimum one head so it
means one head will come and two heads
will also be counted at least one head
means minimum one head so one head will
be counted and two heads will be counted
so you see one head and two heads so
three by four is the answer
now the second one is at most one tail
at most one tail means maximum one tail
it means zero tail and one tail will be
counted zero tail and one tail will be
counted zero tail means no tail
so no tail one tail
so the answer will be three by four
again is the equation clear to every
student over here
I hope it is clear now if I ask what is
the probability of getting
at least one tail ah wait
suppose in this case for three coins I'm
asking probability of
at most one at most two heads
probability of at most two heads in case
of three coins outcomes are already
written over there
probability of getting at most two heads
in case of
when you toss three coins simultaneously
probably getting at most two heads when
you toss three coins simultaneously
so when you toss three coins
simultaneously you want at most two
heads at most two heads means zero head
one head and two heads will be counted
you got it zero head will be there one
head will be there at most means maximum
two head so therefore zero head one head
and two heads will come so zero head
means this one one head this one two
head this one one head two head two head
so the answer will be seven by eight
is it clear to every student over here
very seven by eight is the answer Vicky
I hope you understand the concept any
doubt to any student over here in the in
this session
yes 7 by 8 is the answer
okay now let us take this one in case of
dice two dice one blue and one gray are
thrown
at the same time there is a gap over
here thrown at the same time what is the
probability that some of the two numbers
appearing on the top of the dice is
seven
the first part some of the numbers on
the top of the dice is seven
of the numbers in the top of the dice is
seven
seven so how can you think the outcomes
you want some S7
so what many students do I see that they
will write out all the 36 possible
outcomes and they will pick and choose
no it will waste your time use your
logic you want some seven right sum 7
means see this is sum 7 or not one six
is possible so what you can do just just
increase one two three four
five six now you can do like this one
two three four five sum 7 over here or
not tell me any other possibility is
there or what guys I think no other
possible possibility is there for some
seven so one two three four five six six
possible outcomes are there over here so
six by six favorable outcomes six by
thirty six one by six is the probability
any doubt to any stone in this question
guys
one by six is the answer very good
rishit guide three Lakshmi I think you
must have done some one by seven you can
never get in case of two dice Sachi that
is never possible Guru Prasad that is
correct
that is correct called distiller I hope
it is clear
what is the answer to the next question
probability of getting some less than or
equal to 12 when you throw two dice
together what is the probability in the
second case
exactly see minimum sum is maximum sum
is what guys maximum sum is 12 or not
tell me maximum sum is 12 so every time
when you throw two dice together this
sum will be maximum 12 only so it will
be less than or equal to 12 it can never
be more than 12 so the probability will
be 36 upon 36 so it is 1 so basically
getting a sum less than or equal to 12
when you throw two dice together is a
sure event yes or no this is a sure
event in this case getting some equal
less than or equal to 12 in case of
throwing two dice together is a sure
event exactly that is correct now if I
ask one question what is the probability
of getting a doublet what is the
probability of getting a doublet when
you throw two dice together probability
of getting a double it
when you throw two dice together
can you tell the answer
what is the probability of getting a
doublet when you throw two dice together
what do you mean by doublet you can use
your logic very good so getting a
doublet means same thing on both data is
it will be somewhat like this or not one
one two two this is a doublet three
three these are doublets so how many
doublets are possible six doublets are
possible out of 36 possible outcomes so
the answer will be one by six
so probability of getting a doublet when
you throw two dice together will be one
by six any doubt in this question
now one more question I'm asking over
here and then we'll get go on to the
next question what is the probability of
getting a triplet when you throw three
dice together
what is the probability of getting a
triplet when you throw three dice
together
exactly Wiki what is the probability of
getting a triplet when you throw three
dice together
what is the answer in this case
let me see if you if you people are able
to do this one
although I am being very honest triplet
will not be asked but still I'm asking
only one question
what is the probability of getting a
triplet when you throw three dice
together
0 cannot be the answer I am saying three
dice together three dice together
oh I'm explaining that only Sade we are
doing those questions only sadev I hope
you understand that please don't spam
Sade we are doing the same thing very
good Phoenix
please don't spam we are doing the same
thing over here
okay very good that is correct when you
have got a triplet what do you mean by
triplet C triplet means when you have
got three dice together how will you
write the outcomes outcomes will be like
this or not one one one something like
this one one two something like this so
how many possible outcomes are there
when you have got three dice together so
the number of possible outcomes when you
throw three dice together will be this
or not tell me
for one dice six outcomes are there for
one die six outcomes are there for two
dice six into six outcomes are there so
first three dice dies six into six into
six possible outcomes are there or not
and triplet will be what triplet means
triplet means this one guys one one one
is a triplet two two is a triplet so how
many triplets only six triplets are
possible so the probability will be six
out of six into six into six so
basically 1 by 36 is the probability
probability of getting a triplet when
you throw three dice together exactly I
hope it is clear
1 by 216 1 by 36 is the answer Vicky
1 by 36 Wiki
I hope it is clear to every student in
the class
now what about this question two dice
are rolled simultaneously what is the
probability that four will come at least
once 4 will come at least once what is
the probability of four getting at least
one once when you throw two dice
together
two dice are rolled simultaneously what
is the probability that four will come
at least once
at least once means what that 4 must
come one time and four must come two
time one time and two time at least once
means minimum ones
so when 4 is coming one time guys when
four is coming one time you see
something like this or not one four two
four
three four
and you see uh three four
five four and six four yes or no so you
see 4 is coming one time over here now
guys one more category is left or not
is this category left four one four two
four three so four is coming one time
and it it can also come two times now
because it is at least once so minimum
once is there four four four five four
six
these are the all favorable outcomes so
how many favorable outcomes are there
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven so the answer will be
eleven upon 36 possible outcomes
any doubt in this question guys to any
student over here in this class
exactly option C is correct very good
that is correct
foreign
doubt in this thing to any store in the
class
please don't spam guys yes
so what is the probability of getting
very simple question masking what is the
probability of getting some
two
when two dice are thrown simultaneously
what is the probability of getting some
2 when you throw two dice simultaneously
that is not in the syllabus Deepak I
hope you understand that is there in
grade 11 this is cbse grade 10 maths
going on they are having exams the day
before tomorrow the day after tomorrow
so if I'm going to explain any concept
which is not in the syllabus of them
they will get confused please understand
about those students
one one more question is there Suman
after that we are going to end the class
right so what is the probability of
getting sum 2 when you roll two dice
together
probability of getting sum 2 when you
roll two dice together
one cannot be the probability in this
case guys the only possibility of
getting some 2 when you roll two dice
together is one and one this is the only
possibility when you will get some 2
when you roll two dice together two ah
die so yes so the probability will be 1
by 36 when you roll two dice together
the probability of getting sum two will
be one by thirty six
I hope the question is clear to every
student over here yes 1 by 36 is the
answer Shaheen probability cannot be one
in this case one is the number of
favorable outcomes divided by total
number of possible outcomes is 36. I
hope the question is clear to every
student over here
my name is misba Suman
1 by 36 is the answer fine now let us do
the next question over here the
probability that a leap year selected at
random will contain 53 Mondays is what
the probability that a leap year
selected at random will contain 53
Mondays is what
my name is Muhammad mizbal Zama
what is the probability of getting a 53
Mondays in a leap year
probability of getting 53 Mondays in a
leap year
okay Lakshmi thanks for that so you see
whatever may be a year in a leap year
how many days are there guys 366 days
are there or not in a leap year 366 days
are there out of which 52 weeks are
fixed or not 52 into 7 will be what 364
yes or no it means two days are extra it
means 52 Mondays are fixed you got it or
not 52 Mondays are fixed in a in in this
year yes or no
52 Mondays are fixed we want one extra
Monday we want 53 Mondays now two extra
days are left and we want a Monday out
of this day you got it we have got two
days left we want a Monday out of these
two days got got it now for these two
days can happen
those two days can happen in how many
manner possible how many ways possible
so can it be like this Sunday Monday
Monday Tuesday
Wednesday
Thursday
Friday
Saturday
Sunday
so you see those two days can can happen
like this or not one two three four five
six seven seven possible ways are there
for these two days to be there right so
seven possible outcomes are there now
out of these seven possible outcomes in
in how many outcomes a Monday is there
so one outcome and two outcomes so
therefore the probability is two by
seven or not tell me any doubt in this
question this is the last question only
so two by seven is the answer any doubt
in this question to any student in the
class tell me guys
any doubt to any student in the class
no a this question you will get in every
book its not that it's in oswal or any
other book right so suppose I asked
probability of getting 53 Mondays in a
normal leap year this is a leap year
suppose in a non-leapier what is the
probability of getting 53 Mondays can
you tell me
in a non-leapier what is the probability
of getting 53 Mondays
this we are talking about leap year now
what is the probability of getting 53
Mondays in a non-leap year
last question it is can you tell me
what is the probability of getting 53
Mondays in a non-leap year
exactly so see again in a non-leapier
365 days are there in a non-leapier 365
these are there out of which 364 days
are already fixed because this is 52
into 7 so you can say 52 Mondays are
already fixed in a non leap year 52
Mondays are already fixed in a non-leap
year I want one extra Monday I want one
extra Monday and only one day is left
because 364 is there
364 is already occupied and total 365
days are there so I want one Monday
and one extra day is possible for me
so that one extra day can happen in
seven ways possible or not Sunday Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday that one extra day can be any
day of the week now what is the
probability of that day being a Monday
its probability will be one by seven I
hope the question is clear to every
student in the class
probability of getting s in cards will
be 4 by 52 sadev it will be four by
fifty two four ones or four four threes
are 12 because four aces are there four
aces are there one is in every group
I hope it is clear to every student in
the class
so guys that's all we needed to discuss
in this mega marathon session I hope the
concepts discussed too in this in this
session was clear to every student and a
very best of luck to all of you if you
have prepared in a proper manner try to
get full marks in the examination don't
do anything new tomorrow please remember
that don't do anything new tomorrow just
revise all the things which you have
studied just the very first thing is
wake up tomorrow in the morning take
your ncert see everything don't do
anything just see everything revise
every formula every concept don't do
anything new tomorrow
welcome everybody guys welcome Vicky
I had already explained that sadev
I had explained those thing guys on the
infinity learn class 9 and 10 YouTube
channel we did the board brahmaster
series please check out the playlist
wherein I had discussed every type of
question after that we did
Sprint sessions as well in both maths
and science we did everything I was
taking math and devika Nam palak ma'am
and Akash sir they were taking signs we
did everything on the infinity learn
class 9 and 10 YouTube channel you can
go through those videos I had also made
short videos on the concepts if you want
you can watch those videos as well like
five five questions on each chapter five
important questions on each chapter I
had made them as well on the infinity
learn class 9 and 10 YouTube channel
okay
no I'm from Infinity learn only Krishna
thanks guys so so our very best of luck
to all of you the link everything is
there on the infinity learn class 9 and
10 YouTube channel thank you card
destler
try your best to get full marks if you
have prepared properly okay keep your
emotions in control
we have done every type of question Guru
Prasad I hope you understand if I take
doubts like that it will not be able to
be done I hope you understand that now
it will take 20 hours straight if I
start taking your doubts I hope you
understand
that every link is pinned over there
right
okay Mansa
okay guys it is pinned there Lakshmi
please check that every link is there
and don't forget to uh subscribe to the
telegram channel of infinity learn class
9 and 10 it is given in the description
because after this session you will get
the session PDF as well everything which
we discussed in the class you will be
getting in the form of PDF so don't
forget to subscribe to the telegram
Channel and also don't forget to like
share and subscribe if you have really
made your Concepts clear in this session
guys so that's all we needed to discuss
in this class A very best of luck to all
of you do your best in your examination
please don't I mean keep your controls
emotion in your control guys and have
patience you'll do your best bye bye
guys take care everybody and a very best
of luck to all of you once again